If he was debating Rob Noer right now, Rob Noer would be like
Pesco would like crank down, you know that mechanical can opener
where you like have to press down so it bites into the can and
then he's just cranking. That's what Pesco would be doing to
Rob Noer. Instead with Hutch he's like, oh this is my friend.
I'll just ask him some good faith questions. He'll engage in
good faith and we'll have a great conversation. But that's not
what happens here at all.
I think we just get right [music] into this Hutch Pesco thing.
yeah, Ethan Klein. You had some
>> Okay. Ethan Klein, you had some
Oh
my god.
I hope you guys are ready for this. The first like 30 minutes
are fairly infuriating, okay? After that I was in and out quite
a bit. I didn't really watch that much more, but first 30 minutes,
oh my freaking god.
So, basically I have this view
that I think that we need to be clear
regarding what we're talking about in this controversy.
Are we talking about
>> legal justification for a lawsuit?
Are we talking about the
ethical justification for bringing the lawsuit? By which we mean
ought the lawsuit be brought?
Or are we talking about like other
that that affect the ethical outlook? And I kind of have different
views. Oh, let's go Mad N LT. Let's go.
this is going to be a good one, okay? This is a good one.
Now, Pesco, what he's going to do at the start of this conversation
is he's going to basically
and unfortunately it just takes forever. What what's going to
happen at the start of this conversation is Pesco just wants
to avoid the most obvious answer to these questions
which everybody goes back to. It's just the laziest, most intellectually
dishonest answer, which is uh I just don't really care, man.
Uh Ethan Klein sued someone? I just don't care. I like don't
care at all. It's like, okay, well, technically you can apply
that answer to like anything and it's particularly frustrating
because when a lot of Trumpists try to dodge answering questions
about Donald Trump and the the disingenuous things he does, how
he violates his own stated principles, how his party violates
their own stated principles, what they'll say a lot of the time
is, yeah, man, I like I just don't really care about that.
What do you What do you want me to do? It's like, did he actually
make a bad law? Uh no, well, then I don't really
It's we're trying to avoid that, right? So, you'll see Pesco's
going to start to try to extract concessions on that front right
away from right off the bat, okay? Let's get into it. >> on
this lawsuit. Um and I can talk about my incentives for even
commenting on it. Um but in general I think that a lot of my
views have been
or misinterpreted to be something that they're not. And I think
that what I'm
is not actually a like a a very controversial view at all and
that most of the disagreement with my um has to do with like
perceptions about my motivations
or about relevance or emphasis. And so that's basically like
kind of my my starting set of assumptions is like, let's be clear
about what we're talking about and let's see if we agree.
And then let's talk about why it matters. I don't know if I have
a strong interest in having a conversation about ought the lawsuits
have been brought. That's not Why? That's not really the thing
that interests me too much because Okay. Why? Wait, what did
you think we were going to discuss when you came on the podcast
today? When you When we decided to talk about the H3 lawsuits
you expected us not to discuss
why they were brought? This is the first the first dodge attempt
from Hutch is very interesting. You agreed to come on to talk
about the H3 lawsuits, but you don't want to talk about why they
were
Or should they have been brought? have been brought. That's not
Why? That's not really the thing that interests me too much because
Oh, let me let me give you a point of contact, right? Because
like
>> Dude. Dude.
I don't really want to talk about that very much. Why? Uh
Why? I I session about Hold on. I got to we got to we got to
we got to just look at this. >> ought the lawsuits have
been brought. That's not Why? That's not really the thing that
interests me too much because Why? Oh, my my my my my my my Like
Like yeah, I I Why? And bro, he he's like opening with this.
He's literally opening with
I don't really want to talk about this. And Pesco goes, why?
And then he's like I'm Does he not know why he said that? Did
he just say something that's totally disconnected from his own
thought
I don't I literally from the very beginning of this I'm like,
wait, what?
Oh, let me let me give you a point of contact, right? Because
like I I I >> All right, well, let me let me That's a good
question. How could it be a good
How could it be You just said something. Why did you say That's
a good question.
You Hey, you just said you believe
Why did you say that? That's a great question. He like he's actually
like, wait, why did I say that? Wait, why? Wait, why? Why did
I say that? Hutch POV the entire thing, okay? Hmm. Hmm. Why Why
Why did I say that? Why Why What am I doing here?
What am I What am I attempting here? I don't know. I don't know
what I'm attempting. I'll go for it. Yeah. I mean I So like that
that that to me is like the least part of the interesting part
about of the conversation because like that seems totally subjective.
Like and it's difficult to unpack that, you know? Like I don't
know what I would do. Yeah. Uh does this guy realize he to a
pa Is Hutch's position that you should never debate something
that is subjective?
Because if that's the case, I suggest he delete his channel,
his Twitch thing, his YouTube all of it. All of it probably has
to go, right? He's basically arguing and by the way, that is
Everybody who goes to this front was like, oh, why do you care
about this? It's really stupid to talk about this. It's stupid
to be obsessed about this. Yeah, you're just arguing all this
entire sphere is stupid. I don't know if you know that, but you're
arguing that all of Twitch politics, all of like online political
discussion is stupid and shouldn't be focused on, which could
be true, but then you're also participating here. So, I think
we've all agreed that we care about it. And you by participating
have also agreed that you care about it. So, let's just go on
and do the thing we all were here to do in the first place,
you know? How about that? How about that? >> doing if I
if I was in his if if I was in his spot. And like you you for
example, I think you said that he has a strong case, right? So
like if if if these laws and these copyright regulations or statutes
or whatever they if they exist and somebody abused them and he's,
you know, using the legal mechanism to get a remedy for that,
then you you know, are we saying that he that that that means
that it was justified or like what what kind of angle are you
are you going for? So, you there are absolutely methods within
the legal system where you have the cause and the ability to
sue somebody and it might still not be like morally correct to
do so.
You you would have like some legal like I don't know what would
you say? Like some pretense. You you could sue someone. You have
some justification
and maybe you shouldn't. That that has to be able to exist, right?
Just because SLAPP suits exist, obviously.
Um I guess you argue SLAPP suits are
Usually SLAPP suits are frivolous. I don't think frivolity has
to do with I don't think it should if it does. I don't think
it should have to do with whether or not something's a SLAPP
suit, right? Strategic lawsuit against public participation.
You could do something that you have like a justification for,
but it is also strategically placed, strategi- strategically
done so that you can discourage public participation, which I
think is what's happening here. And you could say, well, then
it depends on what your previously stated morals are and Ethan's
previously stated morals are things like oh, like DMCA'ing people
for no reason is bad. What else would it be? Like fair use is
good. Like encouraging online content creators, encouraging people
to react to his stuff. Right? Encouraging his opponents even
to not miscontext and react to the whole thing. There You'd have
to go to previously stated principles or stated principles of
the space they operate within, which for somebody who's in commentary,
obviously you want people discussing your opinion and you want
them using your whole opinion. Like for the stated principles
of the space he operates in, obviously this goes against those
entirely.
Okay? And that's basically you have to you have to understand
that to acknowledge and understand why he's lying about his motivation.
His motivation is not to protect his copyright. His motivation
is to discourage his critics, to go after the people he feels
were crazy in going after him. Right? That's that's really what
the lawsuit is about is to discourage people who are attacking
him.
And you could say, oh well, that's that's all fine, but it's
like against his principles, the principles of his spaces. Thoughts
on Quinn Hughes to the wild? Eh, I don't follow hockey enough
to really care. To be honest with you. Sorry, man. Um okay, we
continue. >> we're here. Like do you want to have a conversation
about should he have brought the lawsuits? Well, I think that's
a conversation that a lot of people do want to have. Whether
you want to have it, I'm not sure, but I'll just to give you
a point of contact, I stopped by your stream a little bit recently
and I said hello, but I heard you talking about like the propriety
of like Denholm's statement and analyzing whether she should
have said this, whether she was throwing Casey Tron under the
bus. And so in that context, what we're really talking about,
whether it's subjective or not, listen, I take all this kind
of normative
Oh, no, that is really cool to talk about, right? To go and see
Denims reaction and to comment on that. That doesn't mean I care
about the case or Ethan's side. I just care about like these
rancid on the other side. Okay, that's all I care about, guys.
That's all I care about.
That's all I care about. I heard the Leafs are bad this season.
I don't want to talk about the Leafs right now. We're focused
on politics. to be subjective in the sense that we're just talking
about what what do you think about ethics? What do you think
ought to happen? I do think that people have a desire to talk
about the underlying ethical justification for
all sorts of things, including but not limited to legal action
taken by individuals. And I think that there's a lot of people
who care about that. And I think that you care about regardless
of its subjectiveness,
the ethics of certain people's conduct surrounding this,
the ostensible triggering incidents that brought this about,
the CPS call, the conduct of the snarkers. Like this is all norms-laden.
And so I think it's a little bit much to accept that people are
like, "It's irrelevant to talk about ethics. It's irrelevant
to talk about moral justification." Because everyone's talking
about it. And if someone asks me about it, I want to be clear
about where I stand. And the more and separate and apart from
that, I think there's a broader norm that ought be established
to like not blatantly lie to your audiences.
And all of us kind of like take do this kind of debunking [__]
when there's like with Tim Pool. It's It's like I don't even
know why >> Pisco has to discuss this. Obviously,
why would you care?
Why would you say you don't care about this when you're like
already engaged in it? Like we've seen how much you engage for
Hutch specifically in the most frivolous, like least politically
involved drama. Right? We see that. We know that. Why would you
even start down this Like realistically, Pisco is just being
kind in that he doesn't want to call Hutch just a totally lying
scumbag here, right?
That's what's happening, right?
No, well, hold on, Matt. They're friends, so Pisco is just trying
to be very, very, very kind and say like, "Hey, like obviously
you care, right?" When when it's clear he cares, he cares about
tons of drama. And now the reason Hutch is saying he doesn't
care is because it's drama on the other side of what he actually
wants to talk about. That's it.
Right? That's all. There's no real reason for saying, "Oh, I
don't care about this." No, you care about all the things adjacent
to this. You care about this case, just the other side talking
about it. I'm sure that when Hutch watches Denims talk about
Casey Tron's response, right? Casey Tron's apology, which we
could look at a little bit later. I've got the timestamp for
it. I'm sure that when
when Hutch talks about that, would he not be criticizing Denims
for lying to her audience about what was going on I do believe
so, right?
So like the idea that he wouldn't care about this or he's not
interested in talking about it, that's just an obvious lie unless
he just means, "Well, actually I'm only interested in doing propaganda
for the side I care about. I don't like them and I don't want
to have a conversation that could possibly look bad for them."
That would be more honest, right? "I do want to talk about this,
but only as a propagandist who attacks one side."
That's the only way I want to talk about it. By the way, some
people would say, "Oh, but does that apply to you?" No, I'm perfectly
willing to talk to whoever wants to come on my stream and disagree
and take the other side of the argument. There it is, laid out
openly for everybody, right?
I would I would never I would never invite somebody on my stream,
invite a conversation, and then go, "Um I'm just really tired
right now. I'm just really tired. I don't think I can talk."
That would be embarrassing. That would be like career-ending.
Well, is it accused of lying about the shooting or No one's stopping
to say like, "Huh, why are you calling out lies? What do you
care?" And now I can give you an explanation, but You're say
but you're saying that Ethan is lying about any kind of motivation
for to like protect his IP?
Or do you call it IP or copyrighted content? But but but you're
but you're saying that that's a lie because the real motivation
is just like personal grievance. But why can't it be both? I
don't understand why can't it be like that. And and I definitely
want to
But the conversation I'm having is >> it's I it's to me
it's very obvious that he's motivated by both. Because like he
he's already on the record as being someone who was trying to
bring attention to what he considered to be like lazy react content.
And what what what the three people that he sued did went even
beyond that. Like it was beyond just like lazy react content.
It It was That's not true. That's not true. Denims was not lazy
react content. This is I hope I hope Pisco just points this out
that that's obviously not true.
As Like this is already you have to you have to be and I don't
want to call it lying here because he might just be saying what
he thinks, right? Because he's not looked into it very deeply.
But this is you have to automatically be not telling the truth
to feel like you're justified in having this opinion. >> We
might say malicious in nature. You say that has no like bearing
on the case, this like malice or whatever.
but but but the fact remains that that they were being malicious
about it. Like they were they were they were openly
that they their intention was to siphon views. And
it happens to be the case that all three of those people were
doing were participating in an internet pile-on that was like
some of the most vicious behavior from online communities that
I've ever seen.
Okay. So, this is broadly what the conversation's going to come
down to is I think there's this nebulous thing where Hutch really
doesn't Hutch really doesn't like the behavior from these communities,
which is like honestly like a massive
um massive
what would you say? Like decentralized network of influencers,
viewers,
like message board posters who talk about this stuff. And
the the collective entirety of their actions Hutch feels is bad.
And what I would say is if you feel like the collective entirety
of somebody's actions are bad and you want to punish somebody
who's who participates in that in a very tangential sense or
even a like in a non-direct sense, right? Like let's say with
the CPS call. Um Casey Tron, I don't know how much she participated
in in CPS getting called,
If you want to punish Casey Casey Tron because of the CPS call,
how valid is it to punish her to the maximal extent?
Right? To try to enact like financial ruination on
because of her participation on a side that did the CPS call.
Is that reasonable? And then you would ask, "Okay, if you're
allowed to enact punishment on somebody based not on their actions,
but on the actions of some group they belong to, doesn't society
kind of disintegrate? Isn't that like totally against American
principles? Isn't that totally against like liberty and personal
responsibility? Doesn't that like totally conflict with so many
of your actual principles?" And the answer has to be yes. So
then why are you applying it here? Would be the question.
in all my years of being on the internet. Like what they how
they behaved around the whole CPS thing was
Now, for me personally,
This is going to ring hollow. Oh god, we have to let it keep
going though. Wait, I'll back it up. Give me 2 seconds. I just
need to grab something. >> that I've ever seen.
in all my years of being on the internet. Like what they how
they behaved around the whole CPS thing was
It was vicious. And so like I think he was motivated by both
of those things. Like was it right to bring the lawsuits? I don't
know if I would have done it, you know, but I understand why
he did it. I don't know if that's a cop-out answer, but I understand
why he did it. Yeah, so I I just want to make sure we're not
talking past each other. So I I definitely want to have a conversation
about ought he have done it. But before we get into that, I just
like want to make sure that you think it's worthwhile
even have that conver I like So we're we're not even talking
about the thing itself. It's like people will question
why do why should we care about these ethical oughts and whether
good or bad. And I thought I was hearing something approaching
that critique or that observation from you. And so before we
get into like the actual meat and potatoes, which I I do fundamentally
reject the view you just presented on different grounds. I I
want to make sure that you consider that conversation to be valuable.
It would be depending on let me give you a word of insight here
because like Like intellectually,
Dude. He's basically saying, "I don't want to have this conversation
with you." And then actually at the end of it, when you lose,
you go, "I don't care." Because that seems to be the very obvious
thing that happens every single time. Somebody like loses a debate
on this topic, they start losing, and then they go, "Uh I don't
even care anyway. Why do you care so much?" Pisco is trying to
avoid that. And Hutch hinted at that when he said, "I don't really
want to talk about it."
So Pisco is trying to ask you questions about what you actually
value in the world to make sure that having this debate could
be fruitful for both of you. Because if you say that it's like,
"Oh, I don't care if people lie. I don't care about calling people
out who lie." Although Coller Gate like seemed like he was pretty
mad. Like I'm pretty sure we could go through Hutch's transcripts
on Coller Gate and just say, "If somebody asked him why he's
obsessed." I guarantee you could get an answer of like, "I just
think it's bad when people lie. Is it wrong for me to point out
an influencer lying?" Right? Pisco is asking the guy who spent
700 hours on Coller Gate, "Hey, don't you think it's like important
to call out an influencer when they lie to their audience?" And
Hutch is like, "Yeah, I don't know if I really think so. Yeah,
I don't really know if I I don't know if I really believe that."
It's like, "No, you do. We're just trying to Please just acknowledge
reality really quick so we can continue with the conversation."
be valuable? What do you mean? So people [clears throat] will
say things like this, "Pisco,
this is a boring conversation. Who the [__] cares
about whether these lawsuits were the right thing to bring or
not?" Or like I don't really Or someone might say something like
I don't care whether it was right or wrong to bring the lawsuit.
And I just want to make sure you're not proposing those views
of like indifference. Like maybe you are indifferent as to whether
it was right or wrong to do. But
Hold on. So it At Jidion so is Hutch consciously aware that I
don't care is his escape hatch and he knows what Pisco is doing
or is this all reflex action? I had some combination it's very
hard to tell because I can tell when Pisco asked a question like
an open-ended question to Hutch or like a sorry any yes or no
question to Hutch.
Hutch will immediately become wary because he doesn't he can't
think of where that question's going to take him. So really it
seems like a lack of second-order thought, right? Where Hutch
doesn't want to answer a question because he can't foresee when
he says yes or no to that question where that goes, right? He
doesn't understand where it goes in the conversation after that.
And so while he can answer that question
he if he says it he because otherwise he would just answer like
what he feels, right? Like realistically you should answer what
you feel and then discuss like talk through it. I'm totally comfortable
having those conversations most of the time. I know I have some
beliefs that don't jive with reality sometimes. I'll just say
what I feel and then I'll talk through what I thought and cuz
I just feel confident that I usually have a fairly good thought
process and I can figure out where the holes are in my thought
process. But Hutch is not treating Pisco like somebody he likes,
is friends with, understands, and cares about. He's treating
Pisco like Pisco is
like him and Pisco are debating for the 2024 sorry 2028 presidential
nomination and Pisco is like the actual
like or actual communist in the group. Like I if I mess up ever
it's all over. It's like dude that's not really the case, man.
Pisco's your friend. Like just talk. Just talk. That's all you
got to do, dude.
You like you think that that's a worthwhile conversation when
analyzing especially um now this is getting a little bit into
the argument itself but I I still do want to have the meta conversation
first of all to sure that we both agree this is a valuable conversation
that we want to have. Um for someone who presents a lot of his
lawsuits or his legal stuff as vindicating some broader interest
either in a particular group or in a broader
I think that we ought care about whether we agree with the assessments
being uh rendered by
Ethan and Co.
It's not that I'm indifferent. It's It's more than I'm
Ethan and Co. How is he so consistent? How does he always find
a way to get this face out? Bro, what is happening?
What is this one? Hello?
Hello? Hello? Hello? I'm uploading that like eight times to the
Discord. Hutch is a deer in the headlights. What is this reaction?
Does this even make sense?
What is Pisco saying that he's reacting this way? >> Um
for someone who presents a lot of his lawsuits or his legal stuff
as vindicating some broader interest either in a particular group
or in a broader
I think that we ought care about whether we agree with the assessments
being uh rendered by
Ethan and Co.
It's not that I'm indifferent. It's It's more than I'm agnostic.
What? I So you use these lawsuits as like vindication of Ethan's
side entirely, right? Even though they're technically copyright
not related.
Is there something else going on? Like I I Okay.
Like I can I can you can indifferent and agnostic are similar,
right? Um agnostic is acknowledging that you don't know. Indifferent
is saying it doesn't matter. So agnostic might be like people
agnostic being agnostic most obviously to me means like your
belief in God. I think being agnostic means you are understanding
that you do not have the capability of answering the question.
Indifference is saying the answer doesn't matter. With God it's
like obviously that answer matters tremendously. It's like ton
of human history is just based on how do you answer that question,
right?
Like I I do think they're different. I do think they're different.
It's not that I'm indifferent. It's It's more than I'm agnostic.
Like I can I can you can Maybe that sounds like a cop-out answer.
Like I want it both ways. Like I It's not that I'm avoiding taking
a firm position. It's just I can understand why he did it and
I can't tell you if I would have made the same decision because
I've never been in that position. I've never I don't know what
it's like to have
So this is Co because I believe like this is Hutch's entire job
is to go through things like this, right? To look at the circumstances
such as they are and then for him to provide an opinion based
on what he can see and you couch appropriately,
right? You You couch
Yeah, agnostic is orthogonal to how important the topic is to
you. Exactly. Like Like yeah, but you you could believe you could
believe God you could Okay. You could believe it's really important
to know if God exists or not and just still be like I don't know
though. But I don't know.
And yeah, you could be militant as in like I'm I'm going to cut
Like if you say you know, no you can't know. You can't know.
But decision because I've never been in that position. Yes, is
entire Sorry, I was lost my train of thought. His entire thing
his entire
business on the internet is taking circumstances and then caveating
it appropriately for those circumstances to say in this case
given these factors here's how I would act. Here's what I think
is correct.
That's your job. That is literally your
But So if that's literally your job and not only is it your job
but you do that job effectively in nearly every other area. You
have no problem ever making these kinds of declarations in any
other area then what am I to believe when you say that you can't
make a decision here? To me it's that you do have your personal
opinion and it doesn't jive with what you want to put out publicly
and so you've reached like a deadlock and you cannot put that
opinion out That Unless he has a better explanation that would
be what I see happening here.
I've never I don't know what it's like to have children and then
have government called to your home
to like try to force you to justify
that you should be allowed to continue to have guardianship over
your own kids. Like I don't know how I would have felt in that
moment. I don't know what kind of actions I would take after
the fact. Um but I am and I'm also sympathetic to the idea of
like I mean that must really suck to to be bogged down in that
kind of litigation. It's not like I have no sympathy for people
like Casey Tron or or Frogan. Like even though I find their conduct
to be pretty disgusting what they did with Ethan and Eileen and
how they were joking about the CPS calls and you could argue
that Denims helped to enable it with the way that she was running
her chat on the particular day that that topic came up. Like
to me that can't be the line for holding somebody responsible
saying they did CPS so I'm suing them. One, like key to this
all will be that Denims literally sent a retraction notice like
a what would it be like a not a cease and desist but a letter
of intent to Ethan saying hey, I think you've defamed me here.
Retract the statement and Ethan did retract his statements about
Denims,
So like the idea that Denims is responsible for CPS has been
like adjudicated essentially.
Like Ethan retracted his say him saying Denims did CPS he retracted
that. So trying to hold her responsible for it seems kind of
crazy to me. happen. Um but even with all that I'm sympathetic
to like I feel like I mean I wouldn't want to be in that kind
of a situation but uh you know, I don't know that it's going
to be satisfactory for you but I just I don't know what I would
do in that position. I really don't but I understand why he did
it. I I don't I don't take I don't think there's anything inconsistent
with you saying you're agnostic on the ethical question but also
maintaining that it's a worthwhile conversation to have. That's
what I'm want like the I want to say those are distinct questions.
Whether or not you have a firm view about whether it's good or
bad is different than whether or not you think it's a conversation
that the conversation about whether it's good or bad is worth
having. And what I want to avoid
more than anything is someone after the fact saying who the [__]
cares about this [__] or like you saying I don't
even give a [__] about the conversation. Like clearly
you care. We're having this conversation. It's maybe like the
third or fourth time we've had a conversation about this. You
You have a vested interest and you can tell by the way Do you
Do you not have a vested interest?
Um man, is anybody Is anybody talking about this? Why is Hutch
Man, Pisco's really nice.
Hutch is like trying to make it look like Pisco is like saying
something stupid. Why?
He's not saying something stupid at all. Huh. I'm just going
to be honest. You cover some of the other conduct at issue
This is This is the performative ignorance, right? Where he's
like oh I don't I don't actually know. I don't actually know,
man. I don't know. It's dude. What did I tweet? I tweeted like
right before I went live.
It's uh I don't think anyone can have a contentious conversation
with Hutchinson without a moderator present. He employs a performative
ignorance so often he employs performative ignorance so often
it makes any attempt at extracting a concession impossible. At
least he'll look sympathetic to people not paying
You give an example of him doing this? Well, I'm not going to
say anything to this guy. Hold on. Or who the [__]
cares about this [__] or like you saying I don't
even give a [__] about the conversation. Like clearly
you care. We're having this conversation. It's maybe like the
third or fourth time we've had a conversation about this. You
You have a vested interest and you can tell by the way Hold on.
I need to get Was it this one? Makes eye contact. Here we go.
That's my response. That's That's just the only response we can
have here, right?
Like he's just consistently signaling to his chat that he has
no idea what Pisco is talking about. I don't even know what the
[__] What is this guy saying? What is this guy saying?
Is this guy saying something? Why is he pretending that I have
a position that I don't have.
That's a Dude. Uh and Pisco's sitting here like not not actually
acting like he would. If he was debating Rob No right now, Rob
No would be like Rob No would be disemboweled like piss like
he's a [__] can of tuna and Pisco would be a hungry
cat, okay? Rob No would be like he Pisco would like crank down,
you know that mechanical can opener where you like have to press
down so it bites into the can and then he's just cranking. That's
what Pisco would be doing to Rob No. Instead with Hutch, he's
like, "Oh, this is my friend. I'll just ask him some good faith
questions. He'll engage in good faith and we'll have a great
conversation." But that's not what happens here at all. >> tell
by the way, I'm just going to be honest, you cover some of the
other conduct at issue here that you're weighing the respective
normative weight of what the parties are doing. You're thinking
about is it good uh for Denims to throw Casey Tron under the
bus? Is it okay for, you know, Hasan [__] to not
donate? And so I I think it's a little much to accept that this
is a conversation that the ethics of bringing the lawsuit Okay,
who cares about that? Yeah, there you go. Oh, you care about
this. You talk about what's ethical in terms of this drama all
the time. Why would you pretend you don't care about this one
specific thing, whether or not it's ethical for Ethan to bring
the lawsuit? But all the other aspects, uh you know, the ethical
assessments of the other conduct, that stuff is interesting to
me and I will comment on it. So just to be super clear, I I do
want to get into the actual the question here and then and let's
also talk about the other issue, the legal issue, whether I think
it's important or not. Um and the and the line I think this is
gay. I think it's So I think it's gay as in to say I lose respect.
I think it's just all you point out is I personally what Hutch
is doing here where he pretends Pisco's he's trying to make Pisco
look unhinged,
I think that is intentional or bordering on it it's intentional
enough that Hutch
like even if this is maladaptive. Let's say Hutch does this because
he
he just knows he has to survive. Let's say it's maladaptive.
He doesn't even really he's not conscious. He's just doing it
naturally. Well, it's still happening, right? It's still
And it is [__] over because I guarantee you we'll
watch this. There's going to be some points in this conversation,
okay?
basically I think Pisco is trying to get Hutch to like agree
to anything and he starts saying some stuff that like strains
it it sounds absurd, okay? Based on where this goes in a little
bit. And I think Hutch pushes him to that by not being willing
to engage in anything he says by doing the performative like
ignorance the whole time, okay?
And like we'll we'll keep going through it. We'll keep going
through it, but I just I feel like Pisco sort of had some character
assassination happen here from Hutch's side that I don't know
if Hutch was intending to do it, but Hutch did do it. And I just
wonder if he understands that, right? Like on a very real level,
does Hutch understand that he is making Pisco look really bad
because he refuses to even try to engage in a hypothetical? And
Pisco goes, "Well, here's why that's important and here's why
the idea of like just letting it go would be bad." Like Pisco
has to be very very meticulous in going through why he has to
ask the questions he does because Hutch refuses to engage. I
assume for sure that you think that this is a valuable conversation
or one that at least that you're interested in. Cuz if you say,
"I'm not interested about whether Okay, no no but I want If you
Again, meaning cuz Pisco's actually engaging rigorously in the
conversation.
To me, when somebody does stuff like
so Pisco doesn't have to gear down, right? If this was like Kleiman
or me,
I'd go, "Okay, I'll dumb it down for you, you stupid
right?" But Pisco doesn't have that like, "Oh, I'm going to I'm
going to go low now. I'm going to take this guy's knees out now."
Right? That comment right there is perfectly indicative of everything
I'm saying where Hutch is going, "Oh, you take this really seriously,
bro. Are you Are you serious?" Like you're taking this really
seriously. Are you mad right now, bro? Are you mad? "Oh, I want
whatever you want, man. You're getting really worked up over
this." Like when I hear that, I go, "Okay, well, I'll bring this
down to a more colloquial level. I'll bring this down to a less
rigorous level and I'll just start calling you a F-slur, okay?
Let's do that. Let's I'm down for that." But Pisco doesn't have
that gear down. So Pisco keeps engaging honestly cuz Pisco's
sitting here like, "This is my friend. This is my good friend.
He's going to help." Right? He's going to He's going to engage
with me. You want what I want. I I I just want you. Like this
is what I want. I want us to agree that this conversation it
matters. It matters whether or not Ethan did the right thing.
It doesn't it matter to you? I don't know how to evaluate that
in an objective sense though. [laughter] >> That's what
I'm saying. I really don't. I This is such This is such a messy
thing for me like But with Hasan, we know how to evaluate that
in an objective sense. It just comes down to like group think.
Um I've got a lot of people a lot of weight behind me that say
this is the way it is. Right? It's all subjective. Whatever my
side says, that's correct.
Like I can't I don't think I can give you an answer of like this
is unequivocally bad or this is a universal bad thing. >> no.
No, that's getting into the meat about whether it's good or bad.
That's a separate It's like how many how many moral questions
have an unambiguous yes or no always good always bad question
to
Cannibalism doesn't. Murder doesn't. Maybe Is it like is the
only thing? I No No, it's not the only thing cuz technically
if you if you wanted to continue the human race, you know, it's
the far uh hypothetical from whatever, right? If you wanted to
continue the human race, you might have to use people to, you
know, carry children to continue the human race. If every single
woman opted out and said, "I'm never having kids again." Do we
just let humanity end?
Like that's a that's a non-obvious answer, right? Murder? Well,
war. Cannibalism? Well, you're stuck at sea and you draw lots
and some of you guys have to be meat now. Right? All of these
questions have like an actual edge case where they could be answered
and said like, "Oh, there's like So when he says, 'Oh, there's
no objective answer.'" Like obviously there isn't. I'm asking
you about this situation,
right? This situation
in this specific circumstance,
what are you thinking? That's the entire purpose. When you say
there's no objective answer,
that's what
Of course there's no objective answer. There never is. question.
I'm I'm being very precise here. You care
whether or not
like you care about the conversation. You care about um the relative
arguments. You care about thinking regarding whether this is
good or bad. And I I think that's clear. I mean, if you're really
going to say, "Well, I spent all this time talking about the
ethical implications of Denims' conduct, of Hasan's conduct,
of the Snarkers' conduct, but I'm And we get a redeem of Jay
Sock doing the Hutch voice. I can't even remember what Hutch
voice I've done multiple times now, okay? I can't remember, so
I'm not doing it. >> if you're really going to say, "Well,
I spent all this time talking about the ethical implications
of Denims' conduct, of Hasan's conduct, of the Snarkers' conduct,
but I'm not going to consider the ethical implications of Ethan."
I can consider it. It's fine. If you If you have a case to make
in terms of like why you think he shouldn't have made the case,
then then I'm genuinely open to being persuaded. >> Awesome.
No, no, that's that's the Okay. So why did you fight the whole
time? Like like now Hutch has heard something where he understands
what his position will be and now he but this is the this is
the indication that he does not have Oh, how would you explain
it? He doesn't have the spark is normally how we talk about it,
okay? He doesn't have the spark. So in this case,
he can't do like dynamic synthesis and so now he's been asked
a question in a way where it ties into something he's heard and
and thought about before and come up with like the answer before,
okay? So now he answers in the exact way Pisco was trying to
get to get him to, but the synthesis isn't there for him to hear
the questions before this and just go, "Yeah, obviously if there's
like a good enough question, like I'm I'm game for this." There's
There's a universe where you could convince me that it was a
wrong thing for him to do, go for it. >> No, but no, just
just because I get shared uh these people who who really don't
get it and they're making comments like, "Who the [__]
cares?" Like, "Who asked Pisco? Who the [__] asked
whether this is good or bad?" Like you guys all care about this.
We all care about these norms. And the proof is in the pudding.
The fact that we spend any time on it Dude, how does how does
caring about Hasan's
Hasan's dog's collar? How does that help us win midterms, bro?
Would Would Hutch ever expect like accept this answer this this
like answer to any question?
Hey, uh I think it's really bad that Hasan lied to his audience
about the collar. Uh but how does that help us win midterms,
Hutch? How does that help us win midterms, man? Oh, that's like
a stupid That's a stupid answer? Okay, cool. Yeah. The fact that
people feel vindicated and feel that this is just desserts. Just
desserts meaning these people deserve what's going on. That is
Hasan always good? This is actually a case of like where I'm
totally fine with Hutch going into that collar thing because
he thinks Hasan's lying. Yes, if you think he's lying, if that's
what you want, right? If that's what you want to do. You think
it's You think the best thing you can do for Democrats is to
prove that Hasan is bad. Okay, that's
I said that when we covered it. What I didn't like was him pretending
that he had other motives. Hasan is bad. Hasan is bad. That's
He just pretended he had other motives, which was goofy. If he
thinks that the best thing he can do to serve Democrats in the
midterms and going forward is prove that Hasan's a more power
to you, buddy. Go for it. Just don't pretend it's like something
else. Don't pretend it's like
Don't pretend it's like just a little drama offshoot.
No, it's like a whole moral crusade. is a normative conversation.
It's saying this ought have happened. It's good that this happened
to these people and this is uh deserved. This is either a punishment
or some kind of um retribution or some kind of like uh justice
for Ethan. And that is um intrinsically invoking normative assessments.
And so what I don't want to hear is this kind of like banal statement
that you get from the Redditors that are like, "Who the [__]
cares? Who asked about the ethics? As long as long as it's legally
viable, that's the only thing that matters." That is cooked,
agreed? That is cooked, agreed? Just slop job.
We got Mr.
Oh, I can't think of something to make it like Willie, but he's
just a slouch out. He's just mouth mouth a gay.
What's cooked? The notion The notion that the only thing that
matters is the legal argument. The only And this is coming from
someone who obviously cares a lot about the legal argument. My
own My whole reason of examining this in the first place was
because it was a a new copyright case, and I have a an interest
in copyright, and I've been following h3 for a while, and and
even their first case, and I actually, you know, really praised
them. And if you watch my coverage, I really praised them for
their initial lawsuit defense against bold guy. Um but as someone
who does care about the legal argument
Someone saying like the only thing that matters is whether or
not it's legal or not, and whether or not they have a good case.
No, no, no. I mean I Yeah, it's like it's interesting conversation,
and like I'm So I can I can just lay out very clearly to you
the the
the pro case, like the bullish case.
Bro, the Reddit thread on this is so funny. Hold on. Wait, there's
a Reddit thread on this?
Wait, what Reddit? The Reddit I'm thinking of?
No way. The case The case for for this potentially being an appropriate
action. And then And then you can tell me your case, and we can
go from there. But >> clear, this is not the a view that
you necessarily hold, it's one that you want to put out. >> I
have it. I have I hold the I hold I hold the view, but but it
But again, there's a like there is a conflict in me. I'm just
being 100% transparent. On that No, you think it's a good thing
that he brought these lawsuits against Denims, Casey Tron, and
Frogan, correct? I think I think a good outcome of this happening
Ask Hutch a question. It's a It's good that this happened, right?
Well, I think a good outcome of this happen That's not what I
asked. That's not what I asked. It's literally not what I asked.
Okay, well We'll watch
Can somebody watch that real quick and tell me when we hit that
point in the debate? Wherever that clip is from, we'll go read
the comments when we actually see that point in the debate.
is And it's going to be really important that we actually watch
this because, like I said, I think I commented in some Discord
I was in. I I commented that basically at some point Pisco says,
"Well, it's technically possible, like it's logically possible,
that you jump to the
Like he says that to be hyperbolic, right? And say that technically,
if we bring no other system in, if we don't bring any of our
other thoughts in, if you told me you just jumped to the moon,
I've no way to doubt you. It absent other knowledge, okay? About
like how physics works and all of this.
it's super super super funny.
But I As soon as I said that, I'm like, "Oh, Destiny's going
to watch this and react to it." And then when that gets said,
he's going to like he's going to go like
And he's going to get up from his desk. He's going to walk away.
I can't I can't I can't.
That's what's going to happen, right? I can just see already
how it's going to get like hyper performative immediately.
They're the Denims chat in this conversation. Oh, okay. Dude,
the Well, yeah, we'll go through it. Bro, it's just all emotional
signaling because when people want to go through and discuss
the actual facts of the matter, they understand that they're
cooked, right? The whole time? Like
Basically, we're going to go through the Denims thing. And the
Denims thing is her chat was saying, "Oh, we should call CPS."
And she was basically just vibing,
And it's like, "Well, we have to hold her culpable for the CPS
call." And it's like, "No, what you probably have to hold her
culpable for is not moderating her chat when they were saying
something that was a little silly, like a real-life action that
shouldn't be
She should probably call that out, or her moderator should call
that out. It should probably get moderated, right? But that's
That's the end of the the culpability. That's the end of the
the condemnation. You don't say she's responsible for CPS because
that's Anyway, the possibility that creators in that space will
do more to moderate their own community. >> Right, but
do you understand that's a different question? >> that
I That's the value that I stand for. So that is a potential That
is an argument in favor of Ethan taking this action. Did it have
to be this litigation action, or could it have been a different
action? I don't know. But like that That is the strongest case
that I would make is that these these
existed in a world where they were >> Oh, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Real quick real quick comment, though. Jesus Christ,
I knew he had tankie justical freaks in there, but h3 stalkers,
too? Talk about a hive of scum and villainy.
I think I'm the only person from my own Discord who's talking
in Pisco's Discord. I didn't talk in his chat. I talked in Pisco's
Discord. Or if I left a comment, it was like right at the beginning
and never again after that. >> Don't beat. Oh, Space Ghost,
thank you for the gift and sub. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Like how am I getting blamed? I just I talked in his Discord,
and I said basically if you say, "Oh, why does he care about
this?" it's because you disagree with him, and you're too scared
to actually step to him in the in the like VC, right? That in
the comment above started the cancer in me just now. I've been
an ardent Pisco defender this whole time, but this might have
blackpilled me on him. He was being so bad faith the whole debate.
I try to keep reminding myself of the good times through this
whole thing. Hold on. He was this exact same way with Destiny,
though, all the time. This is like This is peak Pisco.
Reminder, when Pisco is like, "Hey, I don't think it's appropriate
even if somebody steals blades of grass from your lawn, I don't
think it's ever appropriate to shoot them." And DGGers were like,
"No, shut [screaming] up, Pisco, you loser." And I know that
cuz um I was on the other side of that debate. I basically thought
like like basically if somebody's stealing from you consistently,
you have the right to shoot them, okay? That was my thoughts.
But I know that there were people even more extreme than me who
were like, "Destiny's right. You get to shoot the guy who's stealing
blades of grass. You do. You get to shoot them."
And Pisco's like, "No, I think it's never I think it's always
bad."
So I don't know why people are pretending that it hasn't always
been this way. It has. It has. They're totally emboldened. They
felt like they had They had total impunity. They demonstrated
no sense of responsibility for moderating their own communities,
and in some cases they explicitly or implicitly egged on I would
just ask, "Hey Hutch, did you see any Frogan clips with regards
to CPS?"
That's That's what she needs to ask right away. "Hey, have you
seen a single clip from Frogan with regards to CPS?" Cuz I don't
know of any. Personally, I would expect her to go, "Oh, that's
fine. Decline."
But I actually don't know. Pisco's just riffing at this point.
Like I at least got a girlfriend out of it. These comments are
crazy.
I think regardless of regardless of who dates who or who who,
listen, maybe maybe this is too By the way, let's not talk about
how unhinged or crazy it is to say somebody's changing their
opinion based on [__] someone cuz certainly we would
We never want to say that, right? When when I point out that
Destiny became way softer on conservatives when he was [__]
Lauren Southern. That's something that's totally unhinged and
crazy, right?
But if you want to imply that Pisco doing a podcast with Shoe
on Head means he's like totally sympathetic to
Okay? Like I Or that Pisco was, you know, dating a somebody who
is more left-leaning, right? And you say that's affecting his
opinion. I I would just ask why, and I would I would wonder why
that's relevant to this conversation. But people like doing that.
People like saying those things. Little crazy. Yeah. This kind
of what I view to be like significant harassment. Like it is
to me a really significant form of harassment to do a CPS report,
and then that ends up with a like government intervention. That
to me is so much more significant than the litigation. A malicious
CPS report?
That's worse than the litigation?
Um hmm. Do we think that's the case? I don't think so, only in
that like
The problem with the litigation is the litigation comes down
to what's his actual reason for doing it. Was he
Right? I don't think he was harmed. That's the real problem with
a lot of the litigation is I don't think he was significantly
harmed. I don't think it's outside the norm of what he would
expect normally. I think he set that up explicitly to try to
harm these people
Certainly, I think you'd agree that within the context of their
lives, the the specter of that litigation, Casey Tron losing
her house, losing her house that she keeps her disabled family
members in and takes care of them, right? That's far worse than
the individual CPS visit to Ethan's place.
I think we could agree there 100%. Then it comes down to, "Well,
who deserved
And then you have to start discussing like what happened there,
right? We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. That is based either
on lies or distortions, things like that, right? Like you wouldn't
say You You wouldn't say like a CPS report by itself is um bad.
It's when it's informed by either lies, distortions, or exaggerations,
right? They had a vendetta against
by bad stuff, either lies or or or bad motive, some kind of So
it's not just a mere calling of CPS, it's calling CPS on a basis
that is um improper, such as trying to hurt someone, not actually
being concerned about what's going on, uh you know, including
lies. [laughter] I like where I like how Pisco twisted this.
Hey, but like calling CPS is bad when it's like for a different
motive, right? Like using that thing disingenuously for a totally
different motive. I think we can agree that's bad, right?
>> And whatever you're telling CPS or exaggerations or
things that you can't be reasonably obtained. Yeah, okay. They
crafted a narrative about him and Ela that they were these ultra-Zionist
genocide supporters. Okay, it was a full-on mass psychosis event
for that community with a collective audience of hundreds of
thousands or millions of people. And in that collective audience
pool, they crafted a narrative about Ethan and Ela. Number one,
that was just a total [__] lie.
And but number two, that that narrative that they delusionally
all convinced themselves
was was true, at least maybe some of them did. But there were
Wait, doesn't that undermine Hutch? If If really thought it was
true, doesn't that make the CPS call justified? >> There
were that there was also Hey, you see how he caught himself there?
He was like, oh wait, hold on, if they think it's true, then
that call would be justified and oh [__] an element
of like bad faith to this as well. And so like I think they wanted
to believe that about him. So it's possible maybe the person
who made the report, you know, like got themselves to believe
this lie about Ethan, but the whole point is like it was fostered
by those creators. They had active role in
Okay, Frogan and CaseyTron had an active role. Every time he
says they, I feel like you should if you're responsible, say
did each of them have an active role. I understand what the blame
on Denims is because I saw the totally disingenuous clip that
got Denims,
I saw that.
Okay, he's saying like what role Yeah, you just have to ask what
role did they play? Cuz he's saying I think this is the case.
And of course it's the case. Now, were they a part of one side
of this thing where both sides were, you know, quote unquote
harassing each other? They're doing a lot of like they're saying
a lot of mean [__] on the internet? Yes. Is that
normally done under the auspices of, okay, you can say [__]
but don't do [__] You can say [__] but
don't do [__] Don't touch the poo, don't engage in
real life, don't do things. This is internet [__]
talk and if you want us to be able to engage in internet [__]
talk, you cannot go to somebody's real life and try to [__]
with them, okay?
Is there any evidence that one of them wanted something done
beyond that? Right? Outside of the normal online understanding
of don't touch the poo.
go and put somebody's real life in a way that isn't just online.
We're talking [__] on the internet, we're we're making
arguments on the internet, but do not bring it into the real
life sphere. making a mock of the whole situation.
They by what do you mean? The the the creators like fostered
this in their own >> Like intended for them to call CPS
or what did you mean? They had they they helped promulgate these
lies about Ethan and Ela. Okay, lies. And in doing in in doing
so Well, did you say what lies? >> no, I said okay, lies.
So I'm under so the how they're fomenting it or how they're fostering
it isn't with a specific intention for a kind of action, but
100%
Okay, go. I'm not saying that, but but but in the case of Well,
here's the thing is Hutch's argument works against like his current
nemesis, his current number one enemy on the entire internet,
which is apparently
um random people who don't even stream in my Discord who talk
about his case occasionally. Okay? Hutch's Hutch's example works
perfectly for that, right?
But it's obviously totally outside of it's the complete opposite
of what is stated in the Kephals manifesto, it's the complete
opposite of everything Destiny stood for online up to this point.
Like obviously the creators can't be held responsible for one
individual person and if you had any evidence of who it was and
they banned that person, then you have to let them go. Like they're
obviously they can't mind read their audience, yeah? And when
when there's a big vitriolic back and forth, you can't expect
somebody to like totally and say like, well, listen guys, um
don't make jokes about this guy being a bad parent cuz his kids
were eating [__] Don't make that don't don't do that.
Like obviously there's a whole thing online where it's performative
and we're going back and forth and we're going to take whatever
you say and say whatever the [__] Yeah.
it's so I I would agree with you that basically every aspect
pre 2024, January 2020 sorry, pre January 2025, yeah, it goes
against this, but we'll see we'll see what the response is. I
would have to go back in cuz it's been a minute since this drama
kicked off. This is like a year ago or a year and a half ago
when the CPS stuff happened, I don't even remember. But with
Denims specifically, she was um watching like a BadEmpanada
video where he was doing these and you know you would agree that
BadEmpanada is a malicious actor, right? Like just one of the
worst malicious actors in the entire space, right? I mean, that's
my understanding of his reputation. I um have seen him uh do
things that I would consider to be malicious and so my answer
is yes.
Like he will lie. Like he will lie, you know, he will call people
pedo. Okay, Pisco, so my understanding is yes, he's a bad reputation.
So what Hutch should hear here if Pisco's friend is the following.
I have not seen that conduct directly, but I understand this
is reputation and I don't want to like stand on this because
I I don't know, so I'm going to trust you on the reputation,
we'll move forward with this. But what Hutch hears is, oh, you
don't think BadEmpanada is bad?
Uh excuse me, you don't think BadEmpanada is bad? If your takeaway
from what Pisco just said is, you don't think BadEmpanada is
bad? Then you are a you are a like deaf, dumb, blind r-
shouldn't be consuming this content. Actually, you shouldn't
really be consuming any content politically. You are a Trump
supporter who happened to fall into a camp that is blue. Okay?
You have no internal monologue, you have no internal thought
of your own. You just happened to roll into a Democrat like a
Democrat audience and a and a Democrat thing online. But if you
had rolled into the Trump camp, if you if you rolled bad on spawn
and grown up in like West Virginia or Georgia, no, maybe not
Georgia, West Virginia or Mississippi, you'd just be a Trump
supporter. You're a r- Stop engaging, stop pretending you have
the capacity to engage and just [__] off. at a file,
he will he will lie. Like his his whole thing is he thinks that
it's justified. >> content. I understand that's his reputation.
I've seen instances, for example, It's not just his reputation,
he has a storied history of lot like maliciously lying about
people that he identifies as enemies. I'm just telling you my
uh what I have access to. What I have access to is I know he
has a reputation for malicious lie. Now, if Hutch had like reason
to believe that Pisco was coming in bad faith to this conversation
and was saying like, oh, actually um yeah, also him. Yeah, I
mean, I'm going to have a hard time not bringing this whole thing
up when he's like reacting to Destiny when Destiny's posting
like full doxes in his Discord or sorry, in his chat constantly.
I think I think probably all of these arguments fade away and
seem not very serious, but that's me personally, okay? It's just
me personally. If Hutch thought Pisco was coming in bad faith,
he would do exactly this because you want to think you want to
say, oh, well, you're pretending not to know, but here's I'm
going to say what really happened here, right?
And so that is my only takeaway from this is Hutch must think
that Pisco is pretending to not know anything about BadEmpanada
to play defense for him. lies. I know he has a reputation for
doxing um and for >> Yes. saying stuff and I know that
they have their own justifications for it, you know, publicly
available stuff, but but I kind of have a different view on on
that issue and and I think that there are self-standing harms
and stuff that he engages in. Uh for example, uh regardless of
whether or not it's technically publicly accessible, I think
that certain kind of revelations of information, even publicly
available information can sometimes I think uh be considered
norm violating. And um yeah, so and and I've seen him make certain
connections that I I find to be malicious. I can't recall them
though as I sit here and I'm not going to claim to know more
than I do.
Let's put it this way. Hassan So Again, H- Pisco just said, okay,
I take it he's got a very bad reputation, let's move forward
and Hutch is like, no, you don't get it. >> had a no BadEmpanada
video policy at one point because That's what I mean, he has
a reputation for this kind of stuff. >> he had even acknowledged
that BadEmpanada was completely deranged and unhinged. And it
wasn't until BadEmpanada started doing like anti- Very interesting
words. >> Ethan content and like I guess pro- Palestine
content that that Hassan just consciously decided to to to forego
that or to get rid of that rule and then he started platforming
BadEmpanada repeatedly over and over again. Knowingly, knowing
that he that BadEmpanada had this like like very unclear record
of malicious behavior. Yeah, so And then people like people like
Denims was watch watch this BadEmpanada video about Ethan and
if you again, it's been like a year and a half at a but like
her chat on the screen that day when she was watching this video,
they were all doing like CPS talk and and it was just like she
was making no effort to moderate. Would you agree >> feel
she has an affirmative obligation to do that, right? Of course,
don't you? I'm not sure what the standard is for so if people
are calling for CPS calls in the in the chat, I'm not sure that
I would um moderate those opinions. If if they have the opinion
that would you? 1,000%
Okay, I mean, I I don't have the >> Would you? 1
1,000%
Okay. Dude, so so so performative.
It's so performative the whole time,
man. Been a year and a half. Dude, it's
It's just it's an insane performance just to try to make It's
try it's to try to have anything but an honest conversation,
right? That's very it's transparently what he's
Totally transparently what he's doing. The CPS chat got debunked,
right? Well, debunked, I don't know what you mean by debunked.
There were people in her chat calling for CPS to be called and
but it was the thing is everybody thinks it's so bad because
of this disingenuously edited clip
which was put out and promulgated, which shows basically like
a wall of CPS CPS CPS CPS CPS call CPS now. But realistically
it was like a it was I think it was like a message every 30 seconds
or something that said something about CPS.
Right? Um yeah, we have I have like all the clips as well for
this, yeah,
It's just goofy, man. Uh I think I think I might have somebody
else. Okay, speaking of unhinged and deranged and
I don't know why I did that. Uh that was rude. But um somebody
else is watching and they asked if they I want a second mic.
I'll take a second mic.
I'm just vibing, okay?
So we'll see we'll see if somebody else hops on. 1,000%
Okay, I mean, I I don't have the you would, come on. If you if
you had people in your chat that were like, I don't know, Hutch
seems kind of dodgy. I think he's like beating his beating his
his uh fiance. I think we should call the cops. Hey, can you
hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you. What's up? How's it going?
Number one hater, crazy deranged stage three snarker >> signing
on.
Sorry, I I said that and I'm like, wait, I don't like it when
people say that even jokingly about me. Maybe I shouldn't say
that. It was like a total joke though, obviously.
I mean, yeah. If but if you said it in my chat, I would ban you.
If you even mention the word CPS, I would ban you.
I'd probably report you, to be honest, to Kick and Twitch and
get you deplatformed cuz it's that intense.
It was
Dude, I >> for saying that as well. Like when this had
just popped off, I said that like it only is obvious to us now
that all of those comments should have been moderated, but because
we know what happened. It's not readily apparent to me that prior
to the CPS actually happening that those comments would be taken
seriously. They like I would assume people were joking, obviously.
>> Cuz like like and people say, well, Denims didn't disavow
it. Well, no, Denims did disavow it because her entire response
was like literally don't engage with people IRL. Like there are
better things you can do with your time. Don't go [__]
with them IRL over internet drama ever. For no reason should
you ever do that, right? That was her takeaway from it. I think
she did some like sort of apology around, well, I think they're
really young and maybe it won't [__] them up or something.
She did some stupid comments, but but realistically it was don't
ever do this. And that's how most creators are. I say it all
the time. Don't ever engage with somebody in real life because
of something they said on stream or some stream drama. It's insane.
So, if Denims was operating from that place, like that state
of mind, she might have seen that happening and not even thought
to go, oh no, that's stupid, cuz she probably says that's stupid,
right?
That's how most people look at it, I
>> But it's one of those things that it's like, well, now
only after this do I know it can't be joked about because if
it happens or whatever, even if you don't say it, even if you
disavow it, people will say that your community is responsible
for it. Just because there were jokes in your chat that you didn't
Yeah, and I I mean I watched Hutch blame the Hasan community
for it. When Hasan came out after it happened, it was like, guys,
that's insane. Ethan's a good dad. Don't [__] around
with that [__] okay? Never do that. That's so crazy.
Like Hasan was so unequivocal in how he denounced it that it's
like not even
>> You know what I got her? >> Totally racist, yeah.
>> No, no, well, no, no. Ethan makes a story that says,
I appreciate him condemning it, but unfortunately
the the other comments that he's made contribute to a culture
that allow people to do it. So, it wasn't enough. The disavowal
and even saying he's a good dad, it's still not enough.
It's like you get like a battalion who like throws down their
weapons and surrenders to the other side and is like, we we're
really we have like an actual moral like problem with what they're
doing. We can't be on their side anymore. We surrender. And the
allies make like a whole show of like publicly torturing and
executing them. It's like, no, no, you should probably encourage
people from the other side to change their opinion and say this
is like morally reprehensible. Don't just execute them. Don't
say it's never enough. You should actually when somebody makes
a good decision, you should acknowledge that and encourage
But you know, it never happens.
Or you could launch a lawsuit against three different creators
just for just to for the hell of it and to scapegoat them because
you can't get them for defamation or harassment or anything
No, but you you do have to admit, okay? People think this is
the greatest gotcha. You have to admit he was allowed to file
that lawsuit, right? You you really have to acknowledge that
he he truly he truly can file a lawsuit. Can't argue that. >> his
god-given right as an American. He can file a lawsuit. Hold on,
even goes beyond that though. He actually it goes beyond that
because he technically
will probably win that lawsuit. At least against Casey, he's
almost certain to win, right? That means it's okay. That means
it's good. That means extracting that concession the way he did
is good.
Obviously. Oh, yeah, 100%. And this is all about protecting
smaller creators, the the little guy versus the big guy. And
this is about
Yep. Yep. Yep. 100%.
I'm going to hit play here. I have to go turn my light on in
front of my house. Give me one second. You would. Come on. If
you if you had people in your chat that were like, I don't know,
Hutch seems kind of dodgy. I think he's like beating his beating
his his fiance. I think we should call the cops. You feel like
you don't think you'd have a responsibility to jump in and be
like, no, hang on. >> sure. I I What I'm telling you is
I don't have that intuition that I that like that this is an
expectation or Hold on. Let's be real though. In that case, in
that specific case, there would have to be a video of like something
that gives you at least plausible reason to say Hutch might be
beating his wife.
Right? Cuz the thing about the Bad Empanada video, while I think
calling CPS based on that video is crazy, like I I think it's
wrong to do, I do think it's not wrong to think, well, this guy,
why is he talking about his kids eating dog [__]
That's like weird. I'd never do that. Like
Right? Like I do think that's a little
And I think like believing some stuff based on that, it doesn't
take you very far to get like realistically
is this not analogous a little bit to the Nick Fuentes situation
with Piers Morgan where everybody says, well, why did Nick talk
about it in public if he didn't want that story discussed? It's
like, okay, well, why did Ethan talk about his kids eating [__]
if he didn't want people to talk about his parenting?
Right? Would these not be totally equal things? You're a victim
blamer if you say that it's incumbent upon creators to be mindful
of the personal information that they share and not spend all
of your time disavowing the CPS and the skulls and chastising
people for making light of it. That's how these people see Well,
here's the thing though. I agree with that a little bit in that
I think any creator who's like actually advocating to call CPS
based only on that and not any other information is probably
bad. Yeah. But like I I do think there's like some element of
like Ethan
it's stupid of Ethan to discuss it,
Yeah. And people get really mad when you say that. It's like
obviously it is
Obviously. This is like no different to me than criticizing
Keffals for what she later admitted to in these like leaked messages
by somebody else that she was being swatted and doxxed repeatedly
and she was going around posting photos of her like herself,
like selfies of her of herself in different locations. And she
said, oh yeah, like I was trying to like egg them on to see how
fast it for like how long it would take for them to do it. Like
incredible stuff. And like I don't think Ethan was doing that
was was saying that to like bait people into it. I don't think
that at all. But it's the
like people weren't crazy for having for criticizing Keffals
before those messages were even leaked to say like, are you like
are you rage baiting at this point? Like why would you if you
if you were running into this problem repeatedly, why would you
not take all avenues to minimize the possibility of it happening?
No one's saying it's fair. It's just what has to be done in order
to try to mitigate that. Yeah, 100%. But people people just don't
want to have like an honest conversation about it. It's It's
very frustrating. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what to I
mean, it's it's also weird to me that like why is it incumbent
upon Denims to not react to videos that are within Twitch terms
of service to react to, but it's not like why why go after Denims
at that point? Like not only is does it obvious to me that you
should criticize Ethan first and foremost for even putting that
out there for it to be like mocked and ridiculed cuz he's
but then why not go after Bad Empanada? That would be like let's
pretend Taylor Lorenz works for Media Matters, okay? And she
makes it her life's mission to deplatform Nick Fuentes, but instead
of starting with deplatforming Nick Fuentes, she starts with
deplatforming creators that reacted to Nick Fuentes and platformed
him  or didn't sufficiently push back. And she targets
Hutch and she targets PeaseGo cuz they reacted to Fuentes and
they didn't push back enough. Nobody would ever find that noble
or understandable. They would immediately say, why are you going
after the creators reacting to him instead of just going after
Fuentes himself if that's what you want to do.
So, why not go after Bad Empanada? I don't get it.
Yeah, well, I mean, go after people based on what you can say
they're responsible for. That's like a crazy thing, right?
Apparently that's a crazy though. I I hate to do the war analogies,
okay? But it's like so obvious.
War analogies?
Yeah, well, there's like the whole Trump thing. A whole bunch
of liberals get like really mad when Trump said we should bomb
terrorist families. It's like, yeah, I think it's bad.
And I can even I can even say cuz I'm a heartless bastard, okay?
I can even say, not unlike Casey Tron, I don't give a [__]
if some terrorist families get bombed, okay? If it keeps people
in America safer, I don't give a [__] But I think
it's a bad precedent to set because you're like the keepers you're
like the leader of the free world, right? Yeah, like if you if
the US position itself is like
the we uphold the rules based order. Yeah, you can't do that
even if it's effective. Yeah. If you're especially so Ethan literally
trying to I thought trying to present himself as the good guy.
A lot of people presenting him as the good guy here. Realistically,
I think that what it boils down to for everyone in this situation
is I I get people to concede this. At least every debate I've
had on this, I just get them to concede it. It's like so you
just think Casey Tron's like a rancid and you just wish any any
bad thing that you could wish upon her, you wish upon her. It's
like that's basically what they have to concede, right? Most
of the Is at least that like that's really what drives them.
It's not what she actually did cuz they can never talk about
what she actually did. They're just like, she was a part of something
crazy and I think she should feel the full brunt of whatever
whatever we can do. But even then it's like, but why is she a
reactive or a rancid and they have a hard time substantiating
even that?
Like there was somebody who called into Pisco's stream the other
night and he was like, "What have these people done?" And one
guy literally started with they like Hassan and then he was like,
"Okay, I'm sorry. I can't do this any" and ended the call.
Uh yeah, yeah, I can see it. Um I can see it. >> that's
going to be your answer, you have to just stand by it and say
it with your
Like their sin is that they they orbit Hassan and they've made
a career off of like, you know, dick riding and I don't like
it.
Yeah, I I want like her house taken away. I want her I want her
disabled parents on the street tomorrow.
Because they [__] around and find out. >> It's
good times. It's good times though. It's awesome. You know, W,
huge W. They're normal that um you have an affirmative obligation
like I have deranged chatters say totally unhinged stuff. Like
for example, you know, they should be kill Mar uh Abrego Garcia.
They should be throwing all these illegal immigrants into the
waters and um that's their, you know, political opinion or that's
their their norm-based opinion. I I don't know that I um
I I guess that it's I don't know if I share that interest. Now,
if it's actively calling for such things that occur, everyone
call CPS. Uh you know, maybe that's different. Maybe that's or
if they're saying you should not people Okay, then then then
I would say then I say I [laughter] have an affirmative obligation,
but then you have to like you have to answer the subsidiary questions
and I do want to take a step back in a second because I think
that in the weeds in a way that I'm I'm concerned about uh and
I'll tell you Uh you have to then see like she saw that and like
she No, no, no, no, no. Yeah, no, no. Sorry. Sorry. I didn't
mean Yeah. Yeah, so so like I I think the nature of the obligation
depends on what the uh you know, what the expectation is to read
chat. Like often I don't read my chat, but like I want to be
clear. I think that there are affirmative obligations to prevent
your chat from encouraging illegal conduct, encouraging false
things, encouraging, you know, government associated things.
That for sure. But an opinion for example is So I'll I'll give
you the following thing. I think it's justified for CPS to be
called. Should that be moderated? In a in just in a general >> censoring
this particular in this particular sense. Uh it seems based on
this that like they're eating poop and they have a wrong opinion
which I I think it's the wrong opinion is to >> No, no,
wait, hold on. Sorry, sorry. Are you talking specifically in
this context or just general
So I think this is already where Pisco loses every single person
who's already involved in this drama at all. And I thought, "Well,
while I understand it's important to stand on this sometimes."
I was like, "Oh, like letting yourself get to here, this is rough."
Cuz while this is true, I do think like, "Hey, you watch that
video, you get the this impression." Like it's not crazy to think,
"Oh, this person's a really bad parent." based on what's in that
video. Now, yeah, Bad Empanada is a liar, all of this thing with
all these people, right? They they think all these like Bad Empanada
is a liar and it's all But like even if you just watch the Ethan
clips alone, it's not difficult to go, "Oh, if I like believe
this, it's really rough."
And Pisco's arguing arguing the truth here, but man,
I I I watch this and I'm like, "Oof,
you know, at least
morally, he's making probably the correct argument. Tactically
though,
I don't know what you thought. What did you think?
It's one of those things that it's like trivially obvious. If
you ask people, "Okay, is there ever a time or a scenario that
you could conceive of where somebody could say something online
that uh like sounded like it endangered somebody or it warranted
contacting the authorities, the police, CPS, some sort of government
agency for the well-being of somebody?" They'll probably say
yes, but then every single instance where it's like, "What about
this? Would you have done it then? What about this?" Most people
will say
In reality, the reason why a creator should not be mobilizing
calls to action is because it's like if brigading is against
TOS,
then people probably shouldn't be flirting with the realm of
like encouraging IRL action against stuff that's online when
there's no way to verify
what's hyperbole and what's fiction from what's not or what's
a bit and what's not. And we're dealing with the uh this thing
called the general American public which already has a very low
median IQ. So you don't need to encourage anybody to do this
cuz some will do it without even being asked to.
So that's why we don't need to encourage it. It's one of those
like like you're like what Pisco is saying. It's not crazy for
somebody to see that clip and think, "Oh, I need to do something."
And not even bother to verify, "Wait, is what Ethan said true?
Is that the only way to contract giardia by consuming feces and
human feces that that is that really the only way?" Definitely
not, but unfortunately he said that. Yeah, but like yeah, exactly.
>> could allow you to contract giardia. Like literally
just playing with the dog, you technically could contract giardia
from that. And he just said some stupid [__] where
if people like say it
it's or if people take it seriously
that would be concerning. That's scary. >> true, but like
again, you have to basically optimize your content for the lowest
common denominator unfortunately. And if you say things like
that, even you don't even have to be the lowest common denominator
for people to be like, uh what the Yeah.
Cuz whether or not that's true, he made it sound like that his
kids were eating
I can't remember it specifically I saw even though I saw the
clip earlier today so gross. If he was talking about like uh
human poop or dog poop, but he literally said that. I'm pretty
sure he thought >> never play that clip. They will only
ever play the reactions to it.
It's it's unfortunate that he put that out there and I don't
think he should have a CPS called on him, but it's like
uh man. I The thing is they'll go over the reaction like the
Denims reaction to this stuff and even with Denims reaction,
I don't think her reaction's like inappropriate
at all. Somebody's like, "Oh, um it's no surprise he doesn't
care about Palestinian kids when he doesn't even care about his
own." And she goes like, "Oh, what are we even doing here?" It's
like I know what that reaction is cuz it sometimes it's like
I don't want to take like a solid position on that and say yes,
but I'm like, "Oh, it's kind of [__] up." It's like
it's like a nothing reaction. And people are like, "Oh, she clearly
supports calling CPS." Hutch argues that, right? Based on her
going, "What are we even doing here? I don't even know what's
going on." It's like I know what that That's called like I know
that reaction. It's like I don't want to I don't want to say
no, [__] you because this guy's an [__]
but it's like kind of a little bit I don't really want to support
it either, so I do nothing. Like a nothing reaction.
Go ahead. >> It's literally when people yeah, read a chat,
they get to the end of it and they're like, "I don't know about
that one." But they don't want to disagree with their community
or chatter, but they also don't want to co-sign it, so they kind
of just pivot to something
Yeah. And pretend like they didn't just read that. Yeah, 100%
and that's like what she was doing there and I just like, "Well,
there you go. Boom." She she didn't thoroughly condemn the guy
who said he didn't care about his kids cuz he or it makes sense
that he doesn't care about Palestinian kids cuz he doesn't care
about his own kids. Like, "Well, listen to that clip. Is it fair
to assume he doesn't care about his kids? When he says, 'Oh,
my kids are eating dog shit.'" Is that kind of fair to assume
that? If that's the only context you had? And then him acting
like an [__] to your the people you care about? Those
are like the two pieces of information a lot of those people
are operating off
It's I don't know. It's like an interesting conversation to have,
but holding Denims responsible for the actions of someone you
don't even know is in her audience that day is just
I don't understand why it never comes up that somebody from the
H3 audience could have done this. Um maybe. Would you bet on
that? I think it doesn't come up cuz it's like, "Would you bet
on that?" It's like, "No, I'd probably bet on somebody who like
doesn't like them." Well, I would I wouldn't bet on it, but the
thing I think it gets at the assumption that the reason why anybody
would be motivated to do it is because of editorialization surrounding
the clip and not just the clip itself, which is a false assumption
to me. Cuz the clip itself is disturbing enough. Nobody needed
to tell somebody it's disturbing. It's already disturbing to
99% of people. That's why they don't play it because it makes
Ethan look really, really bad and it makes their defense of him
even harder. So they never play it. They just play the reactions
and they just focus on the CPS stuff being called and like post
hoc rationalize the rest of it. Right? >> yeah, I don't
know if it would make a difference for them. I agree with you,
but I don't know if I I I think if you played it for people,
a lot of the people who are like in Hutch's audience, they'd
already be sympathetic to Ethan. They'd go, "Well, I would look
for more information." It's like, "Well,
but would somebody hearing that for the first time or would somebody
who's in an audience that isn't favorable to Ethan, would they
just go, 'Oh, he's like a total monster.'"
I don't know. I Yeah. I would say it's it's highly improbable,
but it's not if there's a non-zero chance because there's just
literally no way to know who could have possibly done it. And
Ethan himself
said that the CPS agent who was dispatched to their house and
spoke to them said that the person who made the report was somebody
close to them apparently, which Ethan obviously said, "I don't
I don't believe that and I'm not familiar enough with how easy
it is to lie on like an anonymous report to CPS in the state
of California, which I looked up and you can do. So maybe that's
the case, you know, maybe. Um but realistically, just anytime
you're reacting to the clip, even if you say, "Don't do it. Don't
don't contact CPS or whatever." Just by showing the clip, you're
increasing the likelihood that somebody could act on it because
of the contents of the clip itself.
I think that's Hutch's first argument. Isn't it just crazy to
ever watch a Bad Empanada video?
Isn't that But then he's like he I think at a different point
cuz I saw parts of this already, he says like, "No, no one from
my audi" He was like, "If you reacted to it and you even said
don't, but like there's still a chance cuz you're showing it.
That that could increase the likelihood of it being called, right?"
And he was like, "No, that like that couldn't be ascribed to
me cuz I would disavow it." And Pisco's like trying to explain,
from what I remember, like, "Dude, does it matter that you disavow
it or you discourage it? Somebody in your community could disagree
with you and still do it of their own volition."
And honestly, that especially in these
uh especially in these super what would you say? Like sides scenarios
where there's like half of the internet's on one side, half of
the internet's on the other side. There's like a chance that
somebody in these Denims audience who is like passively consuming
this stuff a lot and already had a very negative opinion of Ethan.
And even if Denims had gone, "Oh, no, don't never call somebody."
There's no reason to think that they're like a full-time Denim
supporter and they care about that more than the how much they
dislike the or dislike Ethan, right? So, yeah, exactly. It's
like there's no reason to assume that her strongly disavowing
that and banning the chatter who said it the first time would
have actually made a difference. And so, that's explicitly why
when you look at the blame for for those chat messages, it's
like you can blame her for a lack of moderation, but you can't
blame her for the CPS call. Like it's it's stupid to say, "Oh,
well, she's Even better. For even more. I looked I looked up
her stats today. She averages 3,000 viewers and she has moderators.
And I don't care that she's like I I'm a like 70 viewer Andy
on Twitch and then like an 80 viewer Andy on YouTube sometimes.
And even I don't catch all the messages and I have mods. Like
I just I just can't. So, I can't imagine what it's like having
an audience of 3,000 people where the chat's going faster.
It's I'm not saying it's like Hasan levels of like it's flying
by or whatever, but it already becomes unmanageable to like like
basically impossible to read every single message when your community
is that size.
Yeah, no, it's it's very tough. Um Hutch will argue that she
reads every message. I don't know how true that is. We'll see,
I guess, when we when we get there. That is what he argues eventually.
She reads every message. It's like I I don't know if she was
doing that at this time. Especially not if she was covering Ethan
stuff. Cuz the Ethan stuff, anytime she's covering Ethan stuff
for drama, I'm guessing she went up significantly in views as
well, right? Yeah. Oh, wait, here's the real thing that he should
have asked him, but he didn't. The real question that would have
tested this if he's truly consistent on like having this level
of community responsibility.
Let's say that following the Collergate stuff, Hasan somebody
contacts animal
they know Hasan's address and says, "Kaya is being abused." Animal
control shows up. Kaya's taken away from Hasan because of city
ordinances within LA or wherever he lives, right? And then he
goes online and he says, "I had my dog taken away because of
a clip that was dishonestly circulated on the internet and it's
because of people like Hutch, it's because of people like uh
so-and-so and so-and-so and so-and-so and it's their fault."
They're the ones their communities are responsible for this because
they were the ones covering it and not giving me the benefit
of the doubt and somebody from their communities did it, so I
hold them responsible. None of those people, including Hutch,
would ever accept any responsibility
for the individual who contacted animal control and got the dog
taken away. None of them. >> Well, and then and then let's
say after that, he retroactively like registers one of his streams
with the Library of
and sues Hutch for like Hutch covered a lot of his streams. I'm
guessing there's a lot of violations.
Sues him for like hundreds of thousands of dollars. Bankrupts
him. Would it be appropriate that he did that?
Well, yeah, because [__] around and find out and
you have to understand how emotional he was at the time and uh
you know, who wouldn't who who amongst us wouldn't launch a lawsuit
like this if we had the money and resources. You have to understand.
Seems to be the same case. We just don't want to play these games
of like you're responsible for everything your community says
and the things that you miss and it's incumbent upon you to like
overtly
disavow things that you dis loudly disagree with and disavow
everything that you see in your chat that you don't like or like
moderate that. Nobody actually wants this. Because again, what
do you want to bet?
Mhm. Just with that argument, it's always the significantly bigger
community who makes that argument against a significantly smaller
community. Like it's You can only make that argument when you
have the public on your side. Like if you don't have the public
on your side, everybody just laughs at you for looking ridiculous.
But when you have the public on your
then everybody goes, "Oh, well, this person's clearly correct."
And the funny thing is is anybody who's in this space who's aware
of like the Keemstar's manifesto knows that that's precisely
what happened in that situation, right? "Oh, well, this this
Destiny community is like responsible for all the harassment
going to Keemstar's." And they're like, "No, obviously we ban
anybody who if you showed us somebody who's explicitly harassing
you, we'll ban them. Like we have every policy here set up to
deal with that. And if you never ever report them or if they
like if they're just using anonymous identities, how could we
possibly say it's our fault? How could we What can we do?" We're
just like It's like a totally disingenuous line to take, right?
So, I don't know. It's It's obviously you can't be responsible
for your audience the whole time. And it's something you only
argue when you have the entire internet on your side because
if you don't have the entire internet on your side, you just
get clowned on. Like these guys do have the entire internet on
their side, so they get to make that argument all day, it seems
like. Even with The sad thing is even
the obviously edited clip that everybody saw the first time.
That like Augie saw the first time. I think You might have been
here when we showed it to him for the first time. Augie was sitting
here with us and he was like, "Oh, I thought Denims really did
this." And it's like, "Well, here's what she did." And then he
watches the real clip and he's like, "Oh. Oh, that's crazy. I
can't believe this is the way I feel like everybody's going to
see it that way and Yep. like the when they go back and see how
it was edited, they'll go, "Oh, [__] Wait, that is
actually way more understandable now."
Yeah, generally. Like are you saying >> let's do an abstract
first and then we'll go to this this context, okay? So, in general,
if someone said, you know, there isn't this massive um whatever
you're characterizing as a wave of of harassment against Ethan
Klein and this someone in your chat says, "I don't know, this
is kind of [__] up. I think that some that someone
should call like I think it'd be justified. I'll I'll put it
there." If it's If it's a good If it's a good faith observation,
sure. That's that's what I I obviously. >> Yeah, so I we
can Well, hold on. Hold on. If I can't apply my subjective standard
to it, then sure. That's another thing people do here that's
very frustrating. They like want to inject their subjective opinion.
They they never want to present any like stand standardized or
um like objective rubric for how to evaluate this kind of behavior,
right? They always just go,
you know, when you see it, well, I think it's really crazy what
they did. Well, you know, as every single time." They just want
to inject their own subjectivity and it's very frustrating. >> person,
I would have simply like inserts like course of action that obviously
is being recommended because you know what happened. They're
they're saying >> something that anybody would be plausibly
thinking. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
with that. But then the nature of what the message is and whether
she read it, I think matters to me. Hutch I do want to say though
I want to take a step back, right? Like like this is all stuff
that I think indicates that we care deeply about the ethics of
people's conduct online and that we're you know, we're we're
interested enough you know, we had the conversation about Taylor
Lorenz, for example, on the chorus stuff. And all of this matters.
That's that's kind of the base root here. That said, I want to
be clear about whose conduct we are assessing, right? Cuz it
could be the case that the conduct to call CPS I do believe that
it would be that it's immoral, incredibly immoral to call CPS
on the basis of what Ethan said regarding the Giardia stuff.
I think that's unhinged. I wouldn't do it. I would condemn people
who would call CPS on that basis. Um and just because though
that is unethical, doesn't mean that everything in response is
also ethical, right? So, we I want to make I want to be clear
about whose conduct at every stage that we're talking about we're
analyzing. Who Who do you want to analyze first?
Well, we can't analyze Ethan's actions in a vacuum though. We
have to evaluate the Whose actions do you want to evaluate first?
Uh I just need to preemptively sweep for Ethan. It's just a funny
instinct for Hutch to have. I just need to preemptively say,
"You can't just be unfair to Ethan, okay? Before I You want to
be unfair to the other people, that's fine. But like just I ground
rules, do not be unfair to
>> know if you've made this observation already, but there
I noticed that like Pisco tries to start with abstractions and
hypotheticals to sort of lay the groundwork for principally where
he's coming from and how he's approaching this. And Hutch was
like >> IQ to understand hypotheticals?
>> that Hutch just doesn't want to engage with the hypotheticals
and would rather talk about the specific instances. But then
when they start to get to the particulars in the specific instances,
he's like, "Why are you taking it down to these like particulars
and the specificity? Zoom out a little bit more." And it just
felt like, "Okay, so there really is no way that you're comfortable
with analyzing this because it's like if you don't want to do
the hypotheticals cuz or you said they were disanalogous, but
then wouldn't explain how they were disanalogous. You just said,
"No, it can't be compared to that." But then we started drilling
into the brass tacks of what happened even in the specific instance,
it's like, "Oh, this is reductio ad absurdum. This is pettantry.
This is uncharitable." So, pretty much it like any like he just
it felt like he didn't want to engage with anything that wasn't
going to lead to Ethan being on top or being in the >> Yeah,
no, it's like transparent that that's what that's like exactly
how this goes the entire time. It's a very interesting like case
study in bias, like online bias. Yeah, very interesting. >> Totally
agree to that. Yeah. >> what is our like what is our dependent
variable? What What are we trying What is the ultimate focus
of our inquiry? Are we trying to figure out whether it's right
or wrong for Ethan to bring the lawsuit? Or do you want to spend
some time to build that to talk about various different actions
that different people took regarding Ethan? You had asked me.
I mean, I I was giving you my argument
um why litigation
um could be justified. Could be a justifiable response to what
happened. Okay, so And that's that's where I'm coming from with
it. >> start with Keemstar, right? It's justified to sue
Keemstar for copyright infringement
because
I I would assume you would say A, she committed copyright infringement,
right? Uh you tell me, you're the you're the lawyer here. >> presumably
you wouldn't be in favor of I feel like Hutch absolutely sees
that as a trap question somehow. Like you could just tell there's
no second order thought going on at all that he hears Pisco ask
a question, he's like I don't think I can answer that. I think
I'm going to get caught up. You you do agree that this is like
yeah, there's definitely copyright infringement going on here.
I don't know if I can answer that. >> I just every time
it keeps happening. >> if you didn't think that she committed
it, right? No, if it was frivolous, no. And and I I want to ask
you because I first of all, I don't think any of these cases
are frivolous. I just want to be make that 100% clear. Anyone
who says it's frivolous, that's wrong. Why would you be against
someone bringing in a frivolous lawsuit in this >> Maybe
I'm I'm a bit like a purist about the system that the system
shouldn't be used in that kind of way. I don't I don't know.
I'm just in two minds about it in this context, you know.
Except in this instance when it's absolutely being abused in
that way.
Well, it's it just comes down to like my general rubric for this
is very simple. If you want to extract an apology from Keemstar
for her copyright infringement, that's fine with me, right? If
that if that apology from Keemstar ends within 30 seconds and
she just goes, "I really apologize for copyright infringement.
I said it was I said this was misogynistic and like it's clearly
not. I actually violated his IP. Thank you for everybody for
paying attention." And then she ends it. I'm like, "Okay, she
he extracted a concession on the actual problem and he just wants
to move on." Then I'm fine with it, right? I don't really care
that much. But it's that he clearly this is just a yet another
piece. Now, I still think the the like the preamble, the sorry,
the um the preceding thoughts are still not clear and he's like
clearly lying to his audience or the preceding hot thoughts are
still that he just wants to sue them for drama. But then he extracts
a concession on drama. It's like as long you used a lot the legal
system to get I guess justice for the the way you were wronged
under the statutes that apply, I don't care. Like that's fine.
To me it was weird that he included like Asmongold's mom and
HasanAbi,
right? That all shows that's more that goes to proving that Ethan
didn't really care about the intellectual property infringement.
Like the the violation. >> just that, but also that he
knows he's fostered a community that doesn't even
like making him keep up the appearances
of trying to pretend that this was about copyright infringement.
Because you didn't even have any as far as I know, I didn't see
it. Maybe it exists somewhere on the internet, any significant
portion of his community be like, "Hey, what the [__]
I thought this was about a win for IP and protecting creators.
What? I feel so blindsided by this. It seems to be about settling
personal like nobody thought that. Nobody said that and it was
because everybody knew it was transparently and flagrantly never
about that in the first place. Cuz if it were, he would have
exhausted every single opportunity before advancing it to a lawsuit.
He would have used Twitch DMCA tools. He would have tried to
get them suspended potentially if he thought it constituted some
sort of like egregious copyright infringement. He would have
sent a demand letter. He would have sent a cease and desist.
Like you would do everything that you can to avoid
Yep. Yeah, and I I think that's a good argument for people will
argue like, "Wait, don't do you think he like didn't have the
right to do a lawsuit?" It's like, "Well, I think there are other
tools for dealing with this kind of thing before this." And I
think he basically invoked a way that's never been used before
in this exact like venue. He uses like the RIAA, the the uh what
is it? Recording Artists Association, whatever. Um that they
used to sue like Napster people, any peer-to-peer sharing network.
They used sue like individual people who downloaded like one
song, right? It's like you downloaded six songs, actually we're
going to sue you for like $30,000.
And it's like that to me when you're trying to do the totally
disingenuous like damages, like the suing for totally disingenuous
damages that aren't aren't even remotely in scope for what happened
to you.
it just shows again that it's it's not about your harm from copyright.
It's not about anything else. You just wanted to hurt these people.
It's just it's very clear. The whole the whole way through, just
every every aspect of it the whole time. And the fact that like
that's what them even arguing about the minutia of the CPS calls,
it's total because that happened in March of this year and Ethan
in his own videos where he talks about I'm suing these creators
says, "Oh, I registered this back in
January comes before March, way before any of this happened.
Yeah, don't forget. I do believe it's the end of February when
the right? Am I crazy? When the CPS calls? I thought it was the
end of February. >> Whether it's end of February or beginning
of March, it's not like he did it all the way back in January.
So that like that had there was no inkling or that hadn't even
I don't even think the clip that ended up being used for that
had existed yet.
The very funny thing is is that even beyond that, I believe after
the CPS call,
he then registers his stream because he decides he's going to
sue Denims. Yeah, cuz I think he looked at it and he knew that
like it might actually be
Yeah, he registered Yeah, he registers the stream after the fact
because she share reacted that knowing that oh, her [__]
might be transformative and I do want to [__] her
up. So it's not just my edited video, I'm actually going to sue
her for my stream and walking away as
Which is just so >> she was allowed to share react to that
whether she knew it or not, I have no clue. But if I were her,
I would absolutely use this as a defense which I'm pretty sure
she did. He had opened the IP to that particular podcast.
Oh, why? What did he say? Because he said he wanted to clip industrial
context and that he wanted to have the same thing that Hasan
had. And so he said, "The only thing I will copyright strike
is if you try to upload like members only content. But short
of that, go for it. I'm not going to enforce IP on those." So
he he doesn't even like I like him registering that after the
fact was like, "No, even that." Again, applying Ethan's own standards
and potentially even legal ones cuz I remember Pisco did a stream
where he looked at some cases where like people that had made
like the guy who created Pepe the frog, right?
He said he made statements like, "Oh, anyone can use Pepe for
whatever reason they want." And then Alex Jones and other like
like people on the affiliate with the far right started to use
it and then he started trying to like enforce IP against it.
But the their lawyers argued, "No, cuz he already made these
statements that he doesn't care about enforcing IP. So when my
client used it, like his claim to trying to say it's infringement
now is completely stale." Yeah, I think there's going to be that
is probably a better argument. I think there's also some argument
about implicit license with Ethan consistently like reacting
back and forth with Um like creating that dynamic as well. But
I think that's a that's a better argument at least for the stream.
So it's very interesting.
Yeah, we'll see we'll see exactly what happens. I don't know
if that defense of share react though would be the only thing
I'd say. I don't know if that defends the share reaction in the
same way. I don't know if that's explicitly opening up the IP
entirely to just like watch on your stream. I don't know. But
there are also a lot of streamers who do watch all of that [__]
I believe some streamers actually explicitly did share react
to the content nuke itself.
Which is just a little funny to think >> it to me is the
fact that Ethan right after it happened said, "I couldn't have
asked for better promotion." and thanked all of these people.
Obviously it's like tongue in cheek, right? But I would have
never get like I did think that this was premeditated, but I
never thought it was for these particular creators. I think that
came later. I thought I got I got the vibe that it was for Hasan.
And then when Hasan didn't touch it, then he went after those
other people and then Hasan reacts and he does like he literally
spends like 10 hours on like half of the video. I do think it
was for all of them, but I think he wasn't going to like close
the trap before
Hasan reacted, right? Like I think he was really holding out
hope that Hasan would react so he could get him, too. I think
that's what he was really hoping for was I'll get Hasan. But
then he sort of he kind of started like calling Hasan a for not
reacting and I think that does start to give him like an implied
license. So unlucky there. Unlucky, unlucky.
Okay. Uh we continue on here. But first, Matt NLT, thank you
very much for the 10 gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you.
It's another hour on the stream. W W's in the chat for Matt.
That's right. I think that we have this intuitive notion
that these legal frameworks are here to um represent particular
things. And we just have like a structural issue with individuals
who at least in the case and again, I want to stress I don't
believe these are frivolous cases. I don't believe they're frivolous.
I don't believe they're frivolous. I don't believe they're frivolous.
In the case of a frivolous lawsuit,
we think that the motivation in bringing that lawsuit um that
that is a predominating
structural concern.
And we don't want the law to be used for an end
that we consider to be improper.
And that I think it's especially present when the suit itself
is frivolous. Because if the suit itself is frivolous, the the
chances that what's actually being motivated are genuine concerns
under the law are much much much much much lower.
So I think that you're repeating intuition that I have and that
we all share, which is that the law protects certain rights,
certain vindicates certain interests. And to the extent
that we are using the law to
target things that we think are improper under those various
frameworks,
it raises a concern about abuse of process. I'm not saying from
a legal perspective and um moral hazard. And the moral hazard
here is is especially concerning given the
the amount of leverage
that a particular rich person has in the context of legal system.
I think a lot of people can understand that. The American legal
system is one which is is not equal in terms of who is trying
to vindicate a claim. So, I agree with your assessment there.
>> I have a question. I have a question then. Beyond Beyond
frivolity, maybe I didn't understand
what you said. Yeah. Is your position that you shouldn't bring
a lawsuit against someone even if it's not frivolous
unless you are exclusively motivated
by the desire to get a particular remedy about that case or can
is it ever appropriate to bring litigation because you have personal
grievance with someone not necessarily because like even if the
case is valid, right? Like in this case you say it's valid. Like
is that So, the way I look at this is just like what are you
looking to get out of it? What are you
Basically, this is like the one way this doesn't work because
it's like got the RIAA thing in there. They put in for music
studios to go and sue for insane damages on people who have really
haven't done anything. So, it's got the statutory thing. So,
if you're suing for actual damages, I'd have no problem with
this, right? Like you you have to show that you were actually
harmed and then you sue for your actual damages maybe plus lawyers
fees, I'd be okay with it. But it's like up to $150,000 statutory
Just because it's meant to like discourage torrenting.
It's like so technically you could do that, but I think I think
that's wrong. I think the fact that that got put in was based
on lobbying and nothing more. It's like totally immoral that
that
when almost all of civil litigation is based on damages like
actual damages
Right? And this one thing exists where they could like pressure
people who torrented a [__] song to like have to
deal with being bankrupted.
I don't know. I think this is like the one example where I'm
like oh actually this is bad. Almost everything else I'm like
kind of good with.
I don't know. Do you look at that any different way, Aaron? What
do you think my position on IP is? You think I'm a huge fan of
IP? Well, I I mean I'm a huge fan of IP. I just think I think
in general like this trying to bankrupt somebody when like if
let's say Hassan had done it and Hassan had siphoned significant
views
and you could prove that. I'm totally fine with you suing Hassan
for the actual damages. But it's like with Casey
you're basically you're basically just going after a woman who
didn't do any real harm to you. It's like just not It's like
total
like totally spiteful vindictive behavior that isn't commensurate
with reality. You're just looking to enforce penalties on somebody
with no money who can't handle those penalties.
I don't I just don't think it's good. >> I assume that
anybody who's who's enforcing IP law and like taking somebody
to to task over infringement probably doesn't like that person.
So, that's probably always going like it's always going to coincide
with like a personal motivation. Right? But I do think that it
should always be secondary and the primary motivation should
be because it damaged
uh it damaged your brand or your product or your movie or whatever
it is or was a market substitute in a significant way. And just
practically speaking like why wouldn't you? But like you're saying
the reason why we have these particular IP laws is not because
that's what the majority of Americans wanted. It's because of
special interest groups and like Sony and other music groups
that have the money to have lobbied them to be set up in this
particular way.
So, they're very very stringent and they basically exist to like
set exa- like as example setting type laws. Not really because
it's about the harm in that instance. It's like a deterrent like
you're saying for other people because if they bring the hammer
down on a few random unlucky individuals who like lose the lottery
as far as like getting noticed by these companies for infringement
uh then it deters other people from doing it cuz they don't want
to be that
Well, that's what it's for, but Ethan isn't looking to deter
deter infringement, right? That's the That's the key thing. Is
there at least looking to deter infringement? They're targeting
infringers, right? With no other motive.
Um Ethan isn't even looking to deter infringement. He's looking
to deter negative infringement. Like if you do infringement in
a way I don't like, I'm going to deter that. And that's the thing
we don't like or that's the thing I don't like. Also, I do wonder
with all the people who who just go well, that's the law. That's
the law. He can do that, right? I do wonder like okay, let's
say it was actually illegal to be gay in New York and stoned
to death for it. Does that make it okay to report somebody for
talking [__] about you on the internet for like laughing
at you getting CPS called on you? Does it make it okay to report
them and get them stoned to
I understand it's like a super heavy-handed analogy, but it's
like you That's why you have to actually have to analyze the
morality of enforcing the law in these cases. You can't just
say oh well, it's legal. So, you're allowed.
That's kind of That's just insane to say. Like obviously you
can say do I agree with the law? Do I think this is like morally
justified? Do I think this is justice?
So, I think anybody who just engages on >> doesn't mean
you should. Yeah, anybody who just engages on like oh does he
have a claim? Okay, then it's okay. It's like that's a really
stupid way to engage with anything basically. I don't >> Like
here's an example. I saw this viral this viral TikTok of a Ulta
employee which is like a beauty store in the United States. I
don't know if you guys have Ulta. She got fired because there
was a mom and her daughter that approached the register and were
trying to buy a lip gloss and it was more expensive than they
thought or like they didn't have the money by like just a cu-
like less than a dollar like some cents. Like I don't know, 75
cents. And so, the shop associate stacked coupons in a way that
only she would know how to use or something like that to give
them an additional discount so that they didn't have to walk
away from the purchase and that got found out and she got fired
for
unauthorized gifting which is also seen as like theft. It's like
is Ulta within their right to fire that employee? Yes, because
she was not authorized to do that. But it's so ridiculous to
do it that it's evil cuz it's like Jesus Christ, you're firing
an employee they've already put money into training because they
gave an unauthorized 75 cent discount to somebody. Give me a
break. I It would depend on like where it goes to. I don't know
I don't know that I care on that front. Like I don't know if
I I think probably like litigating that might have other like
downstream effects. Yeah, just like when somebody can and can't
fire someone. It's like I would have to look into it and know
for sure that I was like totally behind it. Doesn't sound like
that would be bad off the top of my head, but I would have to
look further into it because like I'm thinking of exactly what
you could do to say someone has to keep someone on or that it's
like wrong to fire them for this reason or that reason. >> I
I was going to say are you a right to
Mhm. No, I think you can fire somebody for like wrongful dismissal
or sorry, I think you should be able to sue an employer for wrongful
dismissal. But I do think like in this case depending on I I
mean I'd have to know how much they lost in too. Yeah. Like what
was the total amount of money lost by doing these the stacking
of the
It was like 75 cents.
Wait, what? Yeah, they fired her because she like Yeah, she like
used coupons she like stacked coupons she wasn't supposed to
so that it would give a discount that was 75 cents because they
the mom and daughter like just didn't have the exact change or
whatever for the transaction and so she just did that. >> Oh,
never mind. Never mind. Maybe I just wasn't paying enough attention
early on when you were explaining the hypothet- Okay, that's
bad. No, I I'll take that over you being like no, she should
probably be fired over that. I was like okay, damn. But why would
you Hold on. To me, I'm sitting here I'm like why would you actually
sue somebody? Why would you fire somebody for that? Just on the
press alone, you look like super monstrous for doing that. It
looks like insane to fire somebody over a 75 cent
Because there will always be people that are like that are like
run find out. Like she's not supposed to do that and she knew
that. So, why did she accepted the the responsibility of the
potential consequences? She knew what she was doing. There will
always be people like that that defend like the business side
of this for whatever reason. Even though again it's like irrational
because when you're bringing other factors like the money the
money that was put into training that employee and how much you
have to do now to replace that employee and to train the new
one, you're losing far more than you did when you if you just
look the other way on the coupon stacking or whatever. >> Wait,
how long had that person worked there for?
They were like close to being a manager or something. It wasn't
even just like a normal shop associate. Oh. But that meant that
their penalty was even bigger for some reason. >> No, no,
that's a whole other thing. Um
Oh, that's really rough. I I noticed um I worked at a company
that was like a retail outlet when I was in high school and I
noticed they'd always fire people at like basically the same
mark. I think it's around two years and I realized that it was
because around around like a year and a half or two years or
something you gain some benefits
where I think I'm actually saying the timeline way wrong. But
after some amount of time you gain benefits, right? And I realized
they started firing people around the time where they were getting
these benefits. >> Benefits kicked in. >> oh. Yeah,
it's like oh, that's what's happening. It wasn't two years. And
also, I realized that being actually specific about it and correcting
myself would be not good. So, yeah. But basically you get some
benefits.
Once a thief always a thief. That was what one of the comments
said justifying it. They were like this doesn't this isn't the
first time you did it. It was the first time you got caught.
That's why you got fired. Oh, yeah. Well, which I don't even
disagree with, but again it's like oh my god. They're still generating
way more value for the company than they're losing by like just
not looking the other way on this unless it becomes particularly
egregious or whatever. But I guess Also like builds you up in
a what do you call it? Like a customer?
I guess it's a poor customer, so hard to say, but
what can you do? I just feel like that customer is always going
to appreciate that, right? The week they didn't have enough for
their groceries that you like made it work for them. Got them
in and out.
I don't know. I don't know, man. That's tough.
>> I'm one of these people that thinks that like your boss
or your employer needs to jump through like a bureaucratic nightmare
to be able to fire you. It's a little bit like that in Canada.
You can't just fire somebody for nothing. Um I do think that
there has to be cause. Like in the United States, it's so easy
cuz even even in right-to-work states, there still are you you
can still sue for wrongful termination if you feel you were fired
for like gender discrimination or disability discrimination.
Like they do have those protected classes and regardless of the
right-to-work status of the state, that's always available to
people. But realistically, if you're the type of person that's
like getting fired from, you know, a wage job, like you're not
bring you don't have the money for a wrongful termination suit
even if you're going to win. Yeah.
Um I think that's why they what that's why you have like um
like extremely overworked pro bono like law firms that do that
[__] right? So, David Pakman said he was audited
because when he worked at I think it was either RadioShack or
like Circuit City, someplace that's now like defunct, they were
commission-based sales and that he was making so much money from
the sales that he was generating that they actually thought he
was stealing, which is crazy cuz I really like what that tells
you is that they don't expect like their employees to come out
on top of that arrangement even though it's always used as like
the hook to get people to apply to places like that. I used to
just ask people when I go to places retail places like that,
it's like do you work on
Feel like that's mean, but
wouldn't you want to know? Somebody's like ask like I always
want to know, are you working on commission or what? It's relevant
to you as a consumer. Cuz like in the United States, for example,
if you go to like Office Depot and you just want to buy a printer,
but you don't want to buy or like you I can't remember which
which one it is, but basically like Staples, Office Depot, these
stores don't make any money off of either the ink sales or the
printer sales. So, if you don't show any interest in buying like
one of those products when you're in that general vicinity, they
don't care about helping you. Cuz they get like no money out
of it cuz it's like also a commission-based thing. They need
to like sell a certain amount of like ink cartridges or printers.
So, if you only want the ink or you only want the Yeah, they
don't care. >> Yeah, I think it's yeah, for ink, I do think
they make a bunch of money. I'm pretty sure.
Yeah. Well, all right. Okay. Dude, we got so off topic there,
but we're back to Pisco I can't even remember where we left this
off. Where do we leave this off? merely because like even if
the case is valid, right? Like in this case, you say it's valid.
Oh, right. Um is it a valid copyright case? Like do you agree
that it's an actual valid copyright case? Is that wrong to you?
Is that is that an immoral use of the system to impose that kind
of consequence maybe for some other unrelated behavior, but you're
using the
in that kind of way? Is that what you're saying your moral position
is? But what I'm suggesting to you is merely I I I I wish there's
the one part where I I was watching and I wish Hutch would have
like actually pushed there and say, "But do you think that's
bad?" Cuz I don't know what the legal arguments are and Pisco
usually turns into like a legal dictionary if he if it's like
something he's not prepared to answer and go down a specific
path on. I just would want to know like you're suing somebody
for one thing that you have like a legal claim for be based on
some other justification and you seek to like extract stuff based
on that other thing, is that like seen as legally good or legally
bad or legally moot? Like doesn't matter, doesn't make a difference.
I would assume doesn't make a difference, but I just I'm would
be curious. Cuz I I asked him about that earlier.
And he said that like it's very difficult to prove.
I don't know if it's court or like what what the law is, but
like you can't bring a lawsuit against somebody in bad faith.
That's technically true, but it's very difficult to prove that
somebody's doing that. Okay, that's not an answer to the question
though. Like if I believe it's happening, is it good or bad?
It must be bad then if he's just said it's difficult to prove,
right?
Must be.
He basically said like even if you suspect it and you just know
100% unless you can substantiate it to a court of law, which
is already very hard to do because they require a very high threshold,
it it's like it sounds like it doesn't even matter. So, then
it becomes incumbent upon everybody else to like not abuse the
system. And it has that's why it has to be like socially
Because even though like technically, nominally, that is what
the law is, realistically, it's like not really ever enforced.
It'd probably become like another like kind of bad situation
if you did have your IP violated. Like if the opposite thing
happened, if somebody really hated you, okay, you could argue
maybe this happens in the in the Keemstar case, but if somebody
really hated you and they decided they're going to start violating
your IP all over the place, the idea that you couldn't sue them
would be bad, obviously, right?
Like the idea that you Let's say they're a big creator and they
hated you. Like a way bigger creator stealing your IP and like
actually you over in some way, right? You could take it outside
of you take it outside of like react streaming if you wanted
to do that.
>> That's why intentions need to not be part of infringe
IP law.
Good or bad. >> I don't think they're supposed to be. I
don't think they are actually. No, they're not, but like so many
of the Ethan defenders say like there's somebody in chat being
hard to argue the case that face when they made it so easy for
him like the this like malicious intent thing or whatever, which
doesn't exist. What exists is willful, which means you do you
were infringing willfully and you did that. But that's not malicious,
that's different. >> yeah. Yep. Yeah. That a lot of people
repeat this and they don't they're just like
I don't know. Sheep. Total sheep.
Sheep sheep thing to say. Oh man, it's really rough that they
made it so easy. It's like, well, technically, oh man, I had
this argument in Pisco's Discord earlier, too. Somebody was like,
wait, do you think do you think he would have
if they didn't fall into the trap that he set cuz I was arguing
he set a trap. So, like obviously he's planning to sue them no
matter what. Like sue them no matter whether or not they they
made the intentful statement or not, right? He was planning to
sue. And then they're like, wait, but if they didn't step into
the trap, would he still sue? And I'm like, well, technically,
Denims didn't step into the trap. She did a full reaction. She
didn't steal it at all. Like compared to everybody else who reacted
to it, she reacted to it perfectly fine. Right? And he still
sued her. So, yeah. Like he was just he planned to sue these
people specifically.
It's like almost impossible to argue
There's just so many things that point in that direction. So,
it didn't matter if they made it easy and I I don't think they
made it easy anyway with those
Yeah, it's like it's the type of thing that I would expect his
team to bring up when they argue it, but it doesn't really seem
to have any like like legal standing for it or whatever. It's
just one of those that like I guess it looks bad, right?
I really do think it was retaliation for her threatening to sue
for defamation.
But then it seems like they settled that. Do I have any proof?
No, but Ethan retracted the claim about Denims being responsible
for the CPS thing. And then she dropped the lawsuit around the
same time. So, I had it seemed like something was worked out.
Yeah. >> You remember this or no? No, do you want to go
over it real quick? Yeah, let me send it cuz I sent it to somebody
earlier. Denims had a runtime was an hour more over Asmongold
and XQC. I know. I know. It was more than Nicholas, too. I do
think it this triggers me though when people are like, "Oh, she
like more than doubled the length." It still can be infringement
even if it was like a lengthy reaction
depending on like like how she reacted, you know? And yeah, it
absolutely can. It's less likely, but it still can, yes,
But well, that's why I never bring it up because it feels like
you're splitting hairs or like being about it. Like or actually,
it could still be that long, but not but not
Well, then but but the more time you put in, the more likely
it is to be transformative cuz one of the tests of transformativity
is basically how likely somebody is. Well, sorry. One of the
one of the pillars is how much of a market replacement it is.
If it's like unbearable, which I would argue it's basically I
tell people it's like if you just ran nails on a chalkboard every
like 5 seconds for 10 seconds over a
would that be transformative? It's like nobody wants to watch
it. Well, that's what basically what Denims does. That's like
her content.
>> So, yeah, she just makes it unlistenable for a little
while. What No Ethan viewer is going to go watch Denims, okay?
That's like what it is.
So, I do think it's transformative and the longer it is, the
more likely it is to be actually be transformative in my opinion.
Like isn't your more likely to be making statements that do change
the context to this the content, right? It doesn't guarantee
it, it just makes it more likely. The one case we looked at that
did get solved that somebody used the entire work over 2 days
in two live streams with some people did an E Fap reaction to
some dude's like Fallout 3 review or something, his Fallout New
Vegas review, and they did like over 2 days I think they did
17 hours of content on it. They did the whole thing without any
pre-work
and they did the court determined that it was transformative.
The court found that it was transformative in
that's like way different than what Denims did, but it is just
it proves that you can use the whole work, you use the work in
its entirety and still have it be declared transformative.
I don't have a lot of faith that that'll still work out that
that'll work out that way for Denims though, to be honest. I
think basically everybody who does it on a live stream and tries
to keep things entertaining is going to be kind of [__]
but Well, in his own lawsuit, if you actually read the lawsuit,
which unfortunately I have,
for that particular complaint, it doesn't even make sense to
me that he's trying to argue it's not transformative because
he spends multiple instances saying she was incorrect when she
made this response or this statement is false when she said that.
I'm like, so now it doesn't you're trying to dispute that it
was transformative,
but you're literally disagreeing with her in this court filing
about some of the statements she asserted in reaction to your
piece. Doesn't that tell you that like transformation doesn't
talk doesn't speak to whether or not the arguments or the transformation
was good or creative or correct or true. It just did you transform
it so it's different enough from the original, right? And so
how are you going to say on one hand it's not transformative,
she infringed, she just re-streamed it basically she just sits
there and stares for a bunch of time. But then also get into
like, well, she was wrong here and there. And this too, that
wasn't true. That wasn't correct. I'm going to correct her on
that in the filing. Like basically if you disagree with her are
you not technically arguing she was transforming?
Actually, the purpose of my thing was to say this, she's saying
something else so she's
It's like well you are by another if you look at that through
another lens you're basically arguing she's making a totally
different point than you, right? Wouldn't that be technically
transformative? Yeah, exactly. So to me it's like I'm like this
that's why you don't put file meme
uh cases like that because I'm like couldn't this be used against
you like that it's a backfire it could backfire entirely in the
court. Cuz I assume her lawyer is going to bring that up. Like
how are you going to say it's not transformative but you're literally
disagree with her with her commentary. Do you know if Ethan streamed
it on Twitch? Um I don't believe so, no. Oh, I sent you the thing
that that clip that I was talking about. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hold
on, I'll pull the clip and then Black Ice was asking um let's
see here. Isn't the biggest negative against Adams is that she
did it while she was still
And then okay. Um and then I think the sorry I that's why I asked
about the platforms because I think it's probably for the market
replacement
pillar, right? You would argue that while they're both they're
both live so it took away from the live viewers for Ethan, but
it is not on YouTube. Yeah. So so I think that's that makes it
difficult for me to argue the market replacement thing. Is Twitch
really market replacement?
She made a highlight on her channel and it's still up to my knowledge.
Yeah, but I'm saying that like realistically everybody else is
looking for it on YouTube.
Right? Oh yeah, yeah. The the the thing is that the only upload
that exists is not actually on Denims' channel it's a fan channel
that uploaded that reaction.
Yeah, so if she's not even doing it which is another thing that's
really funny cuz that was Ethan's primary concern the first time,
right? Was competing on YouTube and he he gave the exception
for doing it on Twitch only because he was friends with Hasan
at the
Um that's a gray area, guys. Sorry, I'll pull up this clip. >> says
that oh yeah, he says that in the ex Q C debate he was like I
don't even want to get into that on Twitch because it's just
like it's too much of a gray
Like the live reactions. He was like friends with Hasan at the
time. [laughter] Very goofy. Wait, are these that going to be
the same thing? And in her letter. >> So hold on, the mic
one was first. The mic one was first. Denims' correction demand
in her letter. Very cool. Twit Twitter sometimes doesn't let
you pause videos. The whole UI just breaks.
Hey, give me 1 second. I ordered food earlier so I'm just going
to go grab it. I'm doing like 80 things right now. Okay, I'll
play this. I'll be right back. I can pause if you need to give
commentary. Just give me a second. Uh I want to address something
from Denims' correction demand in her letter. The letter claims
I falsely stated that Denims herself filed the preceding CPS
report or that [snorts] Denims caused others to do so. The letter
also states on March 11th I acknowledged Denims had denounced
her herself or anyone in her community making contact with CPS.
Let me be clear. I have never claimed that Denims called
I [snorts] have never implied that Denims called CPS. If my statements
were interpreted as stating this I want to correct the record
and make it clear that I do not think
do not state, do not believe that Denims called CPS. Obviously,
moronic, idiotic, stupid. Let me also address the point in the
letter that I claim Wait, has anybody shown this to Hutch?
Oh, no. I literally sent it to Pisco and wanted him to but I
knew that he wouldn't because Pisco's arguments don't really
hinge on like the specifics. He wants to take it to like principles
and that's fair enough but like it's so funny that he's like
moronic, stupid, I never said that or whatever which one that's
not true. But to Hutch is out here defending a point that even
Ethan has like been forced to not defend anymore.
I believe the quote is literally Denims did CPS.
I think I'm pretty sure that's the verbatim quote, is it not?
Denims did CPS? He says Denims right now is actively on her channel
like encouraging people to do it. Hold on. Link for that too.
Let me also [snorts] address the point in the letter that I claim
Denims caused others to call CPS. I did not state and I do not
believe Denims made a direct call to action to her audience to
contact CPS. Obviously, right? Never said that. Okay. Wait, should
we do this top one here as well? Ethan was I owned Klein after
speaking to his lawyer per capturing he admits on his podcast
that I did not call CPS or encourage anyone else to call CPS.
In another incredible self-own he cowardly tries to run he cowardly
tries to run away from the debate he invited me to.
Oh yeah, I completely forgot. She was willing to debate him and
he didn't want to do it. And she dropped her lawsuit because
again once he retracted it there was no reason for her to do
it. Yeah. Yeah, it
It's almost like if you can avoid litigation you should and that
people that are genuinely using the courts as like a tool are
doing so as a last resort not because they want to for the sake
of doing it.
Oh yeah, so Denims now wants to call in cuz I well I offered
for her to call in a while ago.
She's all I feel like she's obviously scheming. I don't think
she would dare to stand toe-to-toe with me. She says
Convenient. You say that after
You say that while denying her coming on the stream or
that seems a little
I mean this is a guy who ran away from
>> Wait, what? How do you do that? >> know that?
How the [__] do you Yeah,
I'm so lost.
She must be scheming cuz she's she would cowardly run away from
me otherwise. She would run away. They're stand toe-to-toe with
me. She says I'm scared of her after I just debated Sorry, sorry.
That's her quote. But um
She would never dare to stand toe-to-toe with me. She's asking
you to.
What the [__] Somebody explain it. Well, she's going
to get up to some schemes if she does it, so. I think she must
be scheming. I don't Yeah, I Yeah, that's crazy. She would never
debate me. Denims, I'll literally debate you.
You're just scheming. This is all
Okay, dude.
Well, I I don't know the time line exactly but I need to reset
at one point to tell me uh that she wanted to call in but
I think I I wasn't able to tell you until after the show if I
remember
So you're saying she did offer? In the moment? She did offer
to call in. I don't know how Once again, Denims, I Dubs, Anisa,
any of you guys want to call in to the show at any time. So I
mean I don't know. I'm kind of on the fence if it's even if it's
worth it. I mean it would be I think it could be good content,
right? I I personally
don't think that you should because I
you know. [snorts]
I I know what Dan's going to say there. I don't think you're
mature enough to handle not defaming her again. I think you will
absolutely defame her again if we bring her on the podcast and
so I don't think you should talk to her. I think you will lie
uh immediately because that is your natural like nature. You
just immediately lie about people on the internet. So I don't
think you should talk to her. I think that I'm almost positive
that's what Dan would have said there, okay?
That like Denims would have started talking about the CPS thing
and Ethan would have immediately gone and said some crazy [__]
Are we going to do the fake logs here? This is Well, whatever
about the fake logs, what he says after so he just said in the
clip we watched I never implied that she was responsible for
this and he's like just just watch it's it's brilliant. Giardia
known to science from the feces. I wonder why he skipped over
all of this cuz everything that he said everything that I said
in this story which by the way was apparently compiled by his
crew playing
always sick, yeah. Yeah, it all makes sense now. Literally for
all of this stuff they're showing for reactions as they scroll
through. By the way with the fake logs it's not nobody's even
saying CPS, right? It's all CPS here.
But it's literally in the actual logs it's not there on the screen
at all like the whole time you're scrolling through here. I think
I saw one thing about
By the way, these people can't keep their talking points straight.
On one hand it's we don't raise our kids and our houses just
run by nannies and housekeepers but on the other hand we also
keep our house so dirty that there's dog [__] everywhere.
I mean what are the >> housekeepers and nannies doing?
It all makes sense now. It makes sense why he doesn't care about
Palestinian children when he is neglecting his own. How are you
How is this happening? How is this happening?
How?
How is this happening? Somebody in Pisco's Discord told me that
she said this as a quote. She He's like Denims literally says
that it makes sense that he doesn't care about Palestinian kids
uh because he doesn't even care about his own kids. Somebody
told me that was a direct quote from her and I'm like
To To watch or I mean she's those words certainly did come out
of her mouth. She was reading of course but I guess that's not
necessary context.
Apparently anything you read from your chat that's you're responsible
for, okay? Or an endorsement.
Is it explicit endorsement, yeah.
Um by the way, I I can still say I don't I don't like Denims
particularly. I don't think she like handled a lot of this well.
I can do the thing and say I don't I don't like particularly
think she's like a the good person here. I just don't think it
made any sense to sue her. I think the only reason Ethan is suing
her is because she kind of owned him and he wanted to get one
up on her. I think that's it.
Anyway, where are the logs from? These are edited logs from her
Twitch but they're filtered down to only talk about CPS or Giardia
or
a Zionist, I don't know. So the logs are from her channel but
somebody basically filtered them down based on a set of keywords
and that's not her full chat.
Oh, there is one now here. This should literally get his kids
taken away. Somebody did say that. Finally that one. >> How
is it happening? [laughter]
How? How is this happening?
>> I have a 10-month-old, a 5-year-old Wow.
old and a 3-year-old who are in school. Of course I'm sick all
the time. Once again, these child this people pretend that this
is uncommon when of course anybody with any sense who being honest.
The thing is these people are knowingly
They know that they're lying. It makes no sense what they're
saying, but they do it anyway because as you can see in the chat
and Denims endorses this clearly as you can see Oh.
I never implied.
You'd have to be a [__] stupid idiot to think that
I implied that. She's not moderating this at all. I just think
it's very rude that he said that about Hutch. He like he total
precog move. He was like, "I know Hutch is going to have to watch
this." So, I think anybody suggesting that I suggested that Denims
has anything to do with this, they're [__]
[__] stupid idiot. precog starkon Hutch like that.
That's crazy. And it's pretty much 100% of the comments saying
call CPS on them.
Oh, no. Yeah, that's rough, too. That's rough, too. I think with
regards to Denims, people don't realize like how astroturf that
got and then so many people come and argue like, "No, no, no,
no, no. Like she was her whole chat was saying it. It was crazy."
It's like, "No. No." And I How do you even fix people after that?
After they believe all of this? In my experience, you can't cuz
they back up to another point when you when you
dismantle it on one.
The content Hold on. Somebody in chat wants to argue. The context
would be that she were was watching Bad Empanada and nodding
along. So, if I watch Nick Fuentes and I laugh and I say, "That's
right. He's totally right about women. He's cooking right now."
That means I totally endorse everything Nick Fuentes says about
women.
I think there's like a lot of leeway you can give here to streamers
for like some like they definitely don't endorse everything that's
being said and just because she's like nodding or something when
Bad Empanada is saying some Right? She wasn't agree She wasn't
agreeing with it. She was. She was agreeing with it. I mean,
she was agreeing with some of the stuff there, but unfortunately
some of those cases Bad Empanada is not
Like he's showing clips and some of the cases he's not lying.
He And I say that as somebody who knows that Bad Empanada lies
all the time.
Right? Bro, she agrees with everything Bad Empanada said.
Did So, is that against TOS? Is that against the law? Is that
infringement? What is the point of that? >> is that agreeing
with CPS being called? Is that
That would be the same. >> Her commentary? Basically, she
was agreeing with everything Bad Empanada said. Did Bad Empanada
say call CPS and then she was like, "Yes, absolutely call CPS."
Is that what happened?
Cuz that would I thought he said call CPS in the video.
I haven't watched that video, so I I'm not sure. What's it called?
Uh I have no
Hold on. Let's look at this. We got linked an H3H3 subreddit
post.
Denims had a week ago saying someone should call CPS.
What is this one going to be? But they Well, something that is
probably related to the fact Oh, so this is the edited clip.
This is the very edited clip Horhay the First that we were just
talking about. Like >> you You know these are all the filtered
down messages, right? That this is not what her chat looks like.
You do know that, right? >> people are suing him for a
number of different reasons. So, I would assume he doesn't actually
That's what So, her chat looks like this right now.
But what this video is trying to make you believe is her chat
looks like this. Call CPS. I'm child endangerment much. CPS social
services. Bro, someone needs to unironically call CPS. Which
one do you think is real? Which
Which one are you basing your opinion
Thinking more of the bad EP part. actually have a housekeeper
anymore or perhaps he he lost his extra housekeeper. So, now
the house is just like covered in dog [__] And he's
he has kids and his kids like crawl into the dog [__]
and got
Oh, paused again. Nobody's saying CPS. Tons of CPS comments here.
>> I don't know what they do with it. I don't know if they
eat it or if it's just from like contact with it with their hands
or something, but they contracted a para um
I know Mike from PA endorsed it on
There's literally nothing here that's about CPS, but it's a wall
of CPS here. site that I had previously never heard of in my
life called giardia. >> listening for endorsements the
dog [__] that is all over his house. Dude, how is
it how is it that like maybe once a week
Is this true? Was that the totally agreeing with everything he
says?
It was the is that true chat? I I look into what you think Klein's
been up to and every time I manage to find more and more terrible
[__] This is where Ethan tells a story about his
family getting giardia. >> have mold Mondays. Now we have
[__] Saturdays. Also, this is not a joking matter,
by the way. It can be very severe and deadly to small children.
I mean, [clears throat] much like many other illnesses, it's
very very very dangerous when He agrees with the chatter. You
talk about her clearly taking a stance against it and clearly
taking Ethan's side of it.
Oh, I said after the fact she came out and said that it was bad.
So, after the fact she came out and said, "Oh, it's obviously
bad." She's not disagreeing. Is it incumbent on her to disagree
somebody she hates? Sorry, to disagree with somebody who's talking
[__] on somebody she hates like in the moment and
constantly play the arbiter
You think that's incumbent on her? She should have to do that.
What impression do you think she's giving her chat? That Ethan
is like a disgusting freak. Yeah, so if she if she sees one of
the call CPS comments, right?
If she sees one of the call CPS comments
and she doesn't say anything, I think that would be bad. But
I don't see any indication that she has, right? "This man should
not be allowed to have kids." is a comment here. You think somebody
should call that out? I sent you another
thingy. I'm just saying this is like a pretty crazy standard
to stick to for most people, right? I I think it's a pretty crazy
standard to stick to. Uh okay, he sent me another thing. Ethan
Klein blames And by the way, I would personally do that, but
I also lose viewers all the time for trying to say this is what
I actually believe and I'm going to go against my audience here
and say this is what I actually believe. Uh I have a hard time
holding like a lot of [__] against people who don't
do that. Sorry. But I I do that [__] all the time.
Just for clarification, the lower chat is hers. It's not synced
up or is it? Oh, the lower chat is a filtered chat. The top right
chat is her chat. Her unfiltered chat. So, this top right chat
is her unfiltered chat which is moving this fast. >> the
same sicknesses that adults get.
That's how that's how fast this chat is
And this is this is the chat that's filtered down. >> fine.
You'll be A-okay.
No problem. A child, a small infant that has no immune system,
shouldn't be catching anything. No wonder his house is covered
in dog [__] And his neglected children raised by
nannies have contracted parasites previously unknown to science
from the feces. I wonder why he skipped over Uh there's the comment
Krueger. "This man should not be allowed to have kids." >> all
of this cuz everything that he said everything that I said in
this story, which by the way was a Yeah, this is over a 30-minute
period, this one. >> only come compiled by his crew playing
dude is always sick. Yeah. Yeah, it all makes sense now.
Um so, Ethan Klein blames Denims for CPS showing up at his house
to investigate claims Ethan made publicly. However, his only
proof is a fabricated image.
What is this? What is this? >> kind of your fault looking
like. Love made a a good point. You said is this every comment?
[snorts] I believe this is a live feed of the chat. This isn't
>> What about the top Oh, so he made this claim twice.
Pretty weak. Pretty weak, man. >> Right. I I thought these
were this I think when you full screen it. No, this isn't edited.
It's a cutout of the full So, Horhay, you you see how you've
retreated from like multiple arguments you've made to well, she's
clearly watching Bad Empanada for a reason, right?
Yeah, the reason is Ethan Klein, I don't like him. I It's not
The reason The reason she's become reckless and gone Ethan Klein,
I'm going to watch this
Right? The Sorry, the What's happening here she's become reckless
because she goes Ethan Klein, I'm going to watch this video.
She watches the video. That doesn't mean she endorses calling
CPS. It means she endorses starking on Ethan Klein. She endorses
saying things about Ethan Klein that are extreme extrapolations
from reality. Those are totally different things though, right?
And you should hold her responsible for the things she actually
did and not the CPS call. Uh Horhay the First, you're welcome
to hop in the Discord if you want to actually talk this out.
I'm just saying you've totally switched your argument over completely
from well, I thought she was she was totally agreeing with Bad
Empanada. That clearly wasn't happening, right? Then you said
Well, that was the wasn't even the first one. You said she endorsed
it was the first thing you said. And then I think it was she
agrees with everything. And then she didn't agree with everything.
And now it is and now
it's come to well, I don't even know what we're at. What are
we at now? Oh, sorry that she was watching it for a reason. I
guess so.
It's just like if you introduce any context, either argument
falls apart in my opinion because it's like she agreed with Bad
Empanada. Oh, what did she agree with Bad Empanada on? Oh, the
thing related to the clip where Ethan said things about his family
and his kids having giardia that he literally did not need to
say. So, it goes back to Ethan in that direction. Or it's like,
"Okay, let me grant it and that she did all of that." Is the
solution and remedy to sue her for copyright infringement when
what you're upset about is unrelated to infringement? That's
also no. So, to me it's like no matter what direction you want
to push it in as far as introducing context, it's Ethan looks
bad. Over the Denims stuff. I
Again, um funny question.
I agree on the Denims stuff 100%. On the Frogan stuff or at least
that he's deranged on suing people general, but on the Frogan
stuff, do you have any idea Frogan's react was transformative?
I've never find even a clip. I've never even seen a clip from
Frogan's reaction.
No. It's so weird. >> And the thing is is that like when
that content nuke dropped,
I saw so many clips of people dunking on Denims' reaction saying
like, "Oh, she didn't have anything to say." Or like she immediately
got debunked when she tried to use that as a counter argument
in response to what That was That was my feed for many days after
he dropped the content nuke. I don't remember seeing any from
Frogan or KeiseyTron, but like the whole I thought the whole
point of the content was not only to expose Hasan
Hasan [__] or whatever, but also because he wanted
to embarrass these people in their reactions because he wanted
to have such like an ironclad content nuke that their reactions
ended up being embarrassing because they can't rebut what he's
saying. That was the
Didn't Frogan wipe her bots?
People are making fun of you for misspeaking. That's not cool.
We don't endorse that here, okay? No, the
uh it's hard to get into. It's hard to
It's not just a misspeak, is all I'll Oh, okay. Definitely look
into that, guys. She's watching someone who's advocating the
the ethical Now I've never mind. I'm not going to continue on
with whatever I was >> Oh, what are you talking about?
I'm not going to continue whatever I was going to say. Okay,
where were we? >> You know, just a few minutes moments
ago you said, "Oh, I agree with everything you said about Denims."
You didn't even need to say that because if you just are silent
when I say something, apparently it's always going to be understood
as an implicit endorsement of everything I said cuz you didn't
challenge it, so.
I was excluding KeiseyTron cuz I think KeiseyTron's like a unique
case. I think KeiseyTron broadly like
could have been sued here if he didn't extract the concessions
over things that are unrelated to copyright. And if he wasn't
going for like statutory damages, if he's just going for actual
damages plus his attorney fees, he's like a you for stealing
my stuff, I think that would actually be appropriate. Like, hey,
[__] you for using the platform to steal my [__]
Yeah. Really? Okay, so to me Frogan >> tries to steal things
from people all of the time. And somebody should probably bop
her for
Frogan like my that's I've never watched KeiseyTron, so that
is my understanding that she's done that with like Movie Streets
and stuff like that. Um
Frogan did like a charity act at some point, so I don't know.
I assume that with, you know, IP law that like if there's any
portion that's significant where you're not being transformative,
it basically invalidates the claim entirely. You can't just say
like, "Oh, it was transformative up until the part where I took
a 10-minute break, but other than that the other 2 hours were
like solidly transformative." I don't think that holds up. But
like with KeiseyTron, I wonder I feel like there's a there's
a lawyer that exists that's clever enough to argue that like
she's doing basically like a female Cheech & Chong type bit
where her like being high, confused, not knowing what the [__]
is going on, reacting to this like semi-serious, semi-unserious
like academic video, but like being too stoned to even figure
out what the [__] is going on is transformative.
Your honor, my client doesn't even remember reacting to this
video. How could she be guilty? Like as a bit. Don't you think?
That's like a funny that is like I don't know about the execution
cuz I've never seen her actual reaction to the content nuke,
but from the clips that I saw was like I mean, I do think a lawyer
could argue this is transformative.
Mhm. Cuz absolutely no one who watched it through KeiseyTron
was watching it
they wanted to hear what she had to say as like a substantive
rebuttal to Ethan's arguments. You're what You're there to like
watch her like like again, rip a like take bong rips and be like,
"What? I'm confused. I don't know what's going on." Maybe. I
don't know if that actually Sorry. I don't know if that's actually
what she did. I feel like she probably just falls asleep. If
she was doing that consistently, maybe that could be funny. I
think the issue is she probably just
doesn't do anything. But if that's what she's doing, then maybe
you can make that argument. Not totally sure. Oh, >> I'm
not saying I think it would have like a good chance of holding
up. I just think that like there is some there's some lawyer
who's out there that could probably get it off the ground. Convince
the other people to like don't take it to trial, settle. Yeah.
Yeah, there's a lawyer for anything. Lawyer will You take that
argument to a lawyer, they could they could run with it. Yeah,
100%. We'll get to what my I think my standards are is that there
are situations in which you know, it might not be a crime to
file a frivolous lawsuit, though it's often unethical. Um that
motivations behind bringing a lawsuits matter. And someone who
is, for example, we'll take the easy case.
Suppose that Ethan Klein were purely motivated 100%, not any
other percent. 100% motivated with the specific purpose of um
silencing his critics by filing
um justified lawsuits under the law. >> was trying to Do
you think he's trying to silence these people? This is a hypothetical.
Okay, okay, okay. >> there, yeah. So it's a hypothetical.
I'm not saying that this is necessarily what occurred. I'm giving
you a stylized example just to prove the point that if it were
the case, right? If it were the case that the only motivation,
the pure motivation, this is the easiest case, that's why I'm
making Hold on. POV
Pisco just said the existential dread you feel when Pisco just
said the word hypothetical.
Pisco just used the word hypothetical, and that is a terrifying
prospect, okay? If it were were the case that the only motivation,
the pure motivation, this is the easiest case, right? If it were
the case.
You're in headlines. The only
the pure motivation,
this is the easiest
case. Dude, it's actually crazy. It's like equal parts
kind of I can't tell if it's like bewilderment that Pisco would
pose these hypotheticals or if he's genera genuinely trying to
like untie a knot that Pisco just tied in his brain. I really
can't tell.
>> I don't know. It's very very very funny though. Jesus
Christ.
Hey, that's why I'm making it easier for
were to silence critics because he felt he didn't like their
criticism. Uh he felt that the criticism was like untrue or something
or that he didn't like that they said it. And that's why he was
bringing otherwise valid claims of copyright infringement that
you would think that that was bad. If he was off base
it was respect to what? His opinion?
No, no, no. About his judgment about like what they said about
him. Like in my opinion, like you brought up you brought up the
idea of like him using the legal system to in this kind of way,
but he is responding
a community of people that used the legal system against him
in a way that I would argue is worse.
Yeah, but but but Hutch, I'm what what I'm giving you is a It's
a hypothetical.
No, no, but I'm just saying like so like so so in your >> That's
what he means.
Well, he he He's referring to CPS as the legal system, I think.
>> Yeah. And the but the [__] thing is is okay,
so they used the legal system against you in a [__]
way. You understand Ethan's the one doing it,
Ethan's the one doing it. And KeiseyTron's not the one doing
the CPS thing. Denims is not the one doing the CPS thing. Right?
Frogan not doing the CPS thing. As far as I know, like as far
as I can tell. So like we have direct proof Ethan is the one
doing the thing. We have no such direct proof
that KeiseyTron is the one doing the direct thing. That Denims
is doing the direct thing. So it's obviously different, right?
But I don't know like he he basically can't engage here that
like you don't
And the sad thing is is they get in this conversation later.
It's really about what percentage culpability do you think somebody
has for this kind of thing. And he keeps saying I can't do that.
So for me, I don't understand how you can possibly say they deserve
this if you can't even determine the the percentage that they're
culpable for the CPS call. If you say I can't possibly determine
that, then how do you hold them responsible and enforce consequences
on them for it when you say you can't determine it?
That's my That's my opinion. That happens a little bit later.
We'll get there eventually. Hypothetical, it it dep- it depends
on like what was being said about him. Right, so So I'm trying
to simplify it only because if you don't grant me this hypothetical,
then the conversation's over, right? If you say, "I don't give
a [__] that his motivation is to silence his critics
as long as there's a valid claim, I don't have a problem with
it." Then we don't need to get into the weeds at all, right?
Because you you granted the easiest case. This is what I'm This
is what I'm I'm telling you is that like
we can't we can't evaluate this without getting into specifics
about like what your what is being said about him in this hypothetical.
So like if he's using the legal system to silence critics because
they didn't like his opinions about things, then yeah, I would
say that that's an immoral use of the system. Okay, right. That's
what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying. But I'm building little by little there.
But if they're saying if they're spreading lies about him about
like abusing his children, for example, then that's a different
conversation entirely, right? We're just saying all else equal.
And I would add like a kind of um So I'd say
like spreading lies,
why would you advocate
for copyright infringement claims when they're spreading lies?
There is a legal There is a facet of the legal system explicitly
built for that, Hutch. Why would you not advocate for him going
to that facet of the legal
obvious question.
There could be certain extenuating circumstances where even a
desire to with only desire is to silence one's critics, if there
really is some overriding concern in terms of like the world's
about to blow up and if you don't bring the lawsuit even though
it's motivated by the same like like I can think of situations
in which I would grant it, but in general, this is why I'm using
a stylized example, which I mean like a simplified one that's
not you know, we can't read minds in the real world, right? We
We don't know for certain all the >> And Can Have you ever
seen Chris D'Elia's stand-up before?
No. You know who I'm talking about? He used to have this bit
of like
Oh, what would he say? Don't Pete. Oh, it's Bad thanks for the
five gifted as well. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. He used
to have this bit where he would talk about how
he can't cancel a face. He'd be like, "I'm not saying black people
are the only people who do something, but" and then he'd do like
a face, right? And he's like had a bit about how you can't cancel
a face. Do you cancel a face? I swear to god. In general >> Pisco's
like talking to him and the whole time he's just doing faces
instead of engaging. >> That's why I'm using a stylized
example of which I mean like a simplified one that's not, you
know, we can't read minds in the real world, right? We We don't
know for certain all the time whether Like he's pretending to
have like it's impossible to understand
what's going on. He just keeps like Like I'm sorry. I would just
rather that you if if Hutch was my friend, I'd rather he just
go, "You're like a f'sler." Like that's more polite than this.
That was my experience debating him. This last time I was like
more There were multiple for the majority of it he he was looking
at me like I was speaking Chinese. It's like, "Do you need me
to write this down for you? Or"
Like that this can't possibly It's just It's sad.
It's just a form of signaling. Like, "Oh, this guy You shouldn't
take anything this guy says seriously cuz he's just going to
do the signal with his with his eyes the whole time."
And people will say I know people will look at this complaint
and say it's unhinged or something. It's like crazy to say that.
But it it just is what it is, man. You're like clearly signaling
that he's for saying these things. I would take a screaming match
over
this like the forced kind of civil decorum with this passive-aggressive
[__] cuz that was how I interpreted it. To me it's
like, "No, just say it like if again if you think what I'm saying
is stupid and you just want to like cut me
every now and then, I would take that over the faces. But you
letting me get it all out I'll be honest. Yeah. It's like just
to disagree when you If you If you're going to do this face where
you think I'm like saying something or you're going to make it
seem to your audience like I'm saying something
then go ahead
and just interrupt me. I would much rather the interruption.
relying on circumstantial evidence. The only reason I'm giving
you a stylized hypothetical But then what you say you like you
need to like follow it up with that same
That's also what's trippy is that like he will be He was like
making faces like
you know, he thinks the argument is like particularly egregious,
but then the disagreement was more modest and was like I I thought
it was about to be a lot more intense, but it would it never
really was. And so I'm like, "Are you like hiding your the amount
like that you disagree with me so that it doesn't get too intense
or are you playing up the faces, but in reality it's like not
that you don't you don't actually find the disagreement to be
that serious?"
I think the disagreement is serious, but he's also in a space
where he knows he he isn't supposed to make emotional arguments,
but realistically the only time I ever hear him argue in this
conversation from what I saw was to make an emotional appeal,
right? He just makes emotional appeals like pretty consistently.
Like I don't know if you know this Pisco, but actually the history
here is that Skulls CPS Skulls CPS Skulls CPS. Like he he does
that quite regularly and it's like every time Pisco's like, "Well,
I don't know if we could quite excuse this because of Skulls
because we don't know how much, you know, person A dealt in Skulls."
And Hutch like does the eyes again. It's like it feels like that's
where it's going is like Hutch is basically saying you're doubting
the propaganda and so my eyes get really big and then I don't
want to say that you're doubting the propaganda, so I'm going
to try to make an argument after. Go ahead. Who was the guy that's
always like, "Have you ever been there? Have you ever actually
been there?" when he's talking about Israel-Palestine?
Something Murray, right?
Is it Douglas Murray? >> is the name, but I
He always makes this argument He was like making this argument
when he was debating Dave Smith of all people. And it's like
regardless of whether or not
been there, contend with what he's saying. How is it relevant
whether or not he's been there unless you're bringing that up
to mobilize a point that is going to also like a substantial
like a substantive rebuttal. Like you need to have been here
to blah blah blah otherwise you're missing critical context.
But he kept just saying like, "Well, you've never even really
been there to suggest that like so what? We can't we now can't
comment on the affairs of like a place we haven't
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait. Were you there in 1945
when they liberated Auschwitz? Oh, don't talk about the Holocaust
then. That didn't happen, right? You shouldn't be able to talk
about it. You weren't there. Were you there? Excuse me? Do you
have experience memories of this thing? No? Okay, well then don't
say it happened. You don't know. You don't know that for a fact.
>> Yeah, exactly. Instead of Hutch saying, "Have you ever
been Like have you ever actually been there?" he's like, "But
could you imagine how it feels to be on the receiving end of
this?" It's like, "Yeah, it doesn't follow from that that you
do everything he's done or you even or you justify it."
I can totally understand why he'd be as mad. I've been as mad
over far less consequential things online. No Like everyone can
understand that. What people don't understand is that you actually
go out of your way to like launch lawsuits or do all of this
[__]
dude, I I said this as well, man. If he If he just took the Asmongold
approach and called Casey Tron like a flat a fat slob every single
stream for the next 6 months, I I get it, I guess. Like it seems
pretty excessive, but if that's what you wanted to do, I get
it. That's not like threatening her with financial
That's a better internet. >> very different. It's a better
internet where Casey Tron, Frogan, and Denims if they want to
can laugh about CPS being called and Ethan can just call them
a [__] in in response every single day. That is a
better world than the one that currently exists.
Where No, you can't say that because you can you're going to
fear financial ruin if you do. Well, I think eventually he would
realize that those people that if he does ignore them if he could
get to the point where he is ignoring them, his life would be
better, too.
But yeah, it is what it is. I don't know. Some people just need
to win, I guess. Anyway, we continue with this for you to grant
me the easy case so we have a base to work with. Cuz if you don't
grant me that and if you say I don't really give a [__]
if your only motivation if your pure motivation all else equal
is to silence your critics, then we don't then the conversation
on ethics just ends there, right? Because then like all we have
to talk about are like I guess the lies and the legal validity
of the case, but the ethical stuff kind of falls by the wayside
if you just don't grant me that example. And now we can >> If
he If Ethan was trying to use the system to generally just silence
his
then that would be bad. Okay.
>> All right. And um you would also agree that all else
equal
to Noah Samson. He couldn't do it to Noah Samson, so he did it
to these people, Hutch.
He's starting to silence a lot of people. Yeah. You can think
of situations in which this is not the case.
Lie about your intention
regarding a lawsuit. It's so weird how people will they'll agree,
"Oh, no, it's like It's It's like you have this argument." First
they'll go, "No, like he could have both motives." And then you
walk down the whole thing and they're like, "Yeah, but like what
are you even doing?" So somebody will argue, "Yeah, he's got
both motives. He wants to defend his copyright and he doesn't
like them." And then you walk down like the "Oh, he doesn't"
like he's trying to defend his copyright thing. It makes no sense
given all of the other factors, right? And then I've noticed
the most common follow-up is the gaslighting, the Tucker Carlson
experience where you get "Uh Wait, did you think that like I
thought he was trying to defend his copyright? No, the whole
Everybody knows that he's just being petty. Don't you know that
Ethan is petty? My god, you think I I'm saying more than just
Ethan's petty?" It's like That's where it goes next after you
do the whole walking down "Oh, he's not just He's not trying
to defend his copyright. He's not trying to do both. Okay, he
is just petty." And then it's like, "Wait, but that's bad, right?
Like then you should be able to say it's bad." Well, why do you
care? Well, apparently I'm getting tagged by Dubia about something.
Nothing drives me crazier than what you just said. People doing
that. >> It happens so so often. It's crazy.
That like this happens with like anti-choice people, right? Like
they're all the So many of the appeals that they'll make is like,
"The baby feels pain." It's like, "Oh, so if you could do an
abortion where the baby didn't feel the fetus didn't feel any
pain, would you support it?" Well, no. Okay, why are you bringing
that up then?
The the fake hill. This is the hill I'm going to die on. JK,
I wasn't even on that hill. Oh, you totally bombed that hill.
You totally won. But I wasn't actually going to die on that hill.
That wasn't where my argument was at all. Oh, and somebody's
linking me a comment. People are hilarious. How many times have
they simped at Destiny? Well, he told stream guests and friends
he wouldn't keep his audience from them in
Hold on. Let's see here. What is this? Pisco definitely doesn't
want his audience to attack Hutch. He's just not willing to moderate
his chat or comments. Dude, I told you, when you're on the side
of the like the bigger side, you can make this argument. When
you're on the smaller side, everybody points out how it's obviously
just totally logically flawed.
And by the way, I think Pisco does a like titanic herculean work
to go "Hutch is my boy" despite Hutch being a complete ass to
him in this entire conversation, okay? So But But Pisco definitely
doesn't want his audience to attack Hutch. He's just not or comments
in any way when they say absurd
like "Hutch is the reason why Josiah left Livin' Learn" and beg
Pisco to leave Livin' Learn because they don't like Hutch and
beg Pisco to stalk Hutch's Twitter whenever they think they can
get a gotcha on him. I mean,
I'm sorry. The mind of Scooby Dooter. Hold on. Can anybody explain
to me even a little bit even a little bit? I hate to do this
to you, but where's the where's
Did Did this even reach like 10% of DT's years trying to get
Destiny to go after Lycan? The thing that's dumb about this is
like they've never been in Pisco's chat because Pisco's he keeps
people that [__] on him. He he like basically doesn't
ban anybody unless they are violating TOS. Cuz he wants disagreeers.
He want His whole thing is like he wants call-ins, so he like
purposefully keeps around haters. That makes sense. I mean, it
makes sense for the kind of community you want to run. I think
like what Pisco does he just leads by example. He says, "I like
Hutch. Hutch is my friend."
What happened with Josiah? Josiah left uh um I think ostensibly
because of
uh external just concerns about doxing and [__] And
he couldn't tell where they were coming from. That's That's what
I think, but it's not what he said. He said like, "Oh, I just
I kind of want to go focus on my own show or something. I don't
have enough time for this." Was I think what he said. He wanted
to spend more time with his partner and not do the show, so he
did something else.
But I I don't know, man. What was a counterboy's reason?
That was a counterboy's reason. >> I talked to Josiah about
it and like what he said publicly was what he told me privately.
Okay. Maybe.
That's not what I get personally, but I
I also don't know. Maybe he did just want more time. I feel like
probably set up and scripted like not scripted, but like the
set up oh, this totally fits into everything I do like weekly
thing that's an hour is probably not where you start, right?
Like a weekly commitment that's 1 hour.
I feel feel like this probably maybe two or three hours.
>> It's a he's really busy at this point. It's a time suck
and it doesn't even have like a big return because as much as
he enjoyed doing it um he doesn't get too many viewers. He's
never wants to be a live streamer
And so he's like between all the other things that like I'm outside
of this he was like, "I'm not saying that like live and learn
is taking up all of my time, but like when I can't even get to
the gym most weeks these days like like I kind of need to like
uh drop some stuff and this just is not something that has enough
like pros to outweigh the cons at this point. Cuz he wanted to
like go to the gym or just have more free time. I think one [snorts]
of the things I think when I listen to him, one of the things
he said was I I edit all of my own videos. And I immediately
was like "Oh, well, that's really stupid and where you should
cut time, but okay." And maybe that's not fair. Maybe that's
like um maybe he should edit stuff because he gets like the stuff
just right in a way that blows his channel up. Right? So, maybe
not. But to me it's like that's the place you could easily
But I I think he could
Knowing Josiah, Josiah seems like the type to do like a really
generous rev
So, by not doing the editor, he really does like keep all the
AdSense and all that. Like he at least um is getting back the
money that he's putting into it by not having to do that. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, ultimately he can do whatever he wants to do. I
just I was like, "Oh, I I felt like the time thing didn't make
total sense to me. But maybe it did. Um I do think he was like
interacting with the streamer communities a lot, too, as AugurBoy's
pointing out that he would go and argue on other people's streams
and stuff. And I think I think he maybe wanted to unplug from
like that quite a bit cuz that was like extra time that he'd
end up getting sucked in for. He basically sees it as like cuz
I've I've told him like why not get an editor? And he basically
sees it as like this is my full-time job. Like why if like I
have time in the day to do it, why why wouldn't I just do it
myself?
Yeah. No, that's fair.
Could be another thing where it's like actually the the what?
5:00 to 9:00 p.m. That's like your prime time. And so if he could
do learn and learn it like 9:00 a.m. on a on a Thursday morning,
maybe he'd do it, but he can't. So, he's just like, "Fuck it.
I want my evenings open." Who knows? Live and learn episodes
relating to three four >> to three-hour arguments with
Hutch done Hutch to stream the next day. Yeah. Ultimately it's
up to him. I I kind of thought it was more the the pressure from
outside, but he never said that to me. It's not based on any
personal information. That's just like I was like, "Oh, that
time thing didn't make as much sense, but yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
All right. Let's Oh, this is I just It's so
It's like totally lacking any introspection these comments like
this. There was another one. Hold on.
There was another one that was just totally lacking introspection
that I got linked. Uh it's just another
It's just Charlie Kirk. Like Pisco said, it's this like any criticism
or whatever that's like not moderated
is like contributing to like a toxic environment for that person.
And like regardless of whether or not like that may even be true.
Like do we really want to demand that of one
Like isn't it just easier to kind of compartmentalize it and
be like, "Hey, how about we don't we try to like not
build like breed resentment for one another uh because we allow
there to be criticism of like everybody else in each other's
chats than like asking each other to like aggressively moderate?"
Yeah, I I feel like uh
I think this I don't know if you can get that. You could say
that, but the unfortunate thing is is we all do like content
online and then there's a disagreement and then the chatters
want to see the disagreement get resolved. And you need somebody
to have humility here and go like, "Oh, I was unaware of this."
And like when somebody's incorrect. But I think the issue is
you get a lot of streamers who have huge egos and they refuse
to ever admit they're wrong on anything. And then it's just a
ton of double downs.
At also people thinking that like subjective opinions are objective
and thinking the other side's just totally wrong, but like like
in this case I think Hutch has refusing to engage multiple times.
And of course things are going to get more heated and people
are going to get bad impressions of both of them from that, right?
But
I personally believe that it's mostly on Hutch here. The more
we need to exercise the common stuff. What's up, FairyQueen?
No, it's arguments over the H3 stuff. So, maybe I guess you could
say adjacently. I guess I I know what it's like to
debate Pisco and want to take the route that Hutch is doing.
And probably if you look back at like different debates, I'm
sure at different moments I even like kind of locked up because
uh like I'm like, "Where's he going with this question?" Right?
Cuz I don't feel like the questions of like the line of questioning
is always relevant. But like debating Pisco really is just a
test of patience because you need to just kind of say everything
with your chest, answer yes no first, and then give your explanation.
You're just wasting time because he won't The more you try to
avoid answering a question or try to say that's not relevant
or refuse to like he won't drop it. So, why did you get into
a debate with him at the at in the first place? So, short of
just being like, "Yeah, I don't want to say debate this anymore."
and like dipping, there's really no point in trying to like weasel
out of it cuz he's not going to let you do it.
Um maybe.
I think that's not how you win against Pisco in a debate, but
I just I think Hutch is in like an unwinnable position, so. Aquila's
here. Hutch doesn't know what he believes sadly. So, he's a phobia
of giving hard answers. Dude, the best was like the first question.
You kick it off on
"I just don't really want to talk about like whether he ought
have filed the lawsuit." Why?
"Oh, that's a really good question."
The reaction's like there's no
there's nothing that these people can do
to make this right, honestly. Like that's what they have to acknowledge
because if Denims disavowing it is not okay. Like she can't unwatch
the be the Bad Empanada video, right? Like what Like when you
ask these people, what would they have to do for you to feel
like it's genuine
and for you to not and like
uh for you to say like, "Oh, Ethan's suing them at that point
is not warranted." for them to actually prove that like, "Oh,
they're sorry." or
Like they they need to articulate that because every like when
you say like, "Oh, but she disavowed it." They don't believe
it. Cuz like I don't even disagree with them that actions speak
louder than words, right? So, like if to some people, you know,
a disavowal here or there is like not enough because they feel
like it's over determined how much they dislike a person or how
much they feel they've contributed to harassment
then like outline what it was that they would have needed to
do to be able to rectify the situation with Ethan to the point
that you'd be saying, "Eh, even though you can't sue these people
for IP, that seems just kind of ridiculous cuz it seems like
they've already like made amends." Yeah, you said something there
and I'm like, "Oh, this this is like your point." But I kind
of got like sidetracked of oh, well cuz you probably have had
this conversation with other people. But it was sorry cuz I I
started thinking and I didn't listen all the way to the end.
But it was when you said that, "Well, why didn't he just sue
them then?" Or like he wouldn't couldn't have sued them then
cuz he didn't have the reason. If you could judge If you could
say that Denims had done something equivalent to CPS, then you'd
have to argue she could have been sued there, right? Like the
fact that she wasn't sued as soon as she said these things before
CPS was involved, the fact that like she wasn't immediately condemned
thoroughly for this like before CPS was ever called and only
after the fact I feel like that shows you that you can't say
that she could be held culpable for the CPS call, right? Cuz
if she could be If you If you could predictively do that, then
she would have been before
CPS was actually called. So, that was Ethan being
Yeah, you maybe like think of this in like a different way that
like obviously the the condemnation's totally ratcheted up. So,
when Hutch says like "No. No."
When Hutch says it's obviously she's obvious that she's culpable,
I'd say it's obvious that she's not culpable in anywhere near
the same way because of how people just weren't getting you know,
people weren't outraged at that time. But sorry, I did At that
point I like started thinking about it. I'm like, "Wait. That
would be another way a good way of framing it." Like Well, just
my my TLDR was just like
>> Oh, go ahead. Go ahead.
My my No, well, you go ahead cuz you'll lose it.
Well, I was just going to say it's like it's the act versus rule
utilitarianism, right? It's like what's the outcome you expect
to have happened and what's the outcome that It's like obviously
how good an action that is isn't based on what the outcome actually
was. It's what you could expect from like not moderating the
chat.
Yeah, go ahead.
Like to me the TLDR is like, "Okay, I'll grant you that they
did everything that you're you're saying." Like what would you
have needed to What would you need to see from them
you'd take it seriously that you believe that they're genuinely
sorry or whatever. Like would it need to would it needed to have
been like an unprovoked apology? Would it needed to have been
like more disavowals? Would it needed to have been saying that
like you're not going to platform Bad Empanada anymore? Like
what things could have like avoided
um feeling like it's justified for him to do it. Yeah.
I don't know.
What's up, Riley? How's it going? >> You have a chatter
that's spamming tell Pisco that to his face. You think I haven't
told Pisco that to his face? I have told that to his face multiple
We have had literally arguments over me taking issue with how
even he even goes about structuring debates because I feel like
sometimes he like they're not debates, they're
they're interrogations where he has a line of questioning and
you try to get your own question in and he either very quickly
engages with it but then tries to get back to what he wants to
do, which is run down his line of questioning, or he says it's
irrelevant. Like that that is frustrating when you feel like
the questions he is asking are not the right questions or relevant
to the discussion at hand but he like won't drop them until you
answer it. >> And but also if you go if you say something
about it, if you like ask, he'll literally go he'll he'll start
explaining why he has to ask the question and that does happen
here. Like basically Hutch is like, "Why do you even think this
is important?" He's like, "I I feel like we go down that spiral
twice at least of like Hutch will basically ask Pisco why and
Pisco when when you ask Pisco why it's not like when you ask
Hutch why. Why when you ask Hutch, "Hey, why do you think that?"
Oh man, that's a really good question. Why do I think that? Ask
Pisco, it's like he's about to go into law school mode and start
like reciting stuff from an exam he wrote 4 years ago. It's uh
it's different different process
for different kinds of people. Uh da da da okay. Let's uh let's
continue.
Oh, hold on hold on. You have to admit it's an OP strategy Pisco
W. No, it's not Pisco W. >> I mean it's it's it's effective
as far as like if you want to you know, lead somebody around
in a conversation. Absolute And it's also very very useful in
a court of law. That's highly highly structured environment that
is literally tailored around those sorts of interactions cuz
they don't want to waste anyone's time. But as far as like, you
know, just like friend to friend, person to person, it can be
very aggravating to feel like like can we just bring It feels
like sometimes the conversations given the subjects just feel
too high stakes
when he wants to conduct them that way and he's so rigid about
it. I was like adversarial with him in DGG and I knew for a fact
that as soon as he got locked into something like that, I'm never
going back to that because it'll annoy him and he'll get like
unhinged in the conversation. He'll like totally lose it. So,
I think in terms of people who aren't looking for a good faith
discussion, which is like not Hutch, in terms of like me, I'm
like, "Oh, I can get outside of his like dialogue tree right
now? Yeah, that's going to [__] with him. I'm not
going back there anymore." So, and then but cuz then he gets
I he tends to sometimes get very like strict, like very rigorous
and if you're just in a joking mood and he's I feel like it's
not great not a great look.
But that's me just being literally telling you I'm not trying
to have a good faith conversation with him in that case.
You can continue. that independent of whether the lawsuit it's
filing lawsuit itself is bad. In general, lying about why you're
filing a uh filing a lawsuit is itself bad,
I mean, lying in a vacuum is bad. Right. There's a content element
to this where like Ethan Klein is this public persona and I think
if you if you if you asked his audience, like his his dedicated
fans that like watch all of his shows, they will tell you that
Ethan is like a very kind of like petty person and doesn't really
make any effort to hide it. So, there's him like, you know, maliciously
lying, actually like trying to do actual subterfuge or deception
and then there's like him like being coy, right? Like you understand
that that there's a difference in those kinds of like versions
of Oh, okay. So, Hutch is going to argue that he wasn't serious
about the some of the things. I forgot somebody linked me this
was just Denims um Denims reacts to Child Protective Services
visiting Ethan Klein. >> He wanted to look at everything.
He wanted me to watch this. He was checking the house and like,
"Where do the dogs go potty
we heard that there's poop on the floor." And the house is spotless.
>> Our house is so clean. Can you cancel a face? Can you
This comes up a lot apparently in streaming. Can you cancel a
face?
Look at this smug Look at this stupid smug Can we cancel a face
yet?
>> By the way, she never apologized for for like saying
bad thing She said you should never ever call somebody in real
life. I didn't say she like apologized. I think she disavowed
the the real life interference with people's lives. So, that
doesn't require hand-wringing, doesn't require feeling bad, doesn't
require anything but just saying obviously don't do that. I don't
know what to do. Nothing to say.
>> Oh god.
Okay. Yeah, apparently we need to [__] that was really
critical context. She laughed as they talked about CPS visiting
their house. It's very critical context. I don't know how I don't
know how else to say it. Um somebody could say that's wholly
insane and also laugh at the Kleins for and call them performative
and call them losers for complaining about CPS. You can do both
of those things.
lick her boogers on them.
Uh thank you for the three Reuben Ruben. How many times did you
see CPS during that clip? Did not see CPS. Oh, during this one?
Yeah, I have no idea. But or sorry, during the previous one,
didn't check.
Yeah, it's like I I'm sorry, you don't need to have her like
she all she has to do is say uh oh, Reddit thread. All she has
to say obviously
is this is unacceptable behavior, never do this. She doesn't
have to go and like go, "Oh, it's so Oh, I'm I'm so angry." And
just to be clear, Hassan did do that and Hutch still blames Hassan.
So,
it doesn't even matter. It literally doesn't even matter. It's
honesty, >> what you're what you're suggesting is a kind
of like open um facetiousness or kind of like coy uh wink wink
nod nod where you know, literally it might be a lie but everyone
kind of understands what's going on and we don't really interpret
as a lie because it's kind of like a farce, right? Yeah. And
so I can totally acknowledge that distinction for sure. Now,
I'm not That's not what I'm trying to get at. What I'm merely
suggesting is all else equal, if someone you wouldn't be like
it's good for Ethan to lie about his motivations. You'd be like
it's bad to lie about it, right? >> Sure. Yeah, like Now
there could be some very broad sense but >> Yeah, there
could be some extenuating circumstance where if he doesn't lie
about his motivation, the world will blow up or you know, they'll
take away My opinion is that you can hate the Kleins and still
realize Hassan and all his orbiters are worse people.
all of them? I don't know about all of them. Man, That's true.
All of these people that hate them can't substantiate that cuz
you ask them what have they done and they it's just nothing.
They have literally nothing. I would like to I would love to
join in on the hate train. Sounds like it would be fun
to like malt these people but there's
Um no, straight away would think that
the law is private property and that's what she wants as well.
It's actually all that I know that you're all like vanguards
vanguardists. You're all like vanguard type people, okay? All
of you. I That's obviously why you're why you're all bad people.
Yeah, I'm sorry, I don't know the terms. I don't know how to
I don't know how to commie jacket people effectively. >> a
nice try. I don't know how to commie jacket people. It's dumb.
I just don't care. I don't think people are legitimate I don't
think you can grow up in this much I don't think you can grow
up here in time and truly be
like that much of a tankie. Like that you're willing to kill
people to like get communism into place. I just don't think so.
You're like you're way outside the norm or you would just be
like a psychopath either way. You'd be killing people either
way. Twitter isn't allowed to be smart to your comrades. It's
like, dude, you know those like Is it fallen Chungus
Uh Um maybe.
Let me let me try to find out what it >> I'm aware of the
Twitter account. There's a very particular one that I wanted
to pull up though.
Okay. All right. It's kids or something like that and and there
can be some some more more But in general, like we even think
this of our politicians. We don't like it when our politicians
lie. In general, we don't we don't think that's good and we think
that there's a good norm. Oh Guys, if you're watching [clears throat]
on Twitch right now, I need you to head over to kick.com/jstok,
all right? kick.com/jstok,
head over there. We're going to be on Kick only for the rest
of the stream, okay? We'll see you guys in just a little bit.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Uh one sec, I just need to
reset a thing and good. Boop boop boop. Boop boop.
All right. What was linked? What was linked? What is the Okay,
pull this [laughter] image up.
>> Okay, I'm not going to lie when people are like Frogan
and Casey Charia are the worst. This is really how it comes off
to me because like I don't ever really see Frogan get clipped
outside of the one like about the veterans or whatever and this
drama. And the last time I saw her on Twitch, she That's a different
drama, by the way.
I don't What clip is that? It's the Ludwig is a cracker cracker
privilege clip. Okay, I have no I have no idea but it sounds
sounds cringey. >> go ahead.
But it's like it's one of those that it's like
I I she was live a couple of months ago when I was live and she
had like 80 viewers and she was playing like a Mario game and
I was like, "God, it is like so The hate doesn't feel forced.
It feels very very genuine." But it just this meme like flashed
in my brain when I was like, "God, everybody makes it sound like
this person is
like uh I don't know, a [__] like Houthi pirate or
something. I don't know what or just like the Antichrist. It's
it's like crazy to me how much hate she gets relative to like
her platform size and like what she's even said cuz the biggest
sin is like being cringe, it
And like fat and also Muslim.
Yeah. I think that a lot of that goes a lot of it's that for
people. It's like the combination of all those. No, no, a woman,
too. Don't forget. That's another attribute. Yeah. The best is
the best is
Oh, what was it? Whenever Whenever Tectone's like, "Twitch will
ban me for for calling Frogan a fat pig but she won't ban they
won't ban Denims for calling me a
Sorry. That I've heard that argument. I tend to, you know, do
a little bit of A-logging of TeckTone. I've heard that argument
from TeckTone at least like a half dozen times, and it just makes
me laugh every single time.
He just seethes about Frogan. That that is literally That is
literally TeckTone right there, okay? TeckTone and Frogan This
is TeckTone and Frogan?
TeckTone and baby Frogan, maybe Denims. Just any woman on the
internet might have been Pokimane with the What was it? The buying
yourself a ring story? She
It just makes me want to side with those people because it's
like, okay, you've made these all of these people crash out at
this point. Whatever cringey thing you did is like it's completely
canceled out by like this ridiculous reaction from everybody
that's way more entertaining than the response to the cringey
thing you did initially.
Well, it's like Yeah, and
I don't know. At some point it's totally Jason, actually. It's
just weird to me how it's very clear that there's just like a
very solid market for if you can find like a hateable woman to
just continue grinding on that and making like infinite money
off of it.
I I don't even have like a lot of hatred when I when I'm honest
about it.
I don't even have like that much hatred for TeckTone. Like TeckTone,
I guess, just make your money off of doing the same content all
the time. I have like total disdain for the audience now who
gets fooled by it every single time.
Like Like I have total disdain for the people who have been totally
fooled, and they're like, yeah, everything Ethan Klein is doing
is good because Denims bad, Frogan bad.
Um and Keemstar bad. And it's like, okay, I get that they're
bad and they're annoying, but like other than consistently
getting people to seethe like all the time, what have they really
done? Like what did they What did they really do? What did Denims
do that was really bad? Was she just particularly hateable the
whole time?
Like I remember covering her stuff, and she was particularly
hateable. She's very hateable, okay? Do I have to pull up the
clip again of her smiling and laughing when when Ela's going
through her harrowing recount or her harrowing account of the
CPS visit? And Denims is like smiling and giggling. Very hateable
person, okay?
I'd probably find that funny. But that's just me. To me, it's
like I I saw this also with like uh I don't know, like just Sure,
it's like you'll find cringey moments of everybody, but it's
like any amount of time spent on this is like too much.
Well, I When it first starts, yeah, but then I think it's crazy
when you get into like the industrial complex of people who are
like, okay, Okay, we're doing our weekly update on Denims conversation
today where she talked about this thing.
Like at that point it gets to It's like our Anita Sarkeesian
levels of like you got to be careful because in trying to like
make fun of this person, denigrate them, you've gone about it
in such a way that they've almost come off as like this like
Like again, it's like having to balance like, oh, they're weak,
they're pathetic, they're moronic, they're stupid, no one cares
about them, but at the same time like they have more concurrence
than you, and also like they're a lot of their streams are just
like gaming streams, and you're kind of just like recycling the
same clips or whatever. Like they're not even generating new
controversies, you're just finding new ways to react to the old
controversies.
you're you've kind of like turned them into this like uh they're
like a monster under your bed, basically.
You get like a dossier of clips on like Denims, and then when
Denims says something new, you get to run the whole old of clips
and make all of the same money again with all the same viewers,
and probably you actually get more viewers to watch it again.
It's uh it's like a diabolical way of making money, to be honest.
It's It's just It's wild.
Didn't TeckTone say something about watching Denims with his
pants off? Yes, he did. Yes, he did. He did say that. Dude, there
again, there's so much hate, especially towards Denims, that
I have to assume is like it's pathological. Like it is They hate
that they don't They genuinely find her annoying. I don't doubt
that. They think that she's dumb, but like they hate that they
want to [__] her. They hate that they that they think
she's hot. >> Uh I
Probably. Yeah, sure.
I definitely
I definitely remember reacting to Denims just being like she
is actually like brain damaged. Like when when she's arguing
like factual things sometimes,
kind of rough. Or it was when I watched. It was just It was like
one of those things where I think the natural reaction is to
go, oh, this person's dumb. I'm not going to pay attention to
them. And yet And yet Candace Owens, 180,000 viewers.
So, I don't know. What if What if the only thing preventing Denims
from being at 200,000 viewers right now is the fact that Nicholas
DeOrio, TeckTone, Asmongold, OTK, Destiny,
all these people just snarked on her relentlessly. What if What
if that was the only thing preventing her from getting to be
a 200,000 viewers
Taking over the whole space.
Do we think about how much we should be thanking them? Anybody
think about that?
It could be another Candace situation, guys. It could be really
[__] up.
No, I'm not getting I'm not feeling buy-in. I'm not feeling any
buy-in here. Okay. Well,
>> I'm sorry. I'm off in my own like private Idaho because
I just like can't I'm trying to like understand what it is, but
like this just seems to backfire to me because again, don't get
me wrong, caricaturing your enemies very, very effective. I'm
not like it's highly effective, even. But like you you have to
be careful. Caricaturing them is like cringe, okay? And like
throwing a tantrum over, you know, these clips or whatever.
Because if you go if you lean too much into it, again it becomes
like they're like this super villainous caricature all of a sudden.
They're like Denims is this dark devouring mother archetype,
you know, threatening to like take away your kids and call CPS,
and like you look at the citations for that, and it just does
not line up with the caricature you've just built up. Yeah. Yeah,
I'd say that probably goes for all of them except maybe TeckTone.
>> making them seem too powerful and like almost too badass.
It's like, dude, she didn't do any of this [__] Oh,
it's the it's a little bit of Trump syndrome. Yeah. Right, where
like
it's one of those things where you get to the point where it's
like, can he really be like the super dangerous evil guy and
like the biggest on the planet at the same time?
Like I I feel like probably those two things conflict a little
bit. What I ran into this the other day. But yeah, it's like
she can't be the evil person and the biggest dumbass on the planet
who's constantly telling on herself and the person who like plays
video games 50% of the time she's on The enemy is at once weak
and and all
It really is just that. The old adage.
Dude, where Where were we here? I forget I honestly We don't
like it Adding a lot of context here with the clips and stuff.
I love it. I'll do this for hours, okay? At least for hours.
>> be some some more more But in general, like we even
think this of our politicians. We don't like it when our politicians
lie. In general, we don't we don't think that's good, and we
think that there's a good norm in making sure that our public
communicators are being frank and being up front. And it's distasteful
to us. We don't like it. All right. So, that's This is just establishing
because what will happen, Hutch, and it's not really specific
to you, is people will say things like, who the [__]
cares if he lied? I guess everyone just kind of assumed that
he lied. I whatever. M- Makito, I think the argument here is
not that Well, at least for me, it's not that these people aren't
cringe. You mean intelligent and crazy. Yes, you can. Um but
then you are you arguing Which Hold on, hold on. Grandy, who
are you arguing is intelligent and crazy out of Frogan and Denims
and Keemstar? Cuz then you're arguing that at least one of them
is intelligent, so I'm a little lost, but Makito, the thing I'm
pointing out here is you could think they're cringe or whatever.
It's just probably they're like cringe, and you can like almost
stop there. You don't have to go there like cringe and evil and
destroying this man's life cuz I just don't think they really
were to any extent. It's just very easy to go and farm how stupid
they are. To be honest, with Keemstar specifically, Keemstar
will say the exact thing that you could just go try to farm that
all the time. It's like very obvious. It matters to people. Like
these kinds of lies matter. And it matters when they do it, right?
It matters when Ben Shapiro lies. It matters when Hasan lies.
It matters when Denims lies. Fair? Yes,
but I feel like we just We can't just skip over what I just what
I just said a moment ago, which is essentially just like not
all lies are created equal. Like we should not We should not
evaluate all lies as the same. Just like it's just lie equal
bad. No doubt. So, for example, when when the couple many other
contexts
They what? Dude, they uh this is the
They basically agree.
But Hutch Hutch is like fighting on the dumbest hill I've ever
seen. It's like, okay, I would agree that not necessarily every
lie is bad, but then if it's like the exception and not the rule.
And he's basically He's like consistently pausing to make sure
Piscatella understands that whoa, I have to know I I can't say
lying is bad cuz there are some lies that could possibly be good.
It's like, no, you could say lying is bad outside of a few like
notable exceptions.
You don't have to like pause every single time to say, no, lying
could be good. What if he What if he told us that he was suing
them for copyright infringement? He's trying to protect copyright,
and that lie was important. What if that lie was like morally
good? >> What if he didn't sue her for copyright? His mom
was going to be
What's up, man? How's it going? Not much. Not much. I mean, I
I As far as, you know, his ultimate underlying things, I kind
of stay out of that. I'm just watching left-wing violence. And
I'm like, I'm just going to sit over here and watch this whole
thing unfold. But yeah, it's clear. This is clearly pre-planned.
He played the long game here, and he set a trap that he knew
somebody was going to be dumb enough to walk into, and
you know, I think he probably thought it might be Frogan, but
like I don't know if he knew how many people would do it. But
he knew it was going to happen.
Well, I mean, technically he trapped like everybody cuz there's
just tons of people who probably react to content in a completely
copyright violating way,
Yeah, it's a pretty like lazy tripwire.
Yeah, but you know what it's like you see the bait car, you know,
they were dumb enough to go ooh that that's a nice looking BMW
and ooh the keys are in it. I guess I'll take it. It's like well
you know. But I wish that the like Ethan defenders would just
admit that. What's frustrating is not that not only that that
is what's obviously going on but it's like okay, but then just
admit that this is about using the courts to study settle unrelated
petty disputes that you can't settle legally or like in any other
way. So you're just you know, you have the resources to be able
to vindicate your property rights using the courts and this is
how you're doing it because you can't sue them for defamation
cuz they haven't defamed you and you can't sue them for or you
can't press charges for filing a CPS call that was fake or a
false CPS report cuz you don't have evidence for that and you
can't go after them for being mean. So you do this.
Well, well the biggest thing is he's going after people that
he can't
So this is all it's all but I at the end of the day yes, this
is all information
The discovery in this case is just meant to give him you know
secondary and tertiary targets to go after after the lawsuit's
over. Uh but just once again though it's just you know, Ethan
is so lucky that his
you know, what he is he perceives as enemies are so stupid
that they've made this very easy for him. So but that that's
but you I I I think there're probably a lot of people though
who probably support Ethan who think this is a righteous thing
For sure. But I think yes, if if anybody wants to be honest,
this is clearly just a vendetta ride. And once again >> wants
to be honest. They want to maintain that like because it's technically
plausible as in like there's a non-zero chance he could be motivated
equally by both that therefore it's highly probable that it follows
from that which is what's the most aggravating to me, but at
least you just come out and say it like yeah, that's what he's
[__] doing. And I mean that is his legal right to
do it. It's like that's all he's [__] doing. Oh yeah,
well no right away I could tell that's what it is and you know,
it's funny. I think the Reddit mods um I mean they're terrified
right now and
I get the feeling the way
and I mean it's it's it's a hunch. I don't have conclusive evidence
myself. I'm not involved in anything, but it's just the idea
that this wasn't
part of a plan here. I just I feel like there's some issues that
the way the way the mods have acted, the way they've been involved
in this the way a couple of them have taunted in the uh like
the uh oh god, what's it called? The leftovers subreddit.
I I just I get the vibe that they were involved a little more
than they really wanted to realize and now they're in
Um I mean it's their filings are insane as far as what they're
trying to argue at this point. So I I think they're probably
going to get exposed or a couple of them at least >> you
link the filings
that the mods have made? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, they've made a couple
of them uh up in >> know about that. Well, I knew that
he was like taking legal action against him, but I didn't um
I hadn't been able to locate like how they responded to it. >> Oh
yeah, well the the weirdest thing is Reddit hasn't been fighting
the motions to quash. The mods have which
once I I'll hypothet I'll put out what I've kind of come to the
conclusion of. I think Reddit may have cut these guys loose and
said you're on your own because Reddit's not fighting it. It's
the mods fighting for
the subpoenas to get quashed which
you think Reddit would be all about it, but Reddit's not involved.
Wait, why? They're not a party to this. Why would they want to
get involved? Why why would they why would they might not want
to be why would they want to be
Well, cuz they're being asked to they're they're going to get
a subpoena. They have the right to come in and say no, we don't
want this quash it.
You know, it's getting served on them. But I think they like
to be a platform, right? Is is that a not affecting >> Yeah,
well by allowing that Well, then that's part of well and that's
part of their problem is uh some of these mods especially like
the one guy Roman P or whatever his name is has acted like oh,
I'm in touch with Reddit establishment. I'm in touch with people
in charge and one of the things the Reddit mods indicated they
were receiving free
uh you know
thing they were receiving
identity protection and different things like that from the Reddit
staff and it's like it almost sounds like you're compensating
these guys and giving them special benefits and it's like
Well, Reddit it's Why would You're aware that I believe that's
just Reddit gave out as to to everybody. They basically got like
a company subscription for some PII scrubbing software. I think
it was actually disconnected from this.
Well, I know and then if that's the case, that's great, but they
they didn't really explain like oh, we all got that. They just
said like we got that and that I'm just saying the way that's
been argued has been very poorly done by the Reddit mods because
like I said, I don't know what they got but they said that and
it's like you're not you're not presenting a case of that that
would give me reason to say Ethan's full of crap. Um they provide
those elements you request it. Well, that will make things
helpful to them because if they hand it out all the time, that's
great. It just it makes sense to me that Reddit would cooperate
because one they're not a party to this. Two, I don't see what
they would be held liable for. Well, they could say we have our
terms of service. We have contractual
obligations cuz they say their terms of service we will never
we don't cooperate. We don't provide those things. They have
the right to say look we have terms of service with our customers.
We don't want to cooperate with it. Um that's not an issue of
them then automatically being liable for the copyright infringement.
That's that's a couple steps down the road, but I didn't But
you just think that because they're contradicting their public
stance as to how they would ostensibly cooperate in these circumstances
that they are trying to mitigate something, but you don't know
what it is. Yeah, it's just it's not I expected them to come
out a little harder, but the mods come out of left field on their
own and jump into the lawsuit. It's like you know, I I don't
know I don't know where they came from on their own and you know
it it's something just doesn't make sense here in how this is
being done.
And let me see if I can grab you what they are. Where is that
thing at?
Hold on here. I can send you the link to this stuff, but yeah,
they have a whole they have a whole set of documents and things
they've been filing and dealing with for a while now. Um one
of the biggest things is they're arguing about Casey Tron and
the mods
don't need to get deeper into the quicksand of this lawsuit.
But when they start arguing about what Casey Tron said and Casey
Tron's doing your statements are contradictory. If they really
thought that Casey Tron doesn't have anything
the idea that you would telegraph all this to Ethan ahead of
time and say oh, she's full of [__] Don't listen
to her. No, let him go on a let him go on a wild goose chase.
Let him come into court saying see I have all this proof. Then
they could say all your proofs you win. Like you would you would
win crushing that subpoena because you would show Ethan doesn't
have anything.
The fact that Casey Tron says yes, I'm going to cooperate and
give them everything I have
and now they're running around with their hair screaming on fire.
Well it you know, that's that whole kick dogs, you know, scream
the loudest.
There must be something there. You know, to what extent I don't
know, but if you didn't have anything like if he if he didn't
have nothing on you why would you be worried?
And why would you be trying to say Casey Tron can't be trusted,
she's a liar. I guess that's that's my biggest point is like
if if I know she doesn't have anything, it's like yeah, sure.
Do whatever you think Ethan. Have fun with that. Let him >> wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Are you sure about that? Is that an argument you make? Aren't
you like a libertarian? Isn't like your privacy to be protected
at all costs unless like otherwise
Don't you always say like you need a reason? Everybody else is
lying. Actually give me some real probable cause. >> no,
no, no, I'm no, I'm saying as a legal strategy here, Ethan has
to make a showing. He can show some proof of things and Casey
Tron coming in saying yep, I talked to these people. Boom, boom,
boom. Here's my proof. We all colluded together. Ethan then's
going to be able to enforce that subpoena a lot
Okay, for sure. Have they had a Casey Tron statement yet? Sorry,
I might have missed it. >> she was going to coop. Yeah,
she she gave a whole >> was going to cooperate, but to
me like that could also be Ethan trying to like
trying to basically bluff people, right? Like I I could believe
he did that. >> if he bluffed them, he he successfully
got them to run around.
Okay. Do you get my point here? And I don't know if Well, I think
they they filed like a response saying no, we're not like even
we've never talked to her. But Yeah, and it it just they didn't
even have to do that.
Yeah, sure. Okay, I got it. >> he kind of smoked them out
and
no, you like he he started shooting over the trench line and
they jumped up. It's like what what no, stay down. Keep your
head down. You don't need to let him run wild and then look like
every in front of the judge.
I see and you're saying that basically you don't see why they
would respond if there wasn't something there because they should
know not to respond or say
Yeah, I mean I I don't know why they I don't know why you would
react at that
They gain nothing by doing that. >> Okay. Also, I just
think >> they in this case you mean Reddit or the Reddit
mods? Who do you The Reddit mods. They gain nothing by saying
like oh, there's something there.
Well, now you're saying there is something there. You're kind
of you're kind of reinforcing the thing that Ethan might be right,
but now maybe it's just a little bit. Maybe it's something kind
of inconsequential.
Maybe it's not really that big a deal, but you've already said
there's a there
You've indicated there's a there there. Well, that gives the
court a reason to say, "Hmm, there's a there there. I guess this
subpoena really isn't a bad
You know, go start digging, Ethan, and it's like, "Okay, well,
now you were sharing cat pictures with Casey Tron."
You know, now Ethan gets to know who you are because you just
couldn't just maintain your calm for 5 minutes.
Like there's some strategy here, and Ethan is actually being
very cunning in his actions. I will say that much. Ethan's being
very, very cunning in what he's done so far. Okay. >> And
uh Um I don't have like a disagreement with that like contention.
I just I think there's like easily they could just want to get
on the record because they might be scared that like Reddit will
give away information on them unless they stand up and say
Right. I think that could be the case. That like Reddit might
not be willing to defend them, so they have to stand up and say
something, but I don't I don't like unless I look at the filings,
I don't have a lot to contend with. Straight away. Well, I can
send you I can send them to you guys in your Discord, but it's
going to be So, yeah. So, sorry about that. The link The link
apparently is to a naughty place apparently based on your uh
Well, I have like people who are doxxing people in my Discord
based on the idea that like this is Kiwi Farms adjacent and stuff.
So, I think we have filters on all that stuff. So, unlucky.
I just didn't know the voice chat here would do that, but it's
The Farms is the place that's got the link to you know, everything's
linked there, but Yeah.
I'm just saying though like people So, people in chat are saying
like uh the statement of Casey Tron means nothing. It's like,
"Well, I mean, unless you're going to say Ethan is suborning
perjury and forcing her to make false statements, it's like I
don't know. It might mean something." Like it you know, there
there is levels of cope. It's
I you know, and like I said, I think that that that's that's
entirely normal.
>> That the idea Casey Tron's like was like I will cooperate.
I have information.
uh some people in chat are like, "Oh, that's all doesn't." I
was like, "I don't We don't know the full set of cards here that
Ethan's playing with at this point. We don't." And I mean, then
there's the other issue, the
kind of the
the unspoken issue here of what Frogan's
She hasn't responded for her lawsuit in months, and Ethan hasn't
sought default yet. Wait, yeah. Didn't she say to the extent
that she's able to cooperate, she would do so? That's not That
wouldn't constitute perjury. No, I know that, but that's why
it's like I But that's her saying
um cuz Ethan's already talked to her and said, "What can you
cooperate with?" Which means she's probably already had to show
what she has.
Um that would have been part of the settlement discussions. How
much information do you have and what do you have right now?
There's no way Ethan would just say, "Oh, we'll settle and then
you tell me what you have." He's going to go through all of that.
But no, the bigger thing is Frogan. Frogan's case is kind of
just like
gone into stasis, and she hasn't responded, and Ethan hasn't
sought default judgment against her. That tells me Frogan and
even Denims mentioned it like Frogan's probably
selling out. And it's like, "Yeah, she probably is." So, it's
going to be very interesting to see how this all unfolds. I think
regardless of what information Casey Tron is privy to as far
as cooperating, that was always going to be something that Ethan
had her include in the apology,
even if she had like literally nothing. So, I don't think that
I think it's unlikely that like even in their negotiations between
her lawyer and his that it it was intentionally placed in the
apology because he viewed what she like she said, "Oh, I have
this this stuff that you're going to want to know about." So,
like get herself into a better position cuz it seems like she
has like almost no no leverage.
I could see that. But if that was really the case and the mods
know there's nothing there,
um I I I guess I just feel like they would be responding a lot
differently than just running around screaming about, "Oh my
god, Casey did a hostage video." It's like, "Well, if you know
he's got nothing, then just if you know, the one way to just
kill this off right now is to say, 'We know she's got nothing.
Like this is all clearly garbage.'" But they didn't do that.
So, instead they did this running around, wringing their hands,
and like I just they're not doing it in a way I
There's better ways they could be handling this, and they're
not handling in the way I think they should be handling it. So.
It did come off like not I wouldn't say hostage, but like like
she's saying it at gunpoint, yeah. Well, yeah, but that's it.
Like every settlement's like that. Like that that that's that's
entirely normal.
Every settlement involves somebody having to make a public apology
>> public apology if there's going to be a public apology
involved, yeah. Read
Read this and this only. Yeah. I mean, I think there's been there's
been other, you know, internet things that have been settled
like that. And you watch the person, and yeah, they're reading
it off like they're you know, they have a lot The apology that
I expected was going to be something that was kept to just the
stuff about infringement. Like I'm sorry about that, but it also
included things like I'm sorry about my comments to about Asmongold's
mom. I'm sorry about anti-Semitism and leftist spaces. Like is
it really industry standard that when apologies are extracted
via settlement,
uh they include stuff that's like completely unrelated to the
to the case?
That's what an Do you just That's an unconditional surrender,
and guess what? You get to dictate terms. So. But well, yeah.
Yeah. Well, yeah, but is it is it common?
I mean, depends on how vindictive and you want to be, yeah. I
mean, like you >> it's 100% common for vindictive apples
that are launching lawsuits like this. Yes, I agree with that,
but like common in general for like apologies
that that are made because of settlements, I don't know. Yeah,
no. No. That's I've seen I've seen things like that before, but
If your goal is to make your opponent make their suffering legendary
even in hell, My uh and embarrass them and destroy them, yeah,
this is perfectly >> My contention is that probably I should
just make fun of the person who tries to sue people cuz they've
got way more money and then gets them to settle and extract statements
like basically saying dance around in a circle and say I'm a
little piggy and then tell me I have a huge and then you can
go home and your parents don't get to be homeless. I I feel like
I just have like a lot of disdain for the human being that does
that personally. And I think everybody should have that same
feeling. You can you can
You can have disdain for that. I'm just you know,
I'm not telling you that it's right or wrong. I'm just telling
you that's how the butcher shop works.
So. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I like people can tell me that's how it
works. It's like, "Yeah, that's fine." Yeah. It's like No, but
it's it's not abnormal. used to tell black people it's like,
"Yeah, I know you want wages, but actually you get no wages.
You get to work for me forever and go back to go back in the
house. That's how it works, right?" Yeah, but no, but this is
this is, you know, the idea of civil suits though. This is We
leave it generally up to the parties if we can when it comes
to settlement
That that's pretty That's a pretty standard thing. >> normal.
Just that I don't know about apologies public apologies that
include stuff that's like unrelated to the scope of the lawsuit
and like going far beyond it. Well, and if the court's a court's
not going to get in the way of that because that's what it's
been agreed to. Oh, no. I didn't I didn't think that, but I could
see like the parties being like, "No, my my client, you know,
even with very little leverage, like is willing to make an apology,
but not that goes not when it goes beyond the scope of the lawsuit."
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Well, that's I have very Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. In Nevada, prostitution is legal. Could in if Ethan had sued
her in Nevada, could he have demanded getting his dick sucked
as a condition of the
It's actually only legal in like Reno. That That becomes um well,
number one, I think that that becomes, you know, people have
bodily autonomy when it comes to those types of things, number
one. And I would argue
forcing you to do something for me like that almost kind of gets
into like a 13th Amendment issue. Like I'm forcing you to do
work for me.
Like that'd be another argument you could probably make, but
the idea that you would be entitled to have >> Well, if
it's a if it's a traded good and service in a given state, why
would it not be something you could demand? Wait, why can't you
make somebody Wouldn't this be doing work for them given that
she is a influencer and he's getting her to reverse her influencer
opinions? What what what I think you'd have a better argument
to make here if we're going to play this hypothetical that she
was already doing that for her job.
Like she was already out there, you know, being an escort or
whatever.
But if she's not, she just happens to live in Los Angeles. >> But
she is out there being an influencer, and he's getting her to
reverse her influencer opinions like explicitly. Like literally
stuff she's done only as an influencer, she he's getting her
to reverse those things. So, I'm like, "Oh, if it's about making
him making them do work for you or something." It sounds like
like, "Okay, you're saying that if she was a prostitute by trade,
then maybe you could demand that." Damn. Personally, I think
it might be an Eighth Amendment violation. I well well, it well
Cruel and unusual punishment. Well, that too, but I mean, I think
you'd still would just run into an issue of it's a bodily autonomy
thing, and I you know, I think that Yeah, I just You You think
the courts would intervene? Oh, the court would not allow that.
The court would not allow that as a term. Well, that's to me
it's like a free speech issue, and that compulsion like compelling
speech should be related only
only to undoing the damage done that is relevant to the case.
That is like that is how it should work in my opinion, but then
you're saying it like doesn't work like that. And I'm like, "Oh,
well, damn." Yeah, no. No. And I get I get it. Yes, it should
you know, should it be limited to the topic at hand of you know,
I ruined his copyright, not Ethan's going to do every grievance
that he feels like, "Oh, that would be fun." Or this is going
to be great. And then yeah, Asmongold's thing is right in the
middle of it and it's
you know why why is Asmongold like this?
She does not look like office
Yeah, no it's I thought he had the legal right to do all of that.
I was just of the personal opinion that I think it's incredibly
weird to win a settlement against to get a settlement and then
go like do say all these things that are
I'm like
Well, no and it just goes to show that this is not the primary
goal. Like there is a underlying
This is there's an underlying policy concern for Ethan and that
is to make people suffer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I was people that
yeah.
And that's all I ask people to admit when they come on here.
Sometimes people come and argue this and they're like arguing
he's morally righteous and I'm like, "No." I mean realistically,
he's just like just admit you think Casey is like a vile and
then like you want anything done to her to like [__]
her up. Like like that's okay. It's not really okay. Probably
a problem. But like that's how most people feel. They're like,
"This is the most repulsive
I've ever seen on the internet and I want anything done to [__]
her up." And >> But it's okay. It's like it's a prerequisite
for having an honest conversation because then we can have like
again we're actually have a good foundation for being able to
even discuss it. But when people are being obstinate about this
I it's it can even be hard to put into words sometimes because
it's questioning
such a trivially obvious assumption
especially after like you know trying to convince somebody who's
who doesn't know anything about it it's like hard for me to not
see it as like motivated reasoning to be unwilling to just say
given certain pieces of evidence that like yeah Ethan is not
motivated primarily or even significantly or like at all by infringement.
Yeah, I mean it it I I don't think at the end of the day it's
it's couple percent yes he cares about copyright infringement
but it yes the ultimate goal like I said is >> No, I know
he cares. I just don't think he cares in this case in these cases
which is like the state of motivation cuz like he does have his
street cred like for his past stuff which was cool but I think
he's coasting off of that for this you know and I mean he already
tried to do that with the Ryan Kavanaugh [__] which
nobody ever talks about but like he's really stretching it with
this
To the point that like almost nobody
it was like nobody believed it or like people pretended to believe
it for like 2 seconds because at this point it's not even about
that. Nobody was celebrating Casey Tron's apology as a win for
the react community and nobody got mad at him that's like, "Hey,
you're betraying people because you said you were going to do
this to prevent Sony or Disney from coming in and chilling the
react community with bad standards or whatever." Like there was
none of that happened. But I know that I don't think I appeal
law is not your area of specialty, right? It's it's not but there's
you know it it's When it when it comes to this I mean it's it's
I mean It it it just helps that for
like Froggy and Casey Tron it was really very very clear cut
you know what they did and you know gives him like you know it
those are the easy ones.
Denim's case is a little tougher but you know some of her statements
and like when she reacted to her tweet about Casey Tron's apology
it's like I you know I don't feel like she ran that one by her
legal team and I it's a little uh Ooh.
Did she make extra statements?
Yeah, she made a she she did a tweet to Casey Tron's
She did a wall of text. Yeah, she did she did a little spree
about it. You're talking about the wall of text. I did read the
wall of text. She did stream about it. I don't I don't I think
you know there's some
that ever gets a deposition there going to be some interesting
questions there I Oh wait, really quick I asked you that not
to be like this isn't even your area of specialty cuz I was going
to ask like as far as application of the current fair use standards
let me grant that Casey Tron Froggy or Denims there's evidence
that they colluded with the Reddit mods to attempt to serve as
a market substitute. When they apply the standard if even if
you attempted to do that if you don't objectively end up serving
as a market substitute meaning the person suing you can't actually
prove financial damage or that anybody actually went to you instead
of the uh copyright holder for the content is it Does it actually
end up being applied or like not end up being applied or counted
as a market substitute because it's like even if you attempted
it if you didn't actually achieve that does the court say, "Well,
then it's stale cuz you couldn't get it off the ground?" >> don't
actually know the answer there. I'd like to say I understand
what you're saying like if your conspiracy to do this fails are
you still responsible for it?
That one's going to be a little hard because yeah copyright law
is very
you know cold and it you know just like did this happen yes or
no. Not necessarily your motive behind it. It's just the motive
behind it makes it easier to establish what you're doing. I I
don't know that one. I don't know the answer to that there but
Cuz like if I tried to infringe
like upon like Disney or some massive IP and be like, "Yeah,
I'm going to I'm going to be a market substitute to to Disney."
It's like, "No, I'm not." Even if if like I could collaborate
with a thousand Reddit mods there's no way in how you could ever
do it. Like well, I'm wondering. I'm wondering how that's applied.
Well, the bigger issue for the Reddit mods is there's a case
that just went to the Supreme Court um that just got argued dealing
with this idea of contributory copyright infringement.
So, that may actually help them at the end of the day that the
Supreme Court may say that's actually not a thing
and then they're kind of home free because then there's no claim
against
So, if I if if they were that that's actually kind of a bigger
thing right now at this point that may save them.
I don't know if it's well, they just argued it a couple like
2 3 weeks ago. So, it's a kind of upcoming thing. Um but I don't
I actually don't know the answer. That's actually a good question.
That's a very good question. I can ask somebody I know about
that but um I don't know the answer myself.
Cuz I can understand it being like different depending on like
what the domain is or the market. The smaller the market that
dealer the threshold is for proving that it served as a market
substitute and like the bigger it is. But then it's also I'm
I'm balancing that against the fact that like who in this world
can actually enforce their copyright the easiest and it's like
all these massive corporate conglomerates and at that point like
it's almost default judgment. Like when it comes to copyright
if you know Disney is sending a claim to somebody it's pretty
much you know liable until proven otherwise not liable until
proven. Because they just default so like, "Oh yeah, like this
massive corporation wouldn't even be bothering unless they knew
for sure they had an ironclad case." Oh yeah, they they well
sometimes they do. Sometimes they're just willing to they can
just scare you and spread some money around. And um just so your
chat is aware the case is called uh Sony versus Cox Cox internet
service Cox communications
and it's about the idea that people were using the internet to
uh the internet service providers internet to download and pirate
stuff and Sony won like
a $7 judgment
against Cox. So, that's kind of what they're looking at right
now. My god. Oh, that's
Yeah, that well it just got argued. It's they're awaiting decision.
So, got argued yeah like last week I we listened to it. Um I
think the Supreme Court is going to have to support Cox because
I think they realize like, "Oh my god, this is going to destroy
the internet if if they don't
and they support Sony. >> Basically making like platforms
responsible for the individual users' behavior, right? In terms
of copyright infringement which is Yep. Well, and it's interesting
because in Cox's case they had like actually done as much as
they could. They had taken down all kinds of things. They had
really eliminated like 90 some percent of all the stuff that
Sony came to them with.
But they still ended up getting sued.
And yeah, they just they took it in the shorts at the trial and
they like $7 judgment against them from the jury. And this case
this case may end contributory copyright as an allegation. So,
if I'm the Reddit mods that you know lights and candles that
Alito and Clarence Thomas
want to keep this.
Have you seen the the meta lawsuit?
The it's Kadri versus Meta platforms over like AI where the court
held that like these AI models even though they're accessing
uh they're infringing
to learn because they're accessing materials to websites like
Libgen um pirated materials etc. That that doesn't constitute
infringement. That's going to have everything far more devastating
I think that's that's going to be
well, there's a bunch of these are going to have to get going
somewhere and yeah AI AI using things and you know AI just on
its own cruising the internet and hoovering up all the data it
can.
it's going to be it will be interesting
that one I think is you know that one's probably a couple years
down the road.
I don't know The issue there is I don't know if that's the fact.
Like I I understand you could like do tiny little things but
it's like a black box. Like they can't even figure out how their
models are trained, right? Like
How do you prove that you're not reasonable How's it going to
know?
Man, it's just tough to know exactly like and even if they trained
on your material, how do you know the model expresses that material
in any way?
Yeah, it's I feel like it's just going to be rough. Oh, well,
they found that these people sued because they found an iteration
of like a model that was accessing paywalled material that they
weren't supposed to be able to and like reciting it back or something
like that. I can't remember which which one it was exactly.
But it's just insane.
It's insane that they can like feed it copyright protected material
into their model, not get any permission from any of the holders,
not pay them for any of the rights, not get a license and nonetheless
that conduct is considered
legal for now. Oh, yeah, well, then >> on the basis that
like oh, well, it's using it to learn and then it's generating
like you can use that for creative purposes, but it's like by
that standard, why can't I steal a DVD or a book and then say,
oh, but I'm going to create I'm going to make creative ventures
with this information that I
I can just tell you that I so I don't know how it was accessing
paywalled material for sure, but if it was accessing it in some
way that made it public, I'm guessing they're going to argue
that a human being could do the same thing, right? And that they
aren't using it in a way they're not producing a work that infringes
on the copyright. They're essentially like looking they're like
listening to some music in a bar and then they're walking outside
and they're making a song and technically they're using little
techniques from that music, but they're not actually referencing
the music in any way, no portion of it. They're just using parts
of like like techniques in that music to go into their own [__]
So, it's like how's it different from a human being is the argument
for AI. I can see that argument. I'm not sure if
Well, it's basically >> Yeah, it [__] over
every artist that has public material anywhere. So, it's like
the implications it's like a perfect argument. It totally upends
like
copyright works like AI does, but it it's like okay. Now, we
just need I guess you just need special rules for AI.
I guess get out. >> Well, I mean there it's going to change
the rules for everything soon, so Well, >> I think the
issue is they've probably gotten all of the stuff bootstrapped
off the ground where they could just pay the damages for whatever
they do get sued for and they've got all the models bootstrapped
and they don't need to do that level of scraping anymore. They
figured out like how to do
like I think it's a low rank
low rank or something models.
>> so it's okay. >> Well, they do like these little
lightweight models that people build themselves. So, now in the
big model, you don't actually have that stuff. You have a way
for people to inject their own smaller models that they train
for specific artists for specific things to get like a stylistic
thing, right? So, they upload their own images and then they
can generate their own like AI images off of this smaller model
and like the big model still handles all of the major lifting,
but the small model handles like little stylistic things. So,
if you want to make it look like somebody like somebody's art
or something, you can do it that way and then it's on the end
user. It's not on the platform. So, they've already built the
platform. They've gotten all of the benefit from stealing the
IP and now they don't need the IP anymore and it's like what
do you even hold them liable for? I've no idea. Very crazy question.
Actually >> that's a good way to do it. Yeah, actually
real parallels to the react stuff in that XQC built a platform.
Let's say XQC is like your worst case scenario in the Ethan Klein
situation, right? He built a platform off of reacting to people's
content and now the platform's like big on its own.
so he might owe money to like all of the people technically whose
content he used or stole like over the years, but like none of
them really have that great of a case in any one instance, but
he's like massively enriched. So, for for basically not respecting
copyright, he gets like massively enriched. What do you do about
that as a society? I don't know. It's a hypothetical. It's I
mean yeah, and sometimes yeah, well, and that's if you're if
you're out on the edge, the bleeding edge of things, sometimes
you can
if you're, you know, one of the first people that does it, yeah,
you're you might be able to get away with it because you were
one of the you know, first ones to venture out
The funny thing is is that was literally his argument to Ethan
Klein. Was basically like nobody's getting copyright hit for
this. Nobody's getting punished for this. I'm going to keep doing
it until somebody stops me. You. Was like his argument. He's
like I'm I'm at the bleeding edge. I'm going to keep doing it
until somebody stops me. And now he's like made, you know, he
did his $100 million contract after So, he Yeah, some sometimes
that's good enough. You happen to be
you know, no alligators caught me at the watering hole, so
you know, you win.
Yeah, it is it's interesting.
Yeah. I I think it's funny cuz I argued he was correct at the
time, but not because he's like a good person. It's like he's
a bad person, but he's like he's totally correct that he's he
might as well just keep doing it. It's like there's just nothing
that's going to stop him and yeah, now he's got all this money
and
I don't know. There's not much else to >> Yes. Yeah, no,
good for him. Yeah, I mean he figured out how to
you know, build his empire and all that and it's like well, congrats,
I guess. Wait, I was only half listening. His his argument was
that oh, cuz he can afford to like deal with the fines that he'll
just do >> said like anybody who tells him to stop, he'll
stop, but he's not going to stop doing it as a rule until somebody
makes him stop like until the laws change or something. So, everybody
else and then he just kept doing it and he made a [__]
money and Yeah, but there's there's a lot of industries where
you there's a lot of industries where you just go like that until
somebody tells you to stop. Like the AI and that's the AI. Yeah.
Yeah, like LLMs Well, I'm I'm just saying outside AI and all
that. There's there's other There's other industries where that's
a common thing, too. Yeah, crypto literally every industry. That's
literally the story of like every industry. Dude, that's the
um that's like Uber. Yeah, Uber and every other every every basically
like I'm going to take something that's regulated and I'm going
to deregulate it and just do it via like some app. Every single
one of those basically just decided to take like we can avoid
all city ordinances and make a whole bunch of money cuz we'll
never be like regulated. Yeah. Airbnb. Yeah, all these all these
same apps basically took like a concept that existed, put it
on in a digital form and just basically broke a bunch of city
ordinances until cities caught up. Yes. Yeah.
Yeah, somebody said Napster. Yeah, well, Napster was
example of I'll go till somebody stops me and then they got literally
destroyed. I was say then they certainly did stop him. Yeah.
[snorts] So, He's like sued by everyone who's ever gone to the
Grammys.
That guy won in the end anyway cuz then he just put his money
into Facebook.
Yeah, but as somebody who actually used Napster when they were
a kid, like that that takes me back. You know that NASA Yeah,
Sean Parker. You know that NASA guy got mad money, too cuz he
was a early, so he definitely had Bitcoin. He definitely had
Bitcoin to pay for that [__]
Uh that guy's got to be insanely wealthy now. The Gilded Age
guys did that, too. Yeah. Yeah, sure. Man.
All right, is there anything else we wanted to discuss with the
H3 stuff cuz otherwise I think
shockingly, I might get back to this debate we restarted with
the off the night watching.
>> Which is a debate on H3 and >> We have transformation
to get to. Yeah. I didn't get to see any of this. What was uh
what were they actually discussing here? The differences or what
were they
Like what was Pisco saying or Hutch saying here? Motive for Ethan's
lawsuit.
Yeah, they barely get to it from what I've seen so far, but it's
it's about yeah, the motive for Ethan's lawsuit. >> I cuz
I think Pisco even agrees, yeah, this is all just about hunting
for
information, but I didn't know if they go into it further, but
all right, yeah. Well, anyways, I it's it's late here for me,
so I'm going to hit the road.
All right. I didn't do it so you can because I would like those
court filings, but I don't want to get banned from the server
again. Okay. >> if you could send those to me, too, I'd
appreciate it. I'll do that. That way I won't send them on the
server, though. See you guys. >> Perfect. Awesome. See
you around. Bye. Hey, um Okay.
Cool. We didn't even get that far into this. Hold on. I think
we're only like 30 minutes into this video. Crossed over hour
seven of the stream, 30 minutes into the video. Let's go.
The most transformative content. You have to say the thing.
>> Wait, what what's the thing?
I must play. Okay.
I'm not I'm not in on the memes. I didn't watch the show, okay?
>> They lie about like the fact that they you know, this
thing comes to mind right now is they lied about whether Costa
Rica would accept our bigger Castilla as a third country removal
and even though they said yes, we would love to accept him, you
don't have to send him to The quick Uh I should find it, but
one of his recent vids, Pisco was reacting
Ethan's reaction to Casey's apology and he was like Casey Chan
should sue Ethan for infringement because he's not transforming
[laughter]
his reaction to her apology,
which is copyright protected. I did see that. I do have a feeling
that there's like
there's got to be some rules around I don't know.
It would be funny. I mean it's not rules. It's just like the
reality of not having money.
It's like yeah, no, that's you you don't get to enforce your
IP. People people should learn. Listen, the internet's not going
to like come and jump in behind you and like support you no matter
what. I feel like I feel like I'm I'm thinking Casey and maybe
Frogan thought, okay, there's a lot of goodwill against these
guys and it's like well,
you guys are socialist streamers. It turns out a lot of your
goodwill's from poor people. They're not going to be able to
donate a whole lot to your campaign, so
good luck with that one.
Now, if you're a gooner, okay, Denims Denims crowdfunding going
tremendously better, okay?
Gooners tend to make a lot of money, it turns out.
I also think that she has the best case out of all of them for
it maybe constituting transformation.
The one Hassan was actually willing to donate to? Did he donate
to Denims?
I have no idea. Jay, he didn't donate to Casey Chan, so couldn't
even send her well-wishes, really Hasan?
Really Hasan? You couldn't even say like, "Hey man, I hope everything's
cool." Well, who knows if what's in that is true. I mean, that
entire apology is just falsehood, so I Is there any reason to
think that that's true? Most of the falsehoods are opinion-based.
I do not think he would get hurt to lie.
It's say something is not true.
I don't think that would be allowed. I don't I think there's
got to be something about that, like compelling false statements
from people. She could have donated anonymously. Let's see. Also,
she sniffed his sheets. Weird [__] man. I guess I
could also see
um like
I mean, one Hasan has no obligation to like step in and get involved.
I totally understand like why he didn't even Um it would've been
good if he had, but I totally understand why he didn't. But,
I could also see him being like say whatever you need to say
to like get out of this hell hole. Oh, yeah. Oh, he said that
Oh, dude, I know people are going to get so triggered when they
heard that. I I was like, uh whatever. And then people like,
"No, you don't understand. That's going to upset people so much."
And then it did, just triggered the [__] out of people.
What do you mean, say whatever you want? Are you saying that's
not true? It's
>> Wait, he said that?
I feel like a lot of people in public said that when when Hasan
gave the response, people were just mad that he didn't like get
angry and so on. >> Hasan's response. I didn't know that
he even addressed it. Well, he said what you said. His response
was like, "Just say whatever you want." That was That was his
response was like, "Yeah, say whatever you want." >> Whatever
you want to say about me, you can say whatever you want.
And then people are like, "Are you Or maybe I did say it and
I just don't remember it if it's if it's that if it's
>> it. Yeah, so could be one of those things. I do that
all the time.
>> I just thought of something." But, I did not just think
of it. It turns out I heard about it on stream like 3 days before
that. >> didn't see Ethan's reaction to it. Maybe I did
see this and I just like didn't
like God, that is bad. That is bad how much I'm consuming that
like I can't even like remember it, but I'm regurgitating It's
called like a phantom memory. Yeah. Or something like that. I
don't know. Like Dolly Parton talked about this when it funnily
enough when it came to like IP because there have been different
artists that have been sued because they like accidentally or
they claim incorporated like interpolations and different melodies
that are, you know, sound too much like other songs, then
uh artists try to enforce their copyright, and it's like
uh like, "You stole from me." And it's like, "No, I've never
listened to it." But then it's like, "Well, how do you Could
you even remember every single song that you've ever listened
to? Maybe you listened to it in a store you didn't even realize
it. And then you ended up putting it in your music." I think
that same thing happens with comedy as well, yeah. Like same
concept, basically like you end up copying a joke, but it's like,
"Did you copy it? Or is it like natural that you think of that?
Or did you hear part of it somewhere else?"
>> It's probably a little different, but that's how that's
where I know that that idea from, that you like think you came
up with it and you didn't. Or people just steal jokes. Not sure
which. All right, I'm going to Uh like there's no reason to do
that. You can just send them here. And when Trump lies about
that, I'm like, "Yes. This is a worse lie than a potential lie
about a copyright lawsuit, okay?" All I'm just saying though
is not that there aren't lies that one lie can be better or worse.
If you lie about whether, you know, your girlfriend looks fat
in a dress, if you lie about like, you know, I'm not saying that
all lies are created equal. What I'm just mainly saying is in
general, we would be against Ethan in the sense of we would condemn
him lying about his intentions. We would say it's bad, right?
Like misleading his audience about uh the reason behind a lawsuit.
And I think that you would grant me that, fair? But, what's the
value of like yes, but like what's the value of this hypothetical
when we know the
Why don't we just get to the particulars? You like you're trying
to establish this framework, you know, you're trying to
me on this journey. I I don't want it to be the case that I get
you to agree that there's a lie, and then you be like, "But,
I don't care." But, I just Hang on. I just I just said a moment
ago, "I don't think that like I think when Ethan
talks I think everybody >> He's got yes future sight. What?
It's highly effective. >> motivated Ethan.
in the first place. And I I I think it is both of these things,
like the personal grievance that he had with with these people
for their contribution
to his family's very real like
suffering and harassment.
And I think he also cares about um malicious react content as
evidenced by his Right. Right. previous history of addressing
this thing. >> suffering. There is no evidence he lied
or the evidence you you you don't believe that he necessarily
lied or that he did lie at all. I understand that that's your
position that he didn't in fact lie. [clears throat]
malicious react content as evidenced by his Right. Right. previous
history of addressing this thing. So >> Am I being insensitive?
It's just like
it it it's just it's like an opera.
>> like the Young and the an episode of the Young and the
Restless, the the suffering of the of the Kleins, the multi-millionaire
YouTubers
with the dream life that 0.0001%
of humanity ever gets to have.
And the petty inconveniences
of online internet fame. I mean, it's not totally petty. I do
think the CPS call is actually serious.
I don't think it's all petty. I just think after the after the
CPS call I don't think this To be honest, I hate to I hate to
be the guy in the skulls. I don't think the skulls are like transparently
worse or obviously worse or significantly worse.
I know it seems crazy to say than basically somebody having your
address, having like your docs, and then threatening to kill
you. I don't think it's like significantly significantly worse.
Like if you think somebody's crazy and they're they know your
address, it's basically like the same
So I personally like it's it's an escalation, but it's like not
even that crazy an escalation. So, I think the CPS call is like
the really really really bad thing, and then the other stuff
is like online harassment. That's
I might just be being too good faith cuz it's like pain, sure.
Harassment, sure. Suffering, no. I draw the line at saying it's
suffering. But, the CPS thing or whatever, like it could be one
of those things that like and likely is regardless of how much
You can have all the money in the world, but if a CPS agent comes
to your house, even if there's a like 0.01% chance of anything
like custody of your kids actually being threatened, it's still
scary as [__]
Yeah, and you just don't know like the kids get asked questions,
and it's just like uncomfortable. It's just like anything involved
involving like with your kids. I I hate the idea of, right? Yeah,
and then you never know if your kids say something stupid,
right? It's so high stakes.
Hey, like do your dogs poop on the ground? Yeah, there's always
poop on the ground. There's like I eat the poop some Like if
they just say something stupid in this one case where you're
not
for it, at which kids can do sometimes. I don't know if you guys
have ever heard about this, but sometimes kids just make [__]
>> They sometimes just make [__] up.
So, yeah, I get it. It's like scary.
All right.
There is no evidence he lied or the evidence you you you don't
believe that he necessarily lied or that he did lie at all. I
understand that that's your Uh this is To me, this is the exact
same thing as Piers
and mentioning Fuentes' real name. It's like, "Yeah, I can say
Basically like on the person who did the bad action mostly."
I'm like, "Dude, you did something stupid, Piers. Why did you
mention his name? Why did you go after this guy's dad?" But then
it's also like, "Nick, hey, are you a Why the [__]
you telling stories about your dad on
With Nick, it's a little less bad cuz he wasn't saying it to
like, you know, 30,000 people. He was way smaller at that time,
but very similar. It's like, "Yeah, don't discuss your personal
[__] on stream. It's pretty obvious, man." your position
that he didn't in fact lie. What I'm trying to suggest to you
is if he did, you can understand why someone would condemn it.
And that What do you think he lied about though? Why don't we
get to that? What do you think he lied about? Okay, let's let's
get it. Let's get right to it. I think he lied that his motivation
for the lawsuit was to protect the react community. That's number
one. That's the first lie. So, I've identified a lie. And uh
you can you can confront me and say, "He never actually said
that." I think that would be an absurd thing to say. Number two
lie. He lied when he said that Keemstar's apology was sincere.
I think that those at a bare minimum are two uh significant lies
that we should, if true, and I think you should grant me it.
If it's true he lied about those two things or either of those
two two things, you would condemn it, fair?
I think uh not necessarily now because I think that I think I
I think I agree with you. Okay.
So, we're just okay with dishonesty now? Cool. This is he does
this a couple times throughout the debate where he's just like,
"Listen.
Listen. I can I don't I don't want to sewer alley at all, but
like I don't want to But, it's just like I can come up with a
situation where lying is okay. I can figure out I can like wish
cast something into existence." peppered a little mustard on
on the idea that Keemstar was being sincere.
I think he kind of I think it was a kind of gloating for him.
I think it was a kind of feigned mag mag being like magnanimous.
Well, you you don't think he was being sincere when he told his
audience not What's in It's like so these inferences that they
off of
the off of just like again
it's so clear to me that they are just outright lies, not even
told well. They're the laziest lies. It's like little kids lying.
Now, I'm just spitballing here. Okay, hold on. Hold on. I'm just
spitballing here. But, do you have any proof that Ethan Klein
being
man, do you have any proof that he is not the Messiah?
I just feel like he might be the Messiah, you know, predicted
by the Abrahamic faiths. He might Do you have any evidence he's
not? Like I just want some evidence that he's not the Messiah.
Do you I'm just saying it's not it's not inappropriate to lie
in all contexts, and here's an example. If if I had to hide the
clients in my attic, I would do I'm that kind of person.
And that would be righteous. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Attack Casey trying to Not good when we start making
these references. I'm not even the one making them. This is [__]
up. And this was a sincere apology? No, no, no. I I I think he
was being sincere there. I I think he was trying And then we
were talking about suffering. We were just talking about suffering.
So, that's like where my mindset's at. It's like let's just make
this as dramatic as possible. Let's just make everyone who could
conceivably be a victim why half-ass it? Just go all the way.
They make them the biggest victim of all time
in this uh scenario. It We're going there, you know? If we're
going to compare them, might may as well compare it to,
you know, one of the biggest tragedies. Just go for it.
Anything else would be downplaying their
Did you ever see them talk about that guy who was wearing the
um the uniform with the pig mask in
Oh. It's a very funny podcast segment, unrelated. You think uh
H3 H3 the H3 podcast did a whole thing and it was very funny.
I think he was trying to mitigate like, yeah. Or or maybe he
was may- Wait, is that the Bel-Air pogroms? That's not the same
thing, right? That's a different instance, is it not? Is is it
it's not I'm not referencing the Bel-Air pogroms without realizing
it's the same event, am I? Cuz I remember reacting to it and
I feel like the Bel-Air pogroms video came out like way later.
I Well, I might be. I just might be tired and referencing the
same thing. Hold on. Hold on. >> The Beverly Hills pogroms?
Bel-Air
I'll see if I can find it real quick before I keep going. Give
me a second. Okay, Twitter, do your thing. Load up. Okay. Uh
we're doing cries out. They're not allowed to cry. It's what
Like that's the blatant
dis- violent anti-Semitism that is oozing off these people. If
you can't see it, then we're basically just going I mean,
where are we going? It it feels like we're it was during the
war in the Holocaust. In the Holocaust. It's just it's reminiscent
of that time. Oh my
My sk- PS My A human skull is in the mail. My sk- each not Sorry.
My Bel-Air
She and cries out. Were they reading Aristocracy tweets? Oh,
that's I mean, we always compare it, you know, that's why we
call them the the Toronto the GTA pogroms, okay? Hey, why is
there a This is dry as the [__] Sahara. Oh, it's
Zikgers. I see.
I didn't see that. I see Queen Man arguing with an anime girl
in Tucker's stream. The
Uh wait, Shamoun, now that you can just answer this for me. This
is when it was the pig guy the guy in the uniform with the pig
mask, right? That's what they're talking about here? Just to
get that on the record so I can remember for later.
Seems like it'd be important. Maybe honestly, maybe he was feeling
magnanimous in the moment. But when you when you watched I watched
the opening of that stream. And the vibes were pretty clear.
Like he opened the stream. I mean, that was a [__]
victory lap. Like he was gloating. Like he was gloating throughout
the Amazing. Amazing. Maybe he was feeling magnanimous in the
moment. Let's let's just analyze how specific that claim is.
Maybe meaning there is a non-zero chance meaning it's technically
possible he was feeling magnanimous
meaning generous to his enemies in that particular moment, that
isolated incident. There's a possibility that this occurred.
And then the next statement that he says completely undermines
that and he's like, "Hell yeah, brother. Victory lap." Okay,
dude.
It's like and I I just feel like I'm being an ass, but when I
was talking to Roly, that's like the thing I see a lot with people
like this and I try with other people I'll just be like an ass.
I'll be like the whole I'll just tell them they're like a I'll
go off, okay? But it's like I'm trying to just very specifically
say it seems like you're setting up a way to inject your subjective
opinion of Ethan the fact that you want to defend Ethan Klein
into everything. Like to use that subjective opinion to override
any facts that are
And it's like really irritating to argue in those cases. Oh,
it's it's insufferable.
But what it really is
is not actually coming up with plausible scenarios that are actually
happening. It's possible defenses that Ethan could have made
to explain his behavior, but didn't. Because we all know Everybody
seems to know that it's like not really about
And even Hutch seems like gleeful saying this. He's He sounds
like there's like a like a high five like a a verbal high five
happening
to Ethan. >> Yeah. Most people are like totally happy to
admit that after a little while. That like you argue with them
for a little bit and they're like, "Well, yeah, sure. We all
know Ethan's a little spiteful." Cuz I think Hutch gets there
and Hutch might get there in this conversation. "Well, we all
know Ethan's a little spiteful." Why the [__] do
we have to argue before this? Why couldn't you just started here?
It's the not not picking the right hill to die on. They say this
is their issue and then they lose on that issue entirely and
they're like, "Well, but let's Isn't Don't we all know Ethan's
a little petty?" Aren't we all a little
Isn't everyone a little bit petty? Doesn't everyone just sometimes
sue three people for copyright infringement to get them to retract
their statements online
to win a drama on the internet?
I know I once got an argument with a guy on Reddit and I sued
him for
damaging my vehicle, okay?
To get him to retract
a win he got in a Reddit argument to get him to delete his posts
so I didn't look stupid online, okay? Isn't that aw- Don't we
all do that sometimes? I'm really stretching to try to come up
with something here. I'm going to hit the the whole stream. But
do you think that in the moments when he said, "Casey Tron's
being sincere. Don't attack Casey Tron. We understand her plight.
We understand what's going on." You think that was part of the
kind of like wink wink gloating or you think that he was being
sincere when he was trying to tell his audience not to go after
her? And if he wasn't being sincere, you got another problem
there, right? Cuz then he's Yeah, the plight that she's going
through because I'm suing her is what he leaves out. Because
I'm suing her. What she's going through because I'm putting her
through it. Yeah.
is being said. That is Sorry, that is being left out. I I get
how she's like really upset, okay? I've been sued before and
I wouldn't wish that on anybody. Like since we're again like
just indulge your like have a flair for the dramatic tonight.
It's like Stalin-esque behavior. Like getting people in the gulags
to sign your birthday card type demanding this sort of adoration
from your victims. Do you like the gulags? Okay, tell me I have
a big It's a Stalin impression. Legitimately that No, I I don't
do accents. Every one of my accents turns into Indian eventually,
but I swear to god
I think the thing unfortunately has legs cuz it's just his ego
every time and I can't think of a better metaphor than some insecure
dude's ego than his dick. Okay? It's like just straight up the
way people usually talk about it. That's like what it is to me.
It's straight up that. It's so transparent and I also know that
it would irritate the [__] out of him if he heard
it. So, audience, you should continue to do it. So, you got to
>> No, no, no. I I think he was being sincere. Like you
can Both things Both things can be true. Both things like he
can be gloating and at the same time he can, you know, like have
a better angel in him.
What? Well, actually he was gloating and didn't want people to
harass her and he wasn't joking then either.
Guys,
guys, I'm just I'm just going to, you know, if I start from a
place of Ethan is good no matter what, you can say some really
special things, guys. You can say some really awesome things,
some really cool things. And then And then he can be my kid and
feel
You know, I don't feel more bad so bad about it that I want to
stop beating them, but I can't It is true that I as I'm beating
my child repeatedly day in day out, I do feel, you know, guilty.
I do feel bad sometimes. Like I see the bruises I leave and I'm
like, "Oh, that looks pretty bad. But, you know, no contradictions
there.
No spare the rod and all that. But I I recognize that there's
a difference in terms of whether something is a lie. If there's
a kind of True. Your kid was really [__] annoying
though. So, like I don't actually feel bad for your kid. Your
kid really should have like thought about not being such a [__]
loser. Yeah. Did you think about that? >> really an argument
to like bring back Keemstar, to be honest. Yeah. And when you
put it in that when you when you, you know, compare it to that
and think about the fact that like, you know, we're in a post
witch trial era. Like there's worse and like, you know, there's
certain like child laws that like forbid me from, you know, striking
them harder. This is actually nothing. It's actually kind. I
didn't think about that. How is W child beating, okay? A general
understanding that this is uh some kind of farce or display where
you're not expected to believe it. But you don't think that he
was trying to do that with respect to his statements about, "Guys,
Casey Tron, I believe this is a very sincere apology, very nice
apology. Don't go after her." You think when he did that No,
I think that That wasn't that, right? That wasn't him being insincere.
He was being sincere, wasn't he? No, I think that was him trying
to be responsible in terms of like moderating his community.
So, was he being sincere? Or Maybe. Prob- I don't know. I I think
like listen, I think I think I don't know Ethan that well, to
be honest with you. I don't really know like I can't speak to
his character, but I have seen him in the past demonstrate sympathy
for people, even people that he didn't like. So, for all I know,
in that moment Just bizarre. Again like he's being responsible
and for for moderating his community in response to the reaction
that he financially coerced out of this
That's like, "Okay, yeah, he's, you know, making the [__]
chimpanzee
dance
for the ninth hour for the people that come to this this cheap
circus, but he doesn't allow them to throw tomatoes or jeer.
If they just like what You can spectate quietly. >> tomatoes
and now that the chimpanzees apologized for [__]
up the juggling act, now he's like, "I said I told them, 'Okay,
guys, I get it. No more tomatoes now.' They apologized. They
like got mad about [__] up the juggling. >> you're
leaving out that he installed a glass
pane between the chimpanzee and the audience to, you know, so
the tomatoes can't get through, and I honestly think it's [__]
up you don't even mention that. You looks like you don't even
want to give him credit for anything. It's like you just [__]
hate Ethan some credit? Like, W Ethan.
How did he keep going after the skulls were sent? How did he
keep I wouldn't have had the strength, okay? I would have just
killed myself. If I got those skulls in the mail, I would have
been like, "Oh, somebody's going to hurt me." Brains on the wall,
okay? >> reminding me of Piers Morgan and all these other
right-wing journalists that were going around once the ceasefire,
quote unquote, the most recent ceasefire happened. And it was
like, "Do you give Trump credit, though? You want to give Trump
credit credit for that? Can you give him credit?
Can you like >> that after the most recent
Russia-Ukraine ceasefire as well. Hey, shouldn't we give Trump
credit for this? It's like, "Oh, let's see what happens." Oh,
Russia violated the ceasefire. Oh, can we give Trump credit for
that?
No, not like that. No. Yeah. No, I'm I'm good. I'm good.
Same deal, man. >> seen him in the past demonstrate sympathy
for people, even people that he didn't like. So, for all I know,
in that moment, like he can But like I said, both of the things
can be happening at the same time. So, he can feel a I just think
that And I didn't do this with Rally, so I should have I should
have been better about this. I think I even probably interrupted
him too much so that he couldn't get this all out. But it's like,
can you just give me your positive position on how this went
down and like what happened? Cuz it does feel like Hutch is trying
to basically explain how at all times Ethan is really the good
guy. Once I saw him be nice, and so I think like in that one
moment he was being nice, but then before that he also was like
being mean, and then other times he's being nice. It's like,
could you just His stream is really that, though.
It's That's what it would be. Cuz Ethan is nice to him. It's
really shocking
how often
that's the case.
This person was nice to me, and so I'm going to sweep for them
no matter what. Uh I am susceptible to this, obviously.
>> these hoes ain't loyal. It's It's shocking how often
this happens. What sense of satisfaction >> shocking that
they didn't print out the the script to Full Metal Jacket for
the scene where he's having to confront the fact, justify to
the officer why he's wearing a helmet that says born to kill
but has a peace button, and then starts talking about the Jungian
duality of man. I do not know this this scene. I do not know
the reference. You've never seen Full Metal Jacket?
Oh, Full Metal Jacket. The Stanley Kubrick movie.
Oh, no, I've definitely seen Full Metal Jacket. I don't remember
that part, to be honest with you. I sorry. >> Really? It's
the part where Joker is like They're like, "Why are you wearing
I get it when he It's when he first goes to Vietnam, right? He
literally just arrives, and they ask him about it, right? He's
like fresh off the plane. Yeah, I probably I just don't remember.
I'll be honest. I probably watched that movie when I was too
young to really even know who Jung was, so You've been watching
it since you were like a child? I don't know. I might have watched
it when I was in my like early 20s or late
But I >> Oh, when you were a child? >> I used to
have a really bad engagement with media. No, I used to have a
horrible engagement with media. I really hated um No Country
for Old Men. I hated that movie, and it was just based on not
understanding anything about that movie. I had like horrible,
horrible engagement with any media I watched.
And what no media literacy does to a
Yeah, no, it was like it was actually It's really funny cuz I
I like watched some movies as an adult, and I just had no idea
how to understand anything about
And then I went back and watched them like 10 years later, and
I'm like, "Wait, these movies are incredible." But I just earlier
in life had no media literacy, yeah. It was basically like just
rough. I think I >> to watch it for like so many years.
I barely watched it with Lycan because like I had multiple male
friends begging me to watch It was always Training Day or No
Country for Old Men. And I was like, "No, I'm not watching these
movies." Why Why this Why are you Why are men constantly trying
to get you to watch Top Gun? I've never seen I There's a cultural
divide on that one. I don't even know if I've seen Top Gun, but
yeah, okay. What do I try to get people to watch?
True Detective. And then maybe maybe Fight Club if somebody tells
me they've not seen Fight Club before. I'm like, "Okay, you should
watch Fight Club, okay?" I'm that I know I'm that guy, I [__]
it. I'm just going to hit play. that he got um like like justice
was served. Like there were there were consequences for bad behavior
that negatively impacted him, his wife, his family. And at the
same time, he can also have a part of him that that that that
wanted to be responsible with his moderating of his community
in that moment to to prevent there from from the the the the
war or whatever from from blowing up even further. He can be
motivated by multiple things at the same time. So, I'm not When
you say he can be motivated by things, it's very important, right?
And I'm not trying to just be like super
about how we use the words, but it really matters. Like, when
we say can,
like I will always grant that it can be the case if what you
mean by can is It's just essentially anytime you're like, "Well,
hypothetically, is there any reason he couldn't" It's like, "Okay,
you're about to say something totally worthless. Could you save
everyone's time, please? Like, you you are actually about to
say something that is not helpful to the conversation whatsoever.
I need you to think about it and not do it. Well, it's possible
Isn't it possible that Yes. I'm probably just going to say yes
unless you want to make a claim that you think that's what happened
or you think it's likely that that happened, then [__]
off. Stop wasting my time.
is it doesn't entail a logical contradiction, right? So, if you
ask me, "Isn't it possible that Ethan could have two motives?"
I'm going to say, "Yes, it is possible," by which I mean it is
not entailing a logical contradiction. So, you just have to be
very, very careful when you say that cuz I'm going to every time
you say that going to say, "If by possible, do you mean logically
possible? If by can, do you mean entails a contradiction?"
>> It Pisco just needs a shorthand for this, okay? Come
up with a shorthand that mocks the other person. Is it possible?
what What did Kevin Garnett say? Anything is possible!
>> And then you just you hit a soundboard or something,
and then you move on cuz I like make a claim, please.
Logically possible. I'll say it that way. It is logically possible
to be That's nothing, right? to gloat and show sympathy for your,
you know, Uh-oh, this is this is the one Pisco part where I'm
like, "Oh, this is a rough one." That's nothing, right? It's
to gloat and show sympathy for your, you know, conquered foe
at the same time. What I'm telling you is it's It's logically
possible for you to be Literally at the same time, no, I don't
think so.
In those if you want to say he's switching from moment to moment,
then
my god.
Isn't it Isn't it possible to gloat and show sympathy at the
same time? No, I don't think so. I I do think like they actually
contradict pretty well. be able to jump to the moon right now.
>> Isn't it possible that if the internet didn't exist,
Ethan Klein would be the type of guy to scream at traffic? He'd
be the kind of guy who had like a notepad and a camera by his
window, and he'd like rise up the the one blind, and then he'd
see somebody doing something annoying in the front yard, and
he'd like take a picture, and then he would write it down
if the internet didn't exist.
That's Ethan Klein. Pretty confident.
Pretty confident that's possible. 90% 90% sure. No, I'm making
a solid claim. I'm like 90% sure that would be
Like, I'm not I'm not saying it's possible. I'm saying it's probable.
In fact, it's almost bordering on
Sorry, we're about to hear Pisco's best moment best moment of
the debate. Give me a second. It's logically possible for you
to be able to jump to the moon right now. All we mean by logical
possible Now,
technically, in the frame of reference Pisco's operating from,
he's trying to say there is nothing without any other external
rules, the statement follows that you could jump to the moon
right now. With no other external rules, okay?
But the way that sounds is not reasonable to most people. Most
people hear that, and they're like They're like, "Wait, no, it's
not. What the [__] He should have done He should
have said it's it's possible reality is like a
Something like that. Yeah. >> obvious what he's getting
at immediately because people are like, "Wait, no, that's literally
not possible based off of like information that we know in existing
scientific postulates. It's not
Yeah, and what he means is like absent a frame of reference,
absent like a set of rules. And it's like, "But that I feel like
that's almost certainly like a law school thing. He just got
like a law school bit in here that makes him look
I I can I said this the second I saw this. I was like, "Oh, this
is the moment Destiny's going to react to this, and then he's
going to like pop up out of his chair and go, 'Oh my I can't
I can't even with this guy. He's so dumb.'" And then he's going
to shut his stream off and walk away for 5 minutes. I'm I mean,
I have like a I guess like a soft rule that I don't want to say
the word logic ever in a in a debate because it will always come
off, and understandably so, as incredibly condescending to your
interlocutor, even if it's the best way to describe what you're
getting at, which is like talking about like like getting into
like play laying out premise premise conclusion and like logical
algebra effectively, but in like logic 101, but like you don't
want to do that. What you want to do is like basically I like
to Hutch, I would have been like, "Okay, that's possible, but
is it probable?" That's all I would have said. I wouldn't have
done this like, "If If what you mean by this, that's this." Cuz
it just doesn't I think it really [__] off the other
person. Hutch is in California, right? Like it's possible if
you jump off the Golden Gate Bridge, you discover a propensity
for spontaneous human flight. It's possible.
But like is that worth me bringing up to you?
We could test this out. We could see how possible it is. Or that
you you'd
It's possible you'd survive, sure.
Is it likely? No.
That's a that's a different one, sure. No, I mean by I like I
like doing the crazy things that are technically Technically
that is possible. It's possible we don't actually understand
physics well enough. Okay, I guess that maybe that's just jump
to the moon. Listen, maybe I do the same thing Pisco would do.
>> Uh what are you talking about? How is that logically
possible? Because the definition of logical possibility, the
modality of possibility we're talking about there is specifically
about whether or not there's a contradiction entailed by it.
So, I would be When I say something like Ethan could I feel like
I would be contradicting the laws of physics. Right. So, that's
that's that's like a different like if you take as given the
laws of physics, then you can establish a contradiction in that
the laws of physics Okay, I I know but what But but but then
you're introducing
That's why you don't pursue this line of
I do but yeah. But but then you're
Pisco's right.
Pisco's totally right.
Uh-oh. Pisco just got totally
by a face.
He just He just got completely by a face. What can he do?
First Hutch W. This crazy guy. Look at this crazy guy. of physics
and these external rules that aren't necessitated by the situation
itself. And so that's why it matters to talk about this because
what people will hear when you say isn't it possible that Ethan
Klein has two motives and I answer yes to that is oh well he
just gave the game away because he's saying that it's possible
to have two motives. No, I'm giving you I'm giving you my best
answer. I'm giving But I'm In the absence of certainty because
I have not personally reached out to Ethan and asked Don't say
that that's your best answer. Don't admit that your best answer
is that you can't follow the conversation.
My I mean is he not referring to this whole situation where he
wildly different differentiates between how Ethan's feeling at
any given moment in time to still be a good person while acting
the exact way he does?
Is Is that not what he's talking about?
I mean if he's talking about that then like yeah in that framework
that really is the best you can muster up which is just like
the possibility of a vibe that you could describe to someone
that could potentially justify this in some hypothetical or whatever,
but I think at the beginning of this or tell me if I'm misremembering,
he was like can't I just, you know, talk about all of this stuff
for hours on end but basically be agnostic on it? Basically not
have strong feelings on it. And I think that's that's like Which
by the way is what he stated very early on.
In fact, this is the exact word he used was that he was like
agnostic on it. Yeah. He said he was agnostic and it turns out
that being agnostic, well that somehow turned into I can hypothetically
twist this into anything and make it seem like he's a good person.
>> Agnosticism is when you're like endlessly charitable
to one side
and not to the other and what's not agnostic whatsoever. [laughter]
That's all I can say, okay? If you like
Uh yeah, no. Haven't you heard of intelligent design? I'm an
agnostic but haven't you heard of intelligent design? Look at
how Look at how this banana fits in my hand.
How could you be agnostic? I mean I'm I'm agnostic but how could
you be agnostic? What motivated you to do that? The closer thing
is more like I'm I'm agnostic but I'm just going to live my life
according to Pascal's Wager because I'm terrified of the possibility
of hell and hell in this context is like drawing the wrath and
ire of Ethan Klein. Maybe. I don't But I don't think that's what
it is. I don't think that's why most people do sweeping. I think
it's just like there's they've just established a massive demand
for pro-Ethan
Like there's just online there's just a massive demand for pro-Ethan
content. Yeah, and from people that are not already like that
were not already previously associated with Ethan.
Like the >> Cuz it doesn't mean anything if you support
Ethan but you've like always been a friend or something like
that. Hutch coming out and doing it, right? Or like even Asmongold
is like then they can point to these people and be like I never
thought I'd see the day that even Asmongold would have to admit
that I'm obviously correct
or or Keemstar but crazy world we live in that that's that's
just how correct I
And trying to pretend it's that and not a function of the fact
that like no, you've just like strayed really really far from
where you like where you used to be.
What? I don't even know. Did he stray
much? What did he stray on? I should say from like where the
public's perception of him was. Because yeah, if you actually
like dig into the brass tacks of like the details of a lot of
these things outside of a few controversies, he actually does
not look very good. And like obviously these a lot of people
have dug that up now.
Like the Boston mar- Is it the Boston Marathon victim bombing
marathon like that [__]
Yeah. I think um
Well, I think that's becoming more and more true. I think that's
why he fights with like Tik Tok people now, right? It's like
mostly Tik people on Tik Tok don't like this guy. Like all of
the super soy Tik Tok people, all the normies on Tik Tok are
like not fans. And so I feel like there are a couple people who
have done YouTube videos who are like kind of I feel like way
more Tik Tok adjacent that
he's brought on to fight with recently. But maybe I'm mistaken
it.
Yeah. So, I don't know. Have you reached out to Trump and asked
him the motivations about his malicious acts?
This is also >> And by the way, when I do this comparison,
I'm not saying Ethan is the same as Trump. Guys, okay. Everyone
could know that I want to make sure I want to I want to inoculate
myself against that. When I made the comparison to Trump, I wasn't
saying Ethan is like Trump. It's a comparison.
But it's like but it's like you're you're claiming that I have
Uh
maybe. >> And I don't. I I'm giving you my my vibe, my
best guess from my observation. >> But that's not I'm not
asking you to say 100%
but I'm at 99%
>> well then you know, like you don't have a You have an
issue with me saying it's possible. Cuz I can't prove to you
right now that you're not a brain in a vat, that Ethan doesn't
actually exist, that you're just a figment of my imagination.
Like there's so much that I cannot prove 100%, right? Like I
can't prove that 100% that we live on a sphere. By 100% we mean
to an epistemic certainty. So, understand what I'm saying here
is we're stepping way back to talk about like possibility in
the abstract. And the only reason I'm doing this >> are.
You're because you're debate bro-ing me right now. It's It's
not It's It's It's really weird. Actually, there's nothing that
makes me more insane
than basically Hutch refusing to engage in hypotheticals or refusing
to like engage in good faith in any of this like conversation.
Just
essentially going like oh, you don't agree with the thing that
I'm saying is obviously common sense. Well, you're just debate
bro-ing me right now.
We could debate tactic.
>> Yeah, it's actually so frustrating. It's like performative
It's so [__] annoying.
Uh that's why that my tweet I think this might have been what
I tweeted about
Um Where did I post this tweet up here? It's like literally what
I was tweeting about is like just don't ever debate with Hutch
without a moderator. Like you need a moderator present who's
going to say like Soy Pill did.
Um where Soy Pill was like hey Hutch, just pretend you can like
engage with the hypothetical real quick. And then Hutch was forced
to actually say something although I don't even know that he
engaged, right? This like performative ignorance, this performative
like I don't I don't even know what you're doing right now, man.
What are you even saying right now? Throwing the faces at the
camera. It's like crazy making.
Yeah. Hutch, is there a sniper rifle pointed at you right now?
Yeah, exactly. When there's somebody else there to point out
what he's doing, then you can't be crazy made as badly.
But he does absolutely crazy make people. It's It's like
really transparent and not something you
Like I don't know. Uh it's just not something you should do to
someone you're saying is a friend in my opinion. Yeah, okay.
Anyway. It's like rhetorical pearl clutching. It is the worst.
If I Uh the sad thing is is I think it just works. I think it's
just like a good
to do this when you're like totally like owned in a debate when
you basically have to Basically what Hutch would have to do here
is engage in good faith and admit that he got some stuff wrong
or you would have to pretend to be a Right? Y'all think it's
intentional or he's just lazy and dumb? No, it's definitely intentional.
It's definitely intentional when he >> that right now?
Like this is crazy, man. Are you really You're really going to
argue that? Oh my god. No, right now? That's what you're doing?
That's the Tucker thing. I didn't say that. I don't I would never
say that.
Do you have any of your mind? Are you
Sorry, it's like the same cadence, same feeling, same level of
gaslighting. Pisco Ah, do the laugh. I Dude, I won't do the laugh
tonight. I'll voice crack so hard it'll be embarrassing. Really
not a >> laugh for 10 subs.
10 subs, maybe. >> Bro, because what will happen is you'll
ask isn't it Dude, Tucker Sorry. Tucker's laugh we could both
agree is like the most psychopathic thing that's ever been done
on any podcast ever,
Where he's like telling his story and he just laughs like the
Joker in the middle of telling a story. Like my son who is like
3 years
It's insane. And how red he gets. He just like He just Yeah,
throws his head back and like laughs at something he like like
like his squeezes his eyes shut and he's like beet red.
It is It is kind of like uncanny valley.
I can't get to the octave I need to. I try to do it too loud
and then I But I I can't get to the octave sometimes but it's
crazy the way he does it. The only time I found I think that
the time that I found it like the most
the like the Ted Cruz versus Tucker Carlson. Him doing that constantly
in that thing was
tickling me. You don't even know You don't even know the Democrats
of the countries you want to bomb?
>> Sorry, I don't I didn't get it there. I'm going to listen
to it right now.
>> My god.
That was a little closer, I think. Sorry, I can I'll work on
it, okay? I'm going to I'm going to bookmark this and I'll work
on it, okay?
Done. Bookmarked. We got it. Go go go >> This is the laugh
that like a frat boy gives to you after you say you're going
to report him to the dean for you. Yeah, that's like Like which
is what he is. He's like a fancy last school kid. Yeah, it's
like his entire physiognomy is that, yeah. Do you know who my
dad is?
>> I'm sorry. Uh really not an attempt to debate, bro,
because what will happen is you'll ask isn't it possible that
Ethan has two motivations? And if I say no, I sound ridiculous
because Talk him through it. >> can have mixed motives.
gentle parenting You're like debate bro. You're because you're
debate bro-ing me right now. >> it's it's it's it's really
not an attempt to debate, bro, because what will happen is you'll
ask isn't it possible that Ethan has two motivations? And if
I say no, I sound ridiculous because of course people can have
mixed motives, right? Of course You don't think that. Why don't
we Why don't we skip to that? Right. So so I I just want to clarify
No, he thinks it's possible to have a mixed motive. He thinks
it's very unlikely that the any other motive plays a significant
factor here than just the one we all agree plays a significant
factor, okay?
Like you keep saying copyright plays a significant factor. It
does not. It does not at all. And it's pretty obvious from everything
that's going on.
Um Hutch has been around for a long time without any significant
growth. He's definitely had massive Twitter growth from doing
the Ethan Klein the Hassan is bad bit. Right? So I don't know
about his stream. I assume >> who just put Hutch also vapes,
so gross.
Like if you if you do this type of content for long enough, the
chat will eventually descend into like everything about this
person is disgusting when you think about it. Like [laughter]
This is why I I try and I really try not to do stuff like this
cuz I don't like seeing it. I think it's Yeah, I think they just
want to [__] talk and they I think that person probably
finds vaping like really gross, but would they bring it up if
it was like um
I don't know if it's some friend of the stream Queenman or something
on stream vaping. I don't know if they bring it up the same way,
right? >> It's not that serious. No, it's not. It really
But that's what I mean. It's like I know that people are just
like making They're just like writing down the insults that they're
thinking because they're in an environment that's going to be
permissive of it cuz everybody's like dogpiling on [laughter]
it. What Hold on. I think So when people dogpile on Rally, I'll
say something, but like unfortunately with Hutch
I've started to see some cracks in the visage that make me think
that Hutch is not like uh I thought he was just like a really
good person. He seems kind of like he a little more calculated
now. It's like stopping being like just a ha ha ha ha.
I don't know. We can talk about it after. We'll see We'll see
what he what he gets into like some of the reasons he like cut
somebody off or something. He's like talking about Oh, when he
talks about like Oh, with the Bad Empanada thing, right?
He like starts talking about how it's so unacceptable to watch
any Bad Empanada content ever because of how bad a person Bad
Empanada is and the things he's done. I'm just like, brother
I watched your stream yesterday. Please stop. Please stop with
the performativity. Please stop.
Anyway, I'm going to keep watching. Bad Empanada owns Hutch.
I don't like Bad Empanada. I'm just saying that Hutch is
is goofy, okay? What do you What do you think? Right right. So
I I just This is really important. I want to clarify when I say
he doesn't have mixed motive, I'm not saying it's impossible
for a person to have mixed motive. I'm saying the evidence that
we have is uh I think strong that this motivation, the particular
motivation that I'm citing, isn't what's actually motivating.
But but before we get into that because I I do want to get into
that. I just want to like get an agreement. If he did since like
lie about CaseyTrons apology and whether it was sincere
are you suggesting that you would say that that was good to do?
If the purpose of the lie was to prevent harassment, for example,
would you say that that would be bad? I think that it would that
if you felt that an apology on anti-Semitism,
on whether or not uh it was right to invoke >> the lie
is to prevent harassment?
So like is he lying about So then
Hold on.
What's the lie here? >> that when we take this hostage
is actually good? It promotes diplomatic relations between [laughter]
our country because we can use them as leverage. Hold on hold
on hold on. It's like if he is feeling totally So No no no. Be
Be real with what Hutch is saying here. He's saying um Like I
think Hutch would or I think Ethan was trying to take a victory
lap, but he also doesn't want to harass, maybe even as a function
of the lawsuit. So he's going to say we like her Oh okay okay
okay. >> So he's lying under the pretext that he'll say
like I Like you can lie and say, "Well, don't harass her and
all that." I think that's where he's trying to go. Yeah yeah
yeah. Okay, I got I got you. I got you. But he could have just
said nothing. That's That's the thing. He's like we're presenting
a false binary where Ethan has to react to it instead of it just
being allowed and he doesn't say anything or whatever, but
it it's just weird to begin with to extract and coerce that apology
from her in the first place. Yeah, it's definitely weird. >> everything
that comes after that was always going to be convoluted and weird
because of like the platforms and like the TOS that they demand
even though the law permits this disgusting behavior and like
having to reconcile that and present it to the public. Yeah.
I thought he was saying like the lie being that like he's preventing
harassment of him and his family by forcing them to like do these
apologies and stuff like that. That's what I thought he was saying
that in response to. Okay. Yeah, that makes more sense then.
I also just got a notification that I think you would might you
might really enjoy. Hold on, let me click on this. Ben
>> argument is a hoax. >> It's a hoax. I feel like
Democrats literally just lost an election doing the same thing.
How do we think this is going to work for Republicans? Um actually,
you guys don't understand that the economy's doing really well.
The economy's actually doing incredible right now. I fully support
all Republicans taking these talking points. Guys, the whole
affordability thing, that's a hoax, okay?
Every single person who's telling you that life's unlivable right
now, that's a hoax.
It also do really really well with the base that you relentlessly
and endlessly affirm every single ridiculous feeling they ever
have and coddle. Yeah, start telling that that cohort of people
that something that they're feeling is not >> Dude, uh
Ben Shapiro can engage in all of that and then go, "Oh my god,
why do you guys say that I supported like Trump or anti-Semitism
rising in my party?"
Cuz you did. Cuz that's what you built up. Exact thing straight
straight just said. Coddling every single feeling they have including
the conspiratorial ones until they're just un
I don't know, like undisciplined, uncontrollable toddlers having
a tantrum. Oh boy. Mother. Whether or not Also, somebody said,
"You better encourage us all to view the original Ben Shapiro
clip, else you might be stealing views." Yeah, true. Not your
apologiz- apologizing to your very employees that you are eliciting
known insincere apology. You're also irresponsibly platforming
Ben Shapiro or Hutch?
>> sincere person, would you make that if you were a principled
person? I would say, yeah. I don't want you to lie to your audience
about whether the apology is sincere based on your feeling that
you have to like protect someone who's being insincere.
Does that make sense? But but but if the Again, you're not indulging
my hypothetical. Like like would it be would it be wrong to lie
if you're as a creator
if your intention is to dissuade your audience from like
CaseyTrons streams and >> Hutch is a white supremacist?
No. I actually endorse Queenman's theory that he and like a lot
of other liberal Zionists are actually just like the true America
first.
But like if if you're basing that statement off of like a perceived
lack of empathy for like Israel-Palestine or something, which
I'm making the assumption that you are I I think it comes from
the fact that like they just don't really care about like they
just presuppose and assume that like every department that you
every every decision a democratic US State Department makes is
good.
And And so be it.
You guys are like actually losing your minds right now. Hutch
is voting for Vance in 2028. That's not happening. No, he's not.
>> say substance. Come on, man. level >> of danger
to CaseyTrons health and security, then yes, I think that it
would be okay to lie if like otherwise she would get or assaulted
or attacked or something like that. Or harassed. No, or harassed.
Not brigaded. No no not that. I do not think on at the scale
we're talking about here, which is public criticism, all right?
I I also love this kind of like deflation of the word harass.
This is Pisco's personal worldview, which actually although I
think this is a respectable worldview, I don't mind this worldview,
I do think that like Hutch's hypothetical here isn't crazy and
Pisco's saying, "No, I don't believe that." And Pisco is arguing
that the same way he argues most of his worldview, which is like
vociferously, like aggressively or vigorously. Like vigorously
defends his worldview. So it does seem here like I could see
how somebody if they're trying to paint Pisco as like a debate
bro who won't give I think he'll
I think he'll like uh oh man. I just don't think it's going to
go well. assumed that means anytime you get like a bunch of comments
negative comments and [__] and negative attention.
By that logic like I'm harassed constantly all the time by everybody.
But like I'm sure you are. >> Harassment like what I understand
harassment to be and it's it's not just like like it is a specific
wrongful act that puts you in like fear for your privacy or a
fear of like that you're about to be in physical harm or something
like that or someone's going to stalk you something like that.
Not mere criticism because you did a bad thing. Like it's not
harassment that we say Trump is a piece of [__] or
has to get to go to jail or we say that all of like I understand
these are public figures but same thing on Donald They're not
Yeah, not the same thing on Hasan [__] right? Like
when Hasan [__] is lying about Israel or Gaza or
whatever he's that you think he's lying about. You wouldn't be
like
okay, criticizing that is harassment, right? If he's doing misconduct,
if he's being insincere and you criticize it that's not harassment,
fair? Just criticism is not harassment but but if it's but if
it's organized brigading if it's or if it's organized brigading
>> do you mean what? Like that they're trying to
So you're arguing that Ethan was participating in organized brigading
against Casey Tron right now?
Cuz that's what he would have to be arguing and I don't think
he wants to argue that. But he is literally he is Guys, shouldn't
Ethan disavow organized
Wait, when he says stop harassing Casey Tron are you implying
that he was doing organized brigading?
I think that's what he's implying here and I don't know
why he would say that. I mean that that is like kind of the implicit
assumption by making that disclaimer, no?
That's exactly that is what he's saying, >> to do that
that he would be enabling that sort of harassment therefore he
has no choice but to tell the noble lie.
Yeah, that is literally what he is arguing right now, yes.
What they're talking about why Ethan has to lie and say don't
harass Casey Tron even though he doesn't feel that way, right?
Cuz he like basically Pisco said only he only has to do that
if the harassment is like significant he's worried about some
significant security threat to Casey Tron and Hutch goes well,
what if it's organized brigading? The implication being shouldn't
Ethan lie and say no, don't harass Casey Tron because of the
threat of organized brigading. Now I would wonder why Ethan's
community might be a threat for organized brigading against Casey
Tron.
Yeah, sorry did you have something you wanted to say?
the max
ultra cynical dark assessment of Ethan's behavior in light of
extracting apology like that from Casey Tron of like guys, don't
harass her. The ultra cynical take is that it's rich guy behavior
continued where it's like no, you don't get to harass her because
this is my
this is my monkey that I get to make dance.
Go get your own. I paid good money for this and you're not going
to coast off of it for free. So no the only one who's if anyone's
going to do harassment around here, it's going to be me cuz I
paid dearly for this. You did not. Go do it elsewhere or don't
do it at all. [__] you. Want your own lawsuit. You
mean what? Like that they're trying to >> you don't know
what the You know what brigading means, come on. Brigading means
like sending your people over to their servers or the different
things on purpose to >> doesn't even necessarily need to
be like orchestrated by the creator. It could be something as
simple as
>> Very cool. He recognizes what he just said. He's like
oh
Ah, got to sweep for myself here. Hold on. Yes, to answer your
question no, I don't think that if you're brigading are there
is there like organized brigading that happens that's not on
behalf of the creator that the creator can stop like
Like is Hutch I I still feel like Pisco already said only stuff
that he has a reason to suspect is happening. So does Ethan suspect
organized brigading is happening that he himself is not
is enough to justify lying to your audience about an about an
insincere apology. Because because But you're motivated by you're
motivated by you're motivated by a desire to like prevent harm
or limit harm. How could that be immoral? Because you're motivated
by a desire to like prevent Well, I personally I don't think
I don't I think that his motivation is to try to My god. Um claim
it's sincere for purposes of his further you know, to justify
his position lawsuit and to justify the negative statements made
about Hasan [__] So I don't even I don't >> and
crying is immoral? Are you seriously saying this? Obviously.
Well, there's obviously Dung Devil, you're just doing the same
thing. I don't even think I don't even know
if you're watching this conversation enough to actually jump
in here and comment the way you are. I Well, there's always the
blanket disavow of brigading, right? Not that the creator can
be held accountable in that way but do you understand why we're
talking about this right now?
Or did you just hop in to throw this in? I'm sorry, I I've started
to get really short with my
I love Dung Devil, okay? I called him an F slur in my Discord
earlier tonight but I just sometimes man, I'm I've started to
get like so
cuz it it feels like when I'm discussing stuff like this the
people who come in to argue like actually
do no work and it's like so frustrating sometimes. No, Dung Devil's
fun. Dung Devil's cool. I'm just curious if he
It's very frustrating though. It's like Yeah, I've started to
get like short with people.
Cuz to me Dung Devil's smart which is why I know that, right?
Like in this case we're talking about
when when Pisco says Ethan should only disavow something if he
has a good idea it's happening and Hutch goes but what if it's
organized brigading? So Hutch is proposing that Ethan knows about
organized brigading happening in his space in his community
and he needs to disavow it. I mean like there's another word
or term for that and it's called covering your ass. What if Ethan
is covering his ass? Oh, absolutely. I totally agree with that.
That to be in like to show this apology and also be in compliance
with YouTube terms of service he is saying do not do this. Cuz
if he doesn't he knows there's a high likelihood that he could
and he's going to get backlash.
Maybe. I also don't have any problem with him like I fully believe
and understand and get it that
right now he's saying that no, Ethan does want to gloat but he's
also going to say this yeah, to cover his ass or because he doesn't
want to harass either one and I personally don't care about which
one it is. It's like good that he said it. It's fine.
I I have no like criticism for that. I don't even know how they
got onto this. Oh, Pisco's saying that like oh, Hutch was doing
the performative like well, at that moment he was feeling magnanimous
in that moment he was feeling um
I think I think it's weird for Ethan to be serious in parts of
that and then like lying in parts of that. So if he says that
this is all her words but he knows it's like actually
like a agreed upon statement and he's not making that clear.
I do think that's weird to mix in with other things like don't
harass because then if you say and you're arguing he's sarcastic,
well guys like those are all her words beautifully said Casey
Tron. Also guys, don't go harass her. Come on, don't do that.
Like
the tone would be irresponsible, right? To mix the sarcasm in
the heavy sarcasm with the legitimate like I would say that's
I criticize that on its grounds not necessarily on motive not
necessarily on motive grounds. a good inference that he's really
motivated to you know, protect Casey Tron's well-being and part
of that is because the way he talks about Casey Tron's financial
situation which I find reprehensible but we can get into that
in a second. He can be he can be petty. I I just want to say
that if it were the case that Casey Tron is being He can be petty.
Then why is it like people's insincere.
He can be petty, guys. Okay, can you explain why in other cases
you're like literally attempting
to explain why he's not that bad a person for doing something?
I know that he can be petty. I know.
in her apology and Ethan Klein knows her to be insincere.
You would say that it's okay for Ethan to lie about that. I don't
think it's necessarily bad. But given the facts that we have
here if if under current understandings of the fact, right? His
own your own interpretation of the facts as you know it if you
found out and Ethan said to you, you know what Hutch, I was lying.
I don't think it's sincere. What would you say to that?
Don't care. You don't care about the lie. No. This is by the
fact So I'm not going to spend a lot of time I don't care. I
don't think it's necessarily bad. That's crazy. Like he looks
like bro, are you serious? Did you actually think I was going
to care that someone was
What? It's an altruistic lie, okay?
He's a
the white hat pathological liar, okay? White hat multiple time
defamer.
Hutch is like did I say something that gave you the impression
that I expect people to be you know, forthcoming and genuine
and and things that they say?
What gave you that impression, dude? Why do you care about moral
behavior on the internet? Why would you argue with somebody about
whether someone's actions are moral? Why would you do that? Oh
wait, that's like my entire job. That's like the entire career
path I've chosen.
Wow. You expected me to not like lying when like my entire profession
relies on people being honest in conversations.
Well, wow.
Yes. Yes.
Although in this one case I do believe if he is still referring
to like oh, it's a lie. I'm not totally sure on the context here
like exactly what he's referring to but if he's if in his head
he's thinking
I think it's okay to lie about like forgiving her or thinking
she's cool and not to harass her if you just want to like move
on and you don't want to her harass but you did still want to
gloat. Like it's fine to lie about that. I would be like okay,
that's fine to lie about. I do think if you're mixing that in
with the other sarcasm, that's probably bad.
Maybe on a different level. We'll see. I think Hutch has PTSD
from getting cooked by Pisco so many times he refuses to bite
any bullet because he thinks that everything is a trap. Yes,
this is this is what we said right at the beginning of the conversation.
Um right at the beginning of the conversation
I said that he seems to be significantly lacking in second order
thought as in when he says yes or no to something there's a condition
there and he can't see where the road goes from his answer. So
he's scared to give a solid answer because he doesn't understand
where the path goes. He can't see past that decision, right?
It's why he has a hard time engaging with hypotheticals.
It's why he yes, when he gets asked asked a yes or no question,
he really is hesitant to answer because he thinks that he's cooked.
I think that's a function not of like stupidity. I do I truly
think it's laziness because it's clear that I think Pisco is
ready to field whatever arguments Hutch is going to present or
any of these defenders are going to
And even if he hasn't encountered them, has reason through his
own position enough that he he knows he has a like a good understanding
of where he thinks the opposition is going to be coming from
and understands their argument but still disagrees with it. I
don't know that Hutch actually does the work to interrogate the
opposing opinion and see if it in any way should like make him
re-evaluate his. And so to have to be forced to do that live,
not forced. I mean, he volunteered to do this debate, right?
But to have to do it live is really really uncomfortable because
it involves a lot of like humility and having to, you know, backtrack
and and make concessions and admit you might be wrong or that
like, oh, I hadn't thought about that. I guess that does mean
that like my position is kind of untenable if that's the case.
Um
I think that could be true, too.
I'm How do I put it?
I really I haven't seen enough of his content. So if that's your
read, maybe I would go with yours.
But it's like I I legitimately think there's a
I think there's like a I >> content. It's like it's the
it's the community that I believe that he
Cuz it's not the type like See, I could come into your chat and
disagree and I don't think like, oh, I'm not going to be welcome
here if I disagree. I don't get that sense with Hutch's community.
Or like and like Pisco's community, I feel like I can go and
like disagree in chat and it's not going to I'm not going to
get banned, right? Or I'm not going to get it's really shut down
by like the rest of the chat. You try to say Destiny did nothing
wrong, you might find that chat really disagreeable super fast.
Just saying. I'm sorry, go ahead. I agree broadly that's mostly
the way it is. I would say there's probably an edge case. Go
ahead. Sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off. You're good. But
yeah, with Hutch's it's like it seems to me like no, this community
is is
like not really going to be tolerant of that. Like [laughter]
of disagreements that go you know, go outside of a very small
margin window.
Well, I think I saw Kilo. Kilo is aggressive when he's in here,
but I saw Kilo in Hutch's chat and somebody saying he got banned
recently. And he basically was like asking He was basically just
asking like gut check questions to
And they're like, hey, we're going to ban you if you keep asking
questions.
Yeah, that's what I mean. Like [laughter] that actually lines
up. I didn't even I didn't even know that, but that is the impression
that I got and it's only
>> I'm not surprised whatsoever.
And I think that's why he struggles in these conversations because
if you then you're really you've built an echo chamber for yourself
and it feels treacherous to navigate into disagreement even with
a friend. Pisco who says Hutch is my boy every 5 minutes. I think
it's really [__] up
Hutch did that to him after Pisco's constantly Hutch is my boy,
you're my boy, Hutch. Might be silly to suggest she die or something,
but Ethan is literally implicitly directing people to harass
her. How can you ignore that? Question mark. At KiloTanas, just
going to say you're on thin ice. Oh my god. >> [__]
up comment, Kilo. That's a really [__] up comment.
That's a totally [__] up comment, buddy. What are
you doing with your life? You're on thin ice, buddy. Just from
reading this from thin ice in this community, okay? You're on
thin ice,
I have like one mod on YouTube channel and it's like and cuz
I don't I don't want people like this as my mods. Yeah, I basically
just say if you're like slurring. Also, if you're like spamming
enough, like one took over earlier tonight when he was like getting
mad at you. I If you're spamming enough, you'll just get banned
no matter what. So beyond like racism, anti-semitism, like explicitly
for a prolonged period of time, like you can do a joke once in
a while, but if it's like extreme,
yeah, you basically don't get banned in my chat, so. I don't
know I don't know why like questioning the streamer and
>> It was Kilo's first message that he just sent in your
chat? Oh, that was literally my first message to be clear. They
might know you, Kilo. Also, that's maybe your first message in
YouTube chat. I'm almost positive unless I'm just totally conflating
you with
Have you not talked in his Twitch chat
Or is that literally your first chat anywhere? Would they recognize
you from the kick chat or the Twitch chat? Cuz I
I felt like it was but maybe I'm thinking of Teeny Tiny Tony
cuz that guy talks a lot in chats.
This shouldn't be a complicated conversation for anyone following
this drama. The thing is is that if you're following exclusively
one side of the drama, you're actually not following the drama
and you're actually going to be almost worse off because you're
only engaging with one side of the story. So you can actually
make yourself look far worse than somebody who's coming to the
conversation with nothing with no priors. Yeah. So that's why
he comes off the way that he does even though he ostensibly is
like familiar with this content because he's never been forced
to like really empathize with the other side that's like critical
of Ethan. I will I will say
yeah.
But do you you understand that that doesn't actually help, right?
So he may it it looks bad to us, but it doesn't look bad to most
people. I I can say this, okay, I saw this Oh, I have to pull
up this PF Young tweet cuz it actually fits here absolutely perfectly.
Um hold on.
I first time anybody's ever said that before. I realized that
I was like >> a brand new sentence you just made. I don't
know if you're aware of that.
>> Uh it actually fits here >> not something that
anyone has ever uttered before.
He said said this, welcome to the post I don't even know about
the tweet, but basically he's like, from here on out, political
power will reside with those who have the ability to navigate
within both of these worlds in order to synthesize an ideology
that is greater than the sum of its parts. Thus, the age of dark
centrism centrism has come. Now, me personally, I'm like, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Why would political power reside with
people reviled by the majority of every like I'm sorry cuz I
am the person who actually understands that empathize with both
of these sides and I can say very uniquely
that that doesn't help. That that actually [__] that
nobody likes you for being able to do that. Everybody hates you
everywhere, okay? The fact that you can like steel man somebody
else, they're immediately like, why why would you say that? I'm
just I'm just telling you guys, okay?
I've never once felt like my ability to go, but like I really
do think Ethan was correct here. I've never once felt like that
helped me in these communities at all. Just to be clear.
Yeah, just to be clear. I don't think anybody's ever gone, oh,
that's really awesome. I'm so glad we have like free thinkers
here. I just don't think that's ever happened.
To watch someone actually type that out and be serious about
the thin ice thing. It's like it's a meme between Liking and
I. I sent him an ice skating emoji cuz I did this really early
on talking to him. So he'd be like, what does that mean? So I
could say you're on thin ice, bud, but it was a joke. So when
I send him that, it's like not serious. So to watch somebody
actually say it, it's just it it's just weird >> and mean
it. Very odd.
You're on thin ice, buddy. Just going to say you're on thin ice.
I will say though somebody said he got banned. I did read that
chat message out. I do not believe Kilo was banned. Kilo, you
were not banned, right? He said the one message and then you
were on thin ice. >> Gervais, you're on thin ice.
Watch it. I'm about to get it. I'm about to get I'm about to
get minimized right now. This guy. No, he got banned after. Wait,
did you What did you get banned for, Kilo? The lawyer tactics.
I I actually want to know what he got banned
Did you ask Hutch to substantiate a claim per chance? I just
kept arguing for a few minutes. Autism.
They said you're on thin ice. You just kept going? Rude. He kept
skating.
You're on thin ice.
You've fallen through the ice. All right. Fair enough.
I I think he was Dude, I'm not going to I won't make you sit
around for this, but I'm going to go through this thread later.
I don't know if you I don't know how much you like engaging with
some of this stuff. I feel like not that much, but um big r/destiny
thread about how Pisco is in this debate with Hutch. I'm going
to go and enjoy that, okay? Whatever's going [laughter] on in
that
>> I do feel like that is going to be very funny, okay?
So we'll see how it goes. Even if even if I indulged your even
if I indulged your version of it. Let let's say he's just all
it is is just him doing a backhanded like victory lap. I don't
care. Okay, so that's why I can't deal with this stuff. If you
don't care about whether or not he lied about uh her sincerity
or insincerity on the apology, then I'm not going to spend a
bunch of time if even if I could establish that she lied, which
actually I will ask you about. Um that you would think If If
you're not going to condemn it, right? I'm not I'm not going
to spend a bunch of time wasting like, well, why you should,
right? Like you're saying basically it's okay for him to lie
about the sincerity of the apology even if it's not true. For
him to tell his audience that it is true. >> If you think
that I have some kind of moral obligation to condemn him for
lying in that spot in this hypothetical, you would have to convince
me that the consequences that CaseyTron experienced
were not commensurate with the way that she contributed to what
happened with Ethan and Ela and and all that. No, I'm I'm I'm
I'm examining
Oh, well, coincidence. That's literally why we're here, Hutch.
I don't know if you knew this, Hutch, but that's actually what
we're doing here today. That's the entire exercise. You guys
heard that correct, right? You'd have to convince me that CaseyTron's
punishment, which she received from this lawsuit, is not commensurate
with how she contributed to the environment of Ethan harassment.
I don't even know how you argue that. I don't know how you argue
that it is commensurate.
It's shocking to me that people say this. You would have to say
Because because earlier in the conversation you did you said
that you didn't think it was necessarily immoral to bring litigation
against someone but be motivated by some other kind of grievance.
You said that that wasn't necessarily immoral, right? Yeah, so
so I think that there could be motivations that aren't necessarily
that it doesn't necessarily make it immoral. That's correct.
I was giving some solid examples
but we'll we'll get into the facts about the about the lawsuit
but I just want to resolve this issue of lying. No, but then
but then this conversation needs to be about like do you think
that Ethan bringing litigation was
um was was too far of a response?
Like what? This
is like
it's like elementary morality.
Like so okay, just just so I can understand you Pisco. Is your
argument that people should use laws for the reasons that they
were intended to be used and in good faith? Is that your argument
to be clear?
I would say that for Pisco, what is I don't know what the point
Hutch is making here. I don't know what the point is that he's
making because I do think there he could say something like you
disagree you felt like you couldn't say it's always bad to do
this because there are some edge cases and that's what I'm saying
is I can't say it's always bad to do this because there are some
edge cases. If he's making that argument, I would be okay with
that. But it depends on where he's going. If he's just trying
to point out that like
even you said it would be okay and so he's just trying to make
a point about that then I don't know what you're doing here.
If he's just trying to make a stand alone point out of it it
is stupid, yes.
Cuz I think the impression I got from Pisco was no, that's bad.
Maybe not illegal but it's bad except outside of a few like a
handful of cases. >> And he's not even arguing that it
should be illegal. That's why it has to be socially discouraged
because if you made this illegal then literally nobody would
ever be able to enforce copyright because everybody could always
say well they're just doing it cuz they hate me. Yeah, yeah,
exactly. Yep. >> So like you can only this is like the
most reasonable thing. Again, use the courts for their and laws
for their intended purposes and not for nefarious ends or other
motivations
just for their purposes only. It also we we set a social standard
in absent a legal
Which by the way, I actually have no problem with I don't even
have a problem and I know this is like way outside of what most
people think. I have no problem with Ethan Klein saying I'm going
to sue you and I'm going to argue that you have to pay my litigation
costs but sue for actual damages. It's the statutory damages
with the insane penalties to me that are like oh and like it's
not meant to be used in this person to person settling a personal
score way. It's meant to be used in like this totally dispassionate
way to discourage a certain kind of behavior, a copyright violative
kind of behavior. But Ethan has explicitly said he doesn't want
to chill copyright violations, right? He doesn't want to chill
something he could sue someone for. He wants to chill the people
who are mean to him.
And so it's like it's literally being used for like a separate
purpose in my opinion entirely. And it's like willing
this idea that like
cuz I'm sure Ethan has a good lawyer that he's retained that
is not
the fact that he's willing to pay what do you think he paid?
Like conservative estimate like $60,000
for that apology from Casey Tron? Was that really worth it? Who
knows.
I mean to him >> we're we're in like we're talking about
California like good lawyer that he can afford and he said at
the beginning of the video I like burning money.
>> to get a video of Denim saying that he is a big okay,
I fully believe that 100%.
What he do with Casey Tron? Well, I mean he just did. But I do
I do think it's like that essentially.
It's just that, right? I see >> Like he would never disclose
the amount of money that he spent because he knows it's embarrassing.
If he actually had to say out loud how much money he put in to
extracting that apology from that person.
Yeah, but if you I also believe fully if you if you asked him
would you pay that just straight up to get that humil he would
just say yes, absolutely. If you could have just paid that directly,
he would have paid that directly to like maybe not directly to
Casey Tron but he would have paid that directly to uh like like
the UN Human Rights Council, okay? For purposes of being sent
to Gaza. He would have paid that directly to whatever whatever
charity goes directly to Hamas, he would have absolutely paid
it. Jeez, it's like Oh my god, like if Lycan told me like if
we ever like hit the lottery or something and that's how he wanted
to spend the money, I would just leave him. I mean I just think
it's like immoral
it feels to me in totality that it's like fairly immoral so it's
bad on those grounds, not really based on the amount of money
it costs. I think like money becomes relative once you have enough
money so when like I you might not be there right now. I don't
think you can inhabit the same
like brain space that he does having as much money as he does
for as long as he has where it's like that is something he can
do but like realistically
he feels like he's getting retribution for tons of hours of his
like mental well being. I do think it's probably trade most people
with that much money who are that like at mad at pain about like
Casey Tron. I do think that's like a trade they make. I don't
really doubt that to be honest. My personal opinion is that it's
really frustrating. It's literally like it's I it's like you
know how people can adapt to any circumstance. You don't also
adapt to like any wallet and just have money become like totally
meaningless. Which is I'm sure my plushy wall doesn't suggest
that but I am actually incredibly frugal and very attached to
money. It's literally like it's I it's like you know how people
can adapt to any circumstance. You don't also adapt to like any
wallet and just have money become like totally meaningless. It's
just also like it's literally like it's I it's like you know
how people can adapt to any circumstance. You don't also adapt
to like any wallet and just have money become like totally meaningless.
No, I know what you're talking about. It's called like lifestyle
inflation or whatever. It's like very well sir. I just you know
I'm just built different, okay? Can you just accept that I'm
accept premise one I'm built different and I would be I would
not fall into that cognitive pitfall like everybody else, okay?
I'm built different for one and for two like what it would
what it would mean is that like we come into all this money and
like those are the priorities
of somebody that like I'm with that's insane to think about.
It's like you have all the money in the world and that's what's
on your mind. These like people now. Why are you fixating on
them? It just it just like signals like deep insecurity and like
so I'm like oh you'll oh so you'll never be happy like ever.
Um
yeah, no I think I mean if Ethan Klein has shown anything on
the internet over all of his years, it is that he will never
be happy ever. I think his career is like a testament to this.
Your money is particularly annoying to deal with.
Yeah, I think his his career is like totally a testament to just
he's always upset about everything all of the time. Yeah, yeah.
So unlucky unlucky for him. >> Bot Rick's thing is very
formal and does not match the vibe of this. Follow me on Twitter
for additional content updates on stream times. Yeah, I'm sure
that's why people hit follow on the J Talk Twitter. I don't even
know why people I literally my Twitter is like schizophrenic.
My Twitter my Twitter is being built by people who are like schizophrenic.
It's literally like it's I it's like you know how people can
adapt to any circumstance. You don't also adapt to like any wallet
and just have money become like totally meaningless. No, I know
what you're talking about. It's called like lifestyle inflation
or whatever. It's like very well sir. I just you know I don't
even know why people I literally my Twitter is like schizophrenic.
My Twitter my Twitter is being built by people who are like schizophrenic.
It's literally like it's I it's like you know how people can
adapt to any circumstance. You don't also adapt to like any wallet
Dude, did you see this? Do you know who Nikantros is? Like vaguely
aware of Nikantros? I have read Blood Meridian.
Oh, I mean the guy the influencer
Had a whole pop off today. It was really cool because he's like
a creator we all know. He's like a commentary creator who's made
a couple really big videos. His channel's like super popping
off. He made the Mutahar engineer video. Wait, he made the Mutahar
did he not make the engineer video? But he definitely made he
made what was the other one he made? Oh my god, I saw that profile
picture and I was like He doesn't like Muslims. He's kind of
conservative so some of the lefties don't like him, okay? This
one. Yeah, Mutahar is yeah, 715,000 views. He's been popping
off but he had a big pop off on Twitter because he started doing
like goofy ass Asmongold
You get what you deserve. You get what you And then Asmongold
responded it was like this is awesome. You want a job?
>> Oh my god.
That is the best racist thumbnail I've ever seen. Do you want
a job? You want a job, bro?
absolutely crazy.
What a crazy world we live in. Queen and clip where he mentions
your tweet about Hutch being performative.
Let's see here. You I I truly I'm getting a bad sense, man. I've
just sent a J Talk tweet about the debate.
How do you I truly don't understand how [laughter] you stay friends
with someone like this? Already I would be literally I would
be slinging slurs. If I was Pisco right now.
This is not true. You heard him. He came in this server. He didn't
sling any slurs at all. That's not true.
Speaking of performativity,
okay? Speaking of performativity.
>> I would be going crazy at this guy right now. The faces
he's pulling,
the faces he's pulling alone make me want to just throw something,
dude.
>> it's he's such a performative [__]
bro. He's a totally performative [__]
It is odd. He's literally hitting his own hand. Oh no. It's crazy,
How how do you Oh boy.
I mean we saw that play out in real time so he wasn't kidding.
Uh he had a little of he had a little frustrated, yeah?
Sorry, I was looking at something else. Damn. All right, back
to this. Frogan and Denims and that whole community contributed
to
the CPS call and the harassment that Ethan and Hila got. Right,
so I mean the case you're basically asking me do you think the
lawsuits are justified? That's what you're asking me, right?
Yeah. Yeah, okay. I do want to get into that but I I just want
to deal with lying. Is that
By by by could you mean could I see some possible world that
doesn't entail a contradiction in which it could be justified
the answer is yes but again that's what Do you think that that's
no Like once you have >> Hutch does not get to be frustrated
about that you didn't ask that.
This is but this is what happened. >> it's like you asked
could it be
I feel like this is this is how it works when you're debating
from like outside of an orthodoxy of sorts that like there's
a lot of people who believe a certain thing and then you're trying
to propose something that is fairly outside their way of thinking
and they're so resistant to what you're saying that that's the
bar for them to disprove what you're saying. Is it possible that
you're wrong? Is there some universe where you could possibly
be wrong?
Um like maybe.
But but like that is the frame of reference they're coming from
and it's started to get so frustrating to deal with and Pisco's
experiencing it now he's handling it his own way right?
I just don't know why you think that's where you should start
bargaining.
That's not the entry point for beginning a bargain.
Is like is like getting yeah like extracting the concession of
is there a non-zero chance of something happening just get to
it already it's crazy.
Well it's like I have a position you should have a position and
then we're basically going to argue who has more evidence for
their position.
But what happens is it's like well you're arguing that something
is plausible that plausibly like defeats my position just poking
holes and then you're saying I believe like this happened and
then it's like well here's like some basic questions that I think
kind of poke holes in that that kind of kind of like based on
some facts here right? I'm going to say so you say I think he
has multiple motives and they're about equal. And I say okay
well why did he register this beforehand if he wanted to wait
for somebody stating a malicious intent right? And I'll I'll
say facts of reality and then you'll go I'll say okay I believe
this is mostly based on his anger at other people's you
rhetoric online and you'll say but isn't it possible that something
happened?
It's like okay I said a fact I said I believe based on this fact
that this happened and you go isn't it possible that X?
And I go
I'm going to shoot myself in the head if you ask if you say something
again that means nothing I'm going to end it live on stream.
I'm going to cam up for the first time just so I can blow my
brains out live on stream and have you immortalized as the guy
in the clip
If you do this again.
I think that's that's where we should go with that okay? It's
that's that's where I'm at with people doing this like nonsense
speaking.
I haven't looked into this at all oh god I had this happen with
Android last night you don't know who that is somebody in the
VC where she like didn't she like didn't know what she's talking
about and I like what are we doing? I man I'm an [__]
to everybody now sorry it's all coming apart. She said something
and I was just like I literally I literally just like so you
just said nothing then cool thanks keep it to yourself next time
and then I just like kept talking to the person I was talking
to it was very rude.
I need to I need to be better okay? Trying to trying to be better
I should be better. Oh no no but do you think that >> it's
I think under the circumstances given the nature of the lies
and what's actually motivating it I do not think that I'll tell
you I don't >> how do you feel about like just like do
you give do you how do you feel about the collective communities
that they had piling on about the CPS stuff? Like how do you
feel about that and then the lack of moderation? How do you feel
about that? >> like I I don't
depending on the conduct I of course condemn it. If what they're
doing is advocating for or celebrating for example calling CPS
on Perry's in waiting VC.
I want to Perry for a little bit give me a second. I what's Perry
doing?
What's up Perry? Are you live right now?
Okay what's up how's it going? >> I just man yesterday
you really threw me a
You are the only person who doesn't hop in VC and say they're
live so I have a habit of asking you cuz you'll be live >> even
What do you mean I hopped in VC? I I literally I did I was in
waiting room. What do you mean? >> I know I'm saying in
general when you hop in VC you won't say if you're live so I
have a habit of asking you if you're live. Okay. All right. I
was in waiting room.
Doesn't even count as a habit if I'm like commonly or whatever.
It's can you have a one person habit whatever. All right so before
I start this I have a personal question can I ask you like a
personal question and I had a question about like the Hutch Pisco
thing. I don't want to do personal questions do the Hutch Pisco
one.
Oh it's it's like a question about my chair it's not like a question
about your personal life.
Oh it's not a personal question. It's a this is a personal question
it's a question about your person like you was a person well
you have a bounty but why am I asking you? I have one of these
chairs I'll ask you this question I have one of these chairs
I was like the do you know the armrests where like they move
you know what I mean?
Up and down? >> hear this?
No I'm just like like left like forward and back as well. Oh
like shaky like they're not they're not equipped well or they're
not attached well sure. What happened? No it's like it's like
a oh they're like I dynamic armrests where you can just move
them forward and back and they just make this noise >> No.
like like you're I don't know it's just why why would why do
those exist man I don't get it. I don't know. Next bit. Pisco
Pisco Hutch no. God you're such a man anyway it's just True.
Did you make fun of Hutch's body language yet? Did you do that?
Yeah the body language
>> All right do you think you can do it again? Can you
do it again? I feel like you didn't do it well. >> a lot
of slowing it down zooming in on Hutch's face as Pisco says something
and he like pops his eyes out and darts his eyes back and forth
and Yep. Did you call him a basically the whole time.
Did you call him a drug addict?
I did not. Like that's over the line. >> make fun of how
his sister died of No stop dude why do you always take it so
far? You always take it so
Or I didn't even make fun of it. Oh shut up straight rage you
dumb
Oh you can't make fun of his dumb cancer
sister but only his dumb cancer ridden like why why? >> and
then you're like why am I why aren't I allowed anywhere? Why
won't nobody talk to me?
>> point he's okay he's okay with people's lives being
Why why why won't anyone pull me on? Why won't anyone pull me
>> I'm not saying that's how my I am simply asking why
it's okay for Hutch to joke around >> Any other points?
Any other points you got? >> know it's engaging you know
it's engaging you know why engaging you just really want to hold
the bridge with Hutch cuz you want to go back Lovely exchange.
He's he just be like that sometimes okay? I will say though the
stream where he talked about Connor
controlling his wife's finances and that being the obvious sign
of abuse I did enjoy that stream tremendously okay? Wait what?
>> So You have to send me the link to that one. Didn't
go didn't go a lot further he said far worse than that said far
worse than that about Connor. But that's just the teaser.
That was honestly about as nice as it got so anyway let's continue.
>> facts I condemn that. If they're for example if it let's
say something weird
refusing to condemn the death of a political you know the assassination
or something I would condemn that you know not moderating >> talk
about let's just talk about what
you know? Like they made a mockery of it I'm saying I can think
of I can think of a definite a bunch of guys Is he While I agree
with you unfortunately him going through Aiden's laptop and leaking
DMs with Diorio is like the funniest thing I've ever seen happen
on a stream
So as much as that is psychopathic and I said it at the time
and and Aiden is the pure victim there and I feel bad for him
it was also the funniest thing I've ever seen in my entire life.
So I that is probably one thing I can't really criticize him
for. I'm lucky. Situations where failure to moderate is something
that I would condemn on the >> saying this specific thing
I just want you to I just want your thoughts on this specific
thing like do you not think that do you not do you not think
that that action that they did that the way that they participated
in the whole CPS
>> They I already laid it out for you. We talked about
that before. So it's your view There was there was So so you
agree They they Have you ever heard the three letter words CPS?
Oh straight rage I don't know you might have to do you want to
switch like names
or avatar or something cuz I think we're about to engage in some
skull of cost denial and I believe that gets you banned from
certain
Are you Oh shoot. You okay? Are you are you okay with engaging
in some skull of cost denial? I'll allow it yeah.
>> They it they enabled it. They were wildly irresponsible
at at best and they were they were maliciously egging it on at
worst and in the case of Daniel I think that they're culpable.
You think that they're culpable? Okay skull of cost revisionism
really at best okay? I don't I don't think he made up the thing.
I don't think These things don't People don't really deny the
skull of cost what what they do it's quibbling over you know.
>> bad but we have to tear down the mythology around the
skull of cost because technically like the skull of cost is used
as a method a tool to continue the oppression that we live under
currently okay? So realistically there's like a whole skull of
cost industry I think Norm Finkelstein's writing a book about
it we're going to deconstruct the mythology okay?
Just ask questions.
Pobble. Or what happened? I think they're all like jointly culpable.
Yeah they all have a part to play in that yeah. When you don't
do when you don't take any meaningful
to moderate your community when you can when you can see plain
as day what's going on in your chat and we're making jokes about
it after the fact like why are you joking about it after the
fact? Well presumably if you're joking about it presumably if
you're joking about it after the fact and only after the fact
how do we know there's a causal connection at all between what
occurred and the community? I can I can imagine a bunch of people
laughing at that that they had no So for I'll give you an example,
right? There are some Democrats who celebrated the death Hey
Denims, I know this guy like defamed you, said you committed
a crime, and then had to apologize to you, and then refused to
have you on stream after inviting you on stream. Okay, I know,
but have you thought about how [__] up it is for
you to laugh at his pain? Have you thought about how [__]
up that is? That's so [__] up. Uh but Casey Tron,
that stupid rancid [__] Yeah, it's awesome that she
had to do that apology. Oh my god, it's so funny that she had
to do that apology, that stupid rancid [__] But have
you thought about how it was really [__] up to laugh
at Ethan's
It's like really [__] up to laugh at Ethan's pain
actually. I hope you think about that. What a world we live in,
where people say these things and they just don't think about
them. They just say them, they're out in the open, and then can't
take them back. Can't ever get them
You're just [__] up forever.
You considered the Loner chemical weapons argument.
Dude, I I I did I almost want to ask Loner Box if he wants to
argue about it cuz I Dude, the chemical weapons thing was not
good. It was not great, okay? We did the chemical We watched
that video and then Spider came on, Loner Box's editor, and it
was just like painful. Dude, I >> a kid, cut him some slack.
The Spider. I [laughter] talked to that guy. He's When I say
guy, I really mean kid cuz he's like a little kid. Yeah, I should
be I don't hate Spider. I I went on Spider's stream just cuz
I don't know, everybody's around.
He's like not a >> me a happy Thanksgiving. I've talked
to him like twice.
The [__] Wow. Okay, now I feel less special. Okay,
whatever. [__] you. Wait, less special? I said he
didn't wish me Thanksgiving. Oh, I thought you said he did. Okay.
No, he didn't. He did not. >> What have you done to Wait,
no, you're in Canada. You don't have that there on that day.
>> Does he know that?
I'm sure he does. He knows I'm Canadian, but does he know when
Canadian Thanksgiving is? I'll just say he does.
Death to Charlie Kirk, agreed? Yes or no? Yes. Hold on. We got
a yes or no? >> community. I can I can imagine a bunch
of people laughing at [__] that they had no So for
I'll give you an example, right? There are some Democrats who
celebrated the death of Charlie Kirk, agreed? Yes or no? Yes.
You think that Rando is on Twitter? Sure, yeah. >> Yes.
Are those people culpable for Charlie Kirk's death?
No, but that's not that's not the same thing. Wait, is the same
thing as going to go on to explain how they're disanalogous?
What do we Can I take it back? He has to. But it just to be clear
for what Hutch just said, he was just complaining about them
celebrating, and so Pisco said, "Do you think people celebrating
after the fact are culpable?" And he gave him an
Dude, am I joking about it after
Am we making jokes about it after the fact? Like why are you
joking about it after the fact?
Cuz you can't joke about something that hasn't happened yet.
So when So just to be clear, he's seething about the joking about
it after the fact. And when Pisco explains why that's bad, he
goes, "But it's not the same."
Hopefully if you're joking about it Well, technically, a second
CPS call could happen. A second bullet through Charlie's clavicle,
less likely, all right? Don't make me joking about it after the
fact. And Hutch undefeated as always, all right? You can't double
Charlie Kirk, okay? Ain't no double tapping that guy cuz Erica
Kirk got that body hidden, and ain't nobody seen that body but
her kids, all right?
You hear about that conspiracy?
You covered that stuff the other day, >> Milo has been
saying uh That like the body's hidden? Did you hear on Glenn
Beck saying that she had no choice but to film herself like touching
and crying over his corpse because otherwise people would ask
>> Glenn Beck thing. I didn't watch the whole Glenn Beck
thing. >> out. But I do think that was gross, mostly cuz
his hands were really gross, but I independently arrived at the
exact same point Candace Owens would go on to make, which is
that I already find it to be odd behavior to have like to film
it, but then to like post it is truly what's weird. Like why
are you thinking about Instagram stories right after that?
Why is it on your Wikipedia page that you you said he had a Mona
Lisa-like half smile on his face because you begged the cops
to see his corpse even though they said, "No, you probably shouldn't
look." Yeah, that's that's
This is Have you ever watched Attack on Titan? You know what
I'm talking about?
Oh, never mind. Well, >> Well, I know of it, so I might
be missing out. >> so that's what they're keeping the body
hidden for. It really doesn't hit that well if you've never watched
the anime,
It's an anime >> getting not watching an anime so I could
understand this Erica Kirk meme. It's
It's fine.
The Kirk marriage is a sham is a sham. He's a closeted gay man.
He told me in a dream. Well, I find no fault with that
Yeah, someone literally said that. >> Uh well, hold on.
She said that >> certain things coming to fruition. Yeah,
She was like, "I've been dreaming about beekeepers for weeks,
and Charlie came to me in a dream and said he Do you know she
didn't say the dream part like immediately or she leaves it out
sometimes, right? She's like, "Charlie Kirk told me he was going
to be betrayed." And then >> like later on after saying
it once, she'd go like, "Yeah, and don't forget that Charlie
Kirk told me he's going to be betrayed. He came to me in a dream
and said it." It's like, "Wait, you said that before without
the second part. It feels really irresponsible to say it without
that part in there where he said it in a dream, Candace." I'm
sending you I'm shamelessly plugging my own tweet, but whatever
about my quote tweet, go look at what I'm quote tweeting. This
is not satirical. It's completely serious.
Is this going to be the funniest bit about it? And it's not.
No. All right, hold on. Okay, hold on. Christian men, if your
wife is listening, Candace Owens, you have an important difficult
task ahead of you as a spiritual head of the home. The scriptures
tell husbands to love their wives as Christ loved the church
and gave himself for her, washing her with water of the word
that he may present her holy and blameless. Your wife's spiritual
health is your responsibility, and it's your job to protect her
from influence that will rot her soul from the inside out. Find
what scripture says about slander, false witness, gossip, and
backbiting. Find verses about importance and fulfill and filling
your mind and heart uh sorry, filling your mind and heart and
mind with truth, goodness, purity, and God's word. Talk to her
about why she shouldn't be spending time listening to Candace
Owens even as mindless entertainment. Same goes for smut novels,
soap operas, TikTok, and the like. How about she just keep the
Candace off the bat? Can we get rid of Candace first, and then
you can work on the smut? All right? Smut might help the marriage
stay fresh, all right? Just get Candace out of their brains first.
Do this gently and lovingly, never be harsh. Point her to some
alternate >> Yeah, lovingly control your wife's media diet
and assert total, you know, parental control over all of her
devices.
Do this lovingly. Wait, did it say Hold on, did it say that?
Yeah, you're saying same goes for smut novels, soap operas, TikTok,
and the like. That and the like I take to mean pretty much every
social media platform you should You just injected some stuff
that wasn't there at all. Talk to her about why she shouldn't
be spending time listening to these things even as mindless entertainment.
It just talked about why she shouldn't.
I don't see the part where it says, "Actually, if she doesn't
listen, slap that [__] upside the head cuz she cuz
you're the authority." I never said that. It says have an honest
conversation. Didn't say you control her
It says it Yeah, it says doesn't say you control her devices.
Says listen, explain to her why it's >> I said media diet.
Media diet. You said control devices. Don't make me go to the
Don't make me >> Do it. It's It's 4:00 in the morning.
I probably did. I'll just concede it. But I'm not going to Yeah,
I'm not going to go to the record. I'm just I That was a totally
empty threat. I'm not doing that. It's too late. Point her to
alternate resources that will play the
Yeah, I'm guessing this is Wait, are you on Candace's side? Candace
is like totally insane, right? Below are updates and instructions
>> ridiculous. It might be absurd. Although, I do think
like I If If it wasn't this, like he just said it wrong. It's
like, "Dude, if you got somebody in your life who's consuming
a lot of Candace Owens content, sincerely,
even as mindless entertainment, what would you say is the >> Owens
is irrational, it's because she's like not towing the MAGA line.
That's
Mhm. I mean, I do think that some of are satirizing, but >> No.
They're total These are people that are completely fine with
QAnon. These are people that are completely fine with deluding
themselves into the thinking that Trump actually won in 2020,
that vaccines don't actually work. There is like no conspiracy
that you know, climate change is a Chinese hoax. Like there's
no no conspiracy that these people don't believe in. They're
just not cool with this one because it's not favorable to Trump.
>> I mean, also, dude, I That's not the You You watch the
Fuentes content on this,
Anti-Semitism used to be intelligent. That's That's his point.
And I By the way, the best part is I was watching it, and I called
it. I'm like, "He's just mad cuz he had to work so hard to not
get like totally in debates when he was like trying to do his
conspiracy theories." And then Candace came along, and her conspiracy
theory is Charlie came to me in a dream and told me he was betrayed.
And she gets a hundred views on that. >> annoyed clearly
because
He said from the very start he didn't think Israel was involved
in this, and that was supposed to like set the tone of like,
"Guys, don't do that. That's stupid. Don't go there." And she
couldn't help it. >> She couldn't help it. Yeah. No, it's
it's the Okay, the and the French. She She just said all of America's
sworn
And she's like the >> Literally every every single episode
a new country that is implicated is revealed. It's like the Texas
government, Tucson, Arizona,
Yeah, Arizona. Yeah. Is greatest country. Egypt is involved.
Fran- Yeah, Delaware, France. DuPont
Billion-dollar national corporation. DuPont. DuPont? That's how
you say it, isn't it?
Wouldn't that be how you say it? Yeah, and then there's the croissant.
It's the NT ending in French. But I'm I'm speaking it in I'm
saying it in
And in American you say it Dupont. Okay, say Wait, say say croissant
but say what it actually is. What do you say? Do you say croissiant?
I say croissant. Okay, so you just don't pronounce some of the
How do you say Dupont? Wait, wait. I'm I think I'm pronouncing
too many letters for you for your tastes.
Maybe. I just say I say it the French way cuz it's that's how
it is, okay? Well, that makes sense for you but like to do that
here is like it feels like the equivalent of saying like Target.
You know what I mean? People that think stuff like that's
White women in this country. Okay. Okay, but but let's be real.
Jalapeno is funny, okay? Saying
That's like my favorite aunt joke, okay? Saying jalapenos. How
do we know that there's a causal connection with what >> I would
love to hear you try to speak Spanish. That would be funny. It
could happen. heard and the community. I can I can imagine a
bunch of people laughing at that they had no So for I'll give
you an example, right? There are some Democrats who celebrated
the death of Charlie Kirk. Agreed? Yes or no? Yes. Do you think
that Bad Empanada is on Twitter, sure, yeah. Yes. Are those people
culpable for Charlie So that's his first counter argument. Bad
Empanada is on Twitter, it doesn't even matter. And Pisco keeps
pressing and so he comes up with a new argument which is
No, but that's not that's not the same thing at all. Wait, hang
on a second. It's just Guys, it's not the same thing. It's not
analogous. comparison.
It's an analogy.
No, but this would only be analogous if they were all in message
boards where they were talking about potentially unaliving Charlie
Kirk. That would be analogous. So what you need to show, don't
you? Wait, but but you're Yeah, you need to show that they premeditatedly
wanted CPS called on this guy.
And I I think even with that which is the only one you guys really
have evidence for, I think unless Again, I don't know anything
about
Talking to me. Nobody gives a Is Tekton not on this? Or even
like >> Who's on this? The funny thing is that like the
way that this conversation needs to be structured from what I
based on how infuriating it was is that you actually need to
start with asking them to provide the evidence that they have
for all of like Denims's alleged wrongdoings, Casey Tranz's alleged
wrongdoings, same with Frogan, and then proceed with the conversation.
Otherwise, you will always get trapped in these cul-de-sacs
of realizing so many of their assumptions rest on the idea that
those people did something egregious. As a viewer, it's very
fun to watch them like be pressed for it on the spot and not
have like ball
and just be like it exists out there
We've seen it. You know what I'm talking about, bro. Come on.
I Even though no nobody knows.
and the thing is it's like for me, what I like to do is say,
"Okay, I don't need you to have a source for me, okay? I don't
need that. What I need you to do is tell me what you think
because then we want to track that against what really happened.
I want to see how far what you think Like tell me what you think
happened. Don't just say, "Well, I don't really know at all."
Just Listen, it doesn't have to be correct. I just want to see
the disconnect. Well, I want to see that like are you getting
you know, 80% right or 50% right or 2% right or nothing? Like
that's cuz it's a huge difference to me. It's like if you're
if you it up a little bit cuz you didn't have the clip, I'm cool
with that. But like I want proof that you had a point, that you
had anything, that you remember anything at all.
And how bad was the game of telephone that you were privy to?
Or even even just tune your response to like how much information
you have, right? If you really don't know, just be like, "Well,
I thought it was like this and you know, now that I think about
it, I don't really know." Don't be like, "Bro, are you kidding
me? Do you know how badly they harassed Ethan?" And then you
like don't know what was said at all. Like I think that Cuz it's
actually rational like if you took Ethan at his word that these
people did what he's accusing them of doing, that you'd feel
this way a little bit or like it would be more understandable.
I shouldn't say rational, I just say more
But like No, like
Even that's putting aside the fact that why are you taking Ethan
Klein or really any influencer at their word?
But like that would make some sense, right? But then when they
refuse to concede once you show
that oh yeah, that's a complete distortion if not outright lie,
the immediate pivot to something else is like, "Oh, so that's
what I'm dealing with." So it's not actually like it's just you
feel like scapegoating these people. Oh, I wish
I wish it didn't work this well but it do be working this well,
you know?
There's just so much money in it. Guys, there's so much money
in just like constantly
ball washing this guy and protecting his reputation.
It really shouldn't be like that. It really shouldn't be
People shouldn't be able to build up like a cult around
not wanting Ethan analyzed at all. It just feels like baffling
to me. God, I can explain. >> relationship
between their conduct pre uh you know, in in crimina in crimina
You actually just put me off when you're like, "Yeah, it's just
It makes perfect sense that they just take Ethan's word as like
fact." And then I minatory act and the act itself, don't you?
The CPS call happened shortly after Denims did her stream where
she platformed a Bad Empanada video where he was the making the
he was making the case that CPS should be called and she made
no meaningful she she like maybe she made some but like she did
not go nearly far enough in terms of moderating her If I was
her First of all, why she
Did she react too hard?
It's just weird like it then it it just leads to like, "Okay,
again, why are we holding Denims more responsible than Bad Empanada?
Like
that that doesn't make any sense. And then what are they both
laughing at? Oh, the clip where Ethan says his kids are walking
are like eating [__] and contracting giardia based
on that because he overshared. Got it. That's Denims's fault.
It's It's like yeah, I think they actually go through this here
where But this is unfortunate. Is Pisco lets himself get taken
off track. I do think arguing that is kind of It's like it's
probably morally good to do but getting caught down that rabbit
hole is not great where you're like, "Well, actually did Bad
Empanada really like lie or did he play a clip and then sort
of extrapolate and say some like crazy shit?" Cuz like the crazy
[__] he said was obviously a joke. I thought he's
like, "Ethan Klein's kids are collecting parasites never before
seen by science" or something. It's like, is that a lie or is
that a joke? It's like I don't I'm not even going to say Bad
Empanada doesn't lie. I'm not trying to defend the guy. I'm just
saying in that one case, is that a lie or is that a joke? I Like
he plays a clip and the clip kind of speaks for itself in that
one case, okay? Not He's not a good person, by the way. Not arguing
that. >> to the to the
the harassment of the Kleins or whatever. That's not why you
shouldn't watch Bad Empanada. You shouldn't watch Bad Empanada
because he's not he's he he's like doxxed people. Like there's
other other reasons why it's like not a good idea to watch his
videos in my opinion. And that like he doesn't always reliably
source the videos. So unless you're watching it to like criticize
it, there's no reason to watch it usually to like agree or you
should do that on your own time. But that's not what he's saying.
He's saying, "No, they've been too mean to the Kleins. It's not
fair.
They've been too mean to this to this person. It's beyond the
pale that you would even like think to laugh at that."
Even though it's like what is Ethan Klein's
entire internet history if not milking low cows? And lying and
getting sued for defamation and then having to publish apologies
for lying on the internet about people maliciously.
Like the only like >> trust him for sure. Like Ethan's
quote-unquote plight and suffering, it's like yeah, I I don't
even doubt I I wouldn't like would anyone really be surprised
if one of the subjects of his like videos basically it felt like
they were going through the same [__] or like were
swatted or were harassed
after his video was released. But like you never hear from any
of those people because they just But the only difference being
not their not that their suffering was different but because
they just didn't have a big enough platform that anybody even
noticed or cared. Yeah, and they also might just have a different
strategy for dealing with it, too.
Right? Not Most people who get harassed don't go, "This is exactly
how I was harassed and it really [__] me up."
Not usually a good strategy. >> But even if they wanted
to, they don't have the platform to and no one's going to listen
cuz they're a [__] low cow and that would actually
lead to more harassment usually. But Ethan for some reason is
getting hug boxed for a thing that should be that would get anybody
else laughed out of a room. Yep.
Uh hopefully you know, I keep think crossing my fingers that
things are going to change. Maybe Kilo, maybe some of these other
people will get off their
and do their goddamn jobs. Just I know that's not actually a
job, Kilo. I know you do it part-time but Hope it any day now,
I'll get like something popping up in my feed.
Any day now, the tides Any day now, things will go great. Any
day now, the content will flow. Any day now, one of these people
will do something. Thank goddamn it. All right, I'm I'm joking
about video like a video that should be coming out. That's all.
I think I think that's pretty well known. Okay? It's coming.
It's coming. It'll be here very soon. She platformed Bad Empanada.
Why is she watching a video with this guy who is tacitly encouraging
his audience to call CPS? Do you agree that that's wildly irresponsible
as a creator? To watch a Bad Empanada video? Yeah. Hold on. Let's
go.
Ethan Klein melting down on Alex Novell
4 days.
The conversations you see the straight rate, you know what I'm
talking Mhm. Where Ethan Klein had like a meltdown in this Alex
Novell guy in DMs and then said you can't publish this, by the
way.
And Alex Novell was like, "Okay, bet." Oh my god.
Did he turn it into a lawsuit? Let me see if I can find them
here. You understand two-party consent laws and why I see single-party
consent. Oh, hold on. Hold on. Let's pull this. Uh I gave you
my number because I trusted you, brother, and you you don't have
permission to share this private conversation, either. Just to
prove you to you it's not a gotcha. I wouldn't waste my time
texting you if it was just for a gotcha. Why did he contact this
person or talk to them? He's a total lolcow
who's actually having like a spiral and everybody wanted to make
you feel bad for saying he was having a spiral. Wait, who is
this guy?
Alex Novell? He's the guy who only traps creators into doing
like embarrassing videos for them. That's his entire plat- Okay.
No, he does good videos as well. But he's the guy who like he
got Destiny to talk to him.
Yeah, I know. >> Like the Daily Wire fell for this as well.
Yes, they did. Yes, they did.
>> And you know what? I've seen some of his
his commentary is not even that good.
Okay. Well, he's in the Discord and he's a fan of the channel
he watches sometimes, so you should chill and be
Well, on that note, his commentary sucks. Yeah, I just thought
of different points it wasn't like well substantiated or it was
like a bit soy and I was like, "Okay, if you're going to make
that argument, you can, but you're reaching normies with this
type of content." And to just like launch into that talking point
without any like precursor explanation to it, I just don't think
it like it kind of just seems out of place.
Yeah. Okay. But I am impressed at this this ability to [__]
bait all of these people. Holy
I don't know how he got Dan and
Destiny together. I I just don't know. Yeah, I I literally don't
know.
That rough. And yeah, he keeps getting people somehow. He must
have presented himself as a journalist to Ethan.
I can't think of any other reason why Ethan Klein would have
shared his phone
I don't actually think so. I I don't even I feel like maybe he
replied to a tweet and Ethan reached out to him,
I Dude, Ethan's dumb. I don't want to I don't want to give Roly
this, but Ethan is really dumb, okay? And you just can't select
he's you can't just say he's dumb cuz you don't have a better
answer for something. That's just frustrating to me, okay?
I'm really interested to watch this Joshua Weisman thing that
he has. The Alex Novell guy or somebody else? Yeah, Alex Novell.
Yeah. He's like a food YouTuber that I find kind of annoying.
Only kind of annoying. It's not the worst or anything.
Maybe he's getting exposed.
You think he gave his number to Kephals and he didn't even remember
doing it? I know that Ethan Ethan reaches out to people like
at the drop of a hat. He >> He might have two phones. I
wouldn't be surprised if he has two phones. Like a work phone,
basically.
Maybe, yeah. I see it. >> That not just not not in a vacuum
to watch a bad Empanada video of him making the case for why
the viewer should maybe call CPS. If if I is it a good thing
to
Is it respon- Is it irresponsible is what I said. >> I
think the answer is no. I don't think she should do it. But that's
not But that doesn't Hang on. Because I think that all No, but
the why matters. The why matters. The why >> Wait, I'm
answering that. Did you hear me answering that? I said what when
I >> ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. So, um
Dude, Hutch is crazy work, dude. Crazy work that Hutch is like
Answer that though. Answer that though. When of the two of them
in this conversation, Pisco has not been the one who is not interested
in answering
He actually wants to
dodging liar, bro? Why is he like this? What are you doing, Pisco?
Pisco, come on, man. Come on, man. I don't think it's good because
if you are um you know, watching a video in which these kinds
of uh you know Dude, dude, dude, dude, hold on. Hold on. No.
No. Um >> I missed that. >> because if you are um
you know, watching a video in which these kinds of uh you know,
bad things are being expressed You should just have this little
bit on like a loop in the bottom left corner of your
>> Just all the time. This guy. potentially exactly all
the time. More iconic than the Kelly eating popcorn on a loop.
No. Could be. encourage a risk or something of of something occurring.
But but that Hang on a second. >> Yes. But hang on But
but Hang on But hang on 1 second. You have evidence that Venomss
knew what was in the video before she watched it, yes or no?
I don't know off the top of my head, but So, basically the hypothetical
I was thinking here is
Technically, if you smoke in a
and somebody who's in the restaurant while you're smoking gets
lung cancer, you have some level of culpability, right? for them
getting lung cancer. You probably contributed carcinogens to
them. You've You do it did it knowing full well that that contributes
carcinogens to them. Are you at fault? Would it be accurate to
say you are at fault or you are responsible for giving them cancer?
I asked him
>> Okay. In the first debate that I had with him over like
the ContraPoints or Palestine post where he tried to like ambush
a Ethan Klein debate on me for some reason.
if I like we we were talking about the USAID cuts cuz they love
the libs love bringing out this figure, 14 million dead by 2030
because of the USAID cuts,
I said he was like, "Those people are like going to be killed
or something." Like sometimes they'll use like active language
when it's like to be clear
the real reason why a lot of Democrats are upset about that is
because they were not they that was not constitutional because
it was done via dodge cuts, not only because of the removal of
funds from USAID as a
But I'm like, "Distill it down to its essence. That is just not
as bad." Cuz he was like, "Why don't people care about that more
than they care about the genocide?" And it's like cuz that's
a different rights deprivation. Like that And I asked him like,
"Do you think that people that decline
to donate to like cancer research are responsible for
like like people that die to this to the type of cancer that
they're not donating to because they're abstaining from doing
Is that like equivalent to murder? No. So, that's why people
care more about the genocide cuz you're intentionally killing
people as opposed to like withholding of funds. And like USAID
you know, that's like people people dying as a result of like
lack of access to resources that we could provide
is awful, but it's not as bad as genocide. Yeah, and I think
the be like
Yeah. No, I I get where you're coming from. What did he say?
>> he wouldn't really like He was like, "Oh, I'd have to
think about that." And I'm thinking like, "What is there to think
about?" It's so obvious that like there's a different level of
harm.
But it's like obvious that one is far more egregious like immediately.
It's like basically you're like seven greater than six. And he's
like, "Oh, man, I didn't I I'm going to have to think about that."
And it's like, "No, you don't." You It's like obvious on its
face that it's like a different like it is a less egregious rights
deprivation. You are you're doing something actively that is
increasing deaths versus doing something like refraining from
doing something that possibly if you do it would reduce deaths.
>> Save more. Yeah.
It's like Cuz it's like Yeah, obviously those are totally different.
>> Cuz it's stuff like, "Oh, we're not funding like vaccine
programs." And that leads to more people dying, obviously. Or
like people less people have access to clean water and then it's
like these deaths are attributed to that or whatever. Like the
calculations can be done in different ways, but it's indisputable
that it causes a lot of suffering to not do it. But it was They
also probably wouldn't argue that it's like incumbent upon the
US to have that program in the first place. Yeah, whereas like
basically the way the genocide I I assume the argument would
be that it's an active process to fund Israel
Right? Yeah.
So, yeah, like I can see that USAID cuts is worse though, right?
It depends on what you think it's worse like what part of it
is worse, right?
should the US send money to a regime that is like actively killing
people that most people object to? Like most people object to
the exact kind of killing they're using the funding they're getting
to do.
Most people can object to that like immediately. I'm a little
tired. I'm I'm all over the place. Most people can just say I
don't want my tax dollars to be used for that. But it is way
different, okay? To say
Let's say Israel wanted aid and then you weren't giving them
you hadn't already been giving them aid and they were like, "Some
people are dying there." Would it be bad to say, "No, I don't
have the money for that?" Would that It's like a different thing,
Or it's like for every like empty room in your house that you're
not inviting like a homeless person into, that's you contributing
to like the homelessness
Dude, it's
The two comments we got were, "USAID AID cuts are way worse though,
right?" And then somebody else was like, "Oh, brave tank. Genocide
is worse than a lack of health care." So, they disagree with
each other. That's like a person just meming. But the second
one, don't fall for it. But like the
I mean it I understand like where people are coming from because
it's like Wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. That's like a But
he's he's meming as in he thinks that's a stupid thing to say,
no? Like or it's stupid to pretend that that's not contentious.
It's stupid to pretend that it's not that it's
Like genocide. He's saying that's obvious, no? No, that's not
I know that's literally what's being said, but I know the connotation
of what's being said and that's not what they're saying.
What are they saying then? Explain it. trust me now. The
>> It it's like
I mean some people sometimes I see libs do this as well and it's
like come on, stop it. When you're like in response to that Ukrainian
woman that was killed on the train
people bringing up like if you really cared about reducing suffering
you'd care about like you'd want more gun control or like you'd
care about like getting helping less Americans die of strokes
and promoting like healthier lifestyle habits.
And it's like oh come on, give me a break. You know that that's
not
what's happening there when people have the visceral reaction
to a woman being stabbed in the [__] neck. It's just
easier for people to like empathize and like I'm like like grasp
what's going on like the consequences of something when they
can see it particular to one individual than when you have to
imagine like these huge numbers that it's just it's actually
just so big that they can't it it becomes almost meaningless.
Sure.
I agree with you. I think it it's more than the big numbers and
maybe you said this as well. It's like the disconnect of like
direct causality. Like you have like a chain of causality there.
Which you have to go through like the disconnect like I pay people
buy. That's really easy to understand. The USAID stuff is like
I pay my taxes. It goes into like some
vague aid program that goes to a bunch of different places and
then in some of those cases people get vaccines and they don't
die. By cutting those it's like Yeah. You cut like a big thing
and then people don't see it as like a direct causal thing.
It's like and yeah, I guess research and stuff too would be like
massive there'd be massive research cuts that would lead to deaths
in the future or lead to non-life saving measures being taken
or something. Yeah. The cause the causality thing the non-direct
causality thing I think for the people in a big way. Or they
they >> But it can still be moving because if like I guarantee
if if there's like some New York Times short like 10-minute doc
where they just interview like families affected in some like
like an impoverished family in like a developing country that's
like yeah, my child that was born with this like very unfortunate
congenital condition that like was able to have you know a modest
improvement in their quality of life because of this
Well, they no longer have that so they basically have to be bedridden
because
that they can't get access to like the medication that they needed
to be able to like be pain free and like walk around or whatever,
then people can relate to it more and
even even if they can't understand like how it like how direct
the impact is. You know, like they see the the side effects of
it and they're not comfortable with it or like explaining
like why these heartbeat bills are bad. You know, like what happens
when like women are forced to give birth to fetuses that are
like not viable and they die instantly and like reading the testimonies
of what happens like makes people actually confront like the
results of these policies that were pitched and sold to them
because they only they never actually considered like what happens
if you follow it through. Yeah. Just don't fall asleep.
I'm like I'm actually struggling right now. I'm so sorry. I think
I literally
We're only on the ninth hour. No, no, no, no, we actually I'm
not joking. We can't continue. Like I'm probably going to I'm
probably going to call it right away. Like as in pretty much
right now. We got like an hour in. There's like two and a half
hours left.
Oh yeah. We have no way of finishing at all. No possible way
of finishing this.
And realistically it's just content for
Yeah. If I was live it would have been faster because I would
have been like in the rhythm of like forcing you to do the momentum
but because I'm not live it's it's literally just like yapsity.
Well, I don't mind doing the what do you call it the I don't
mind like talking through stuff and then we had actual debates
happening which is like better anyway. I like I like doing that
way more than anything else. Although now I feel like it got
like content I don't mind things getting contentious. I just
feel like when things get contentious especially somebody I'm
friends with I tend to just like be very conciliatory and then
I don't actually get my points out and then I feel very frustrated
and I feel like it is valid to say that somebody's like kind
of if somebody's going like well, that's the first good argument
you've made. I'm like bro, you don't know what you you just said
you hadn't looked into this. It's actually [__] annoying
to hear
I but whatever. Hopefully it didn't go too badly. Hopefully things
are fine. Isn't that Pisco's stamina? Hold on. Let's go to 9
hours Rob plus Hutch back-to-back. We did 9 hours. 9 hours 16
minutes on the stream top >> Wait, there's no way What's
Pisco's bod? Is it really 9 hours? How long is it? 9 hours. No,
it isn't.
>> Him arguing with Rob for hours. Oh, he did 9 hours?
What the hell was he doing all day?
He argued with Rob for like 4 hours and he argued with Hutch
for like 4 and a half hours. Okay, that's actually impressive
for Pisco cuz dudes usually like unexpectedly tapping out after
like 2 hours and 12 minutes. >> Yeah, but that's cuz he's
talking by himself. If he's arguing with someone I think he can
go forever.
And if he's arguing with Hutch he can really go forever.
Pisco's been addicted to streaming for the past couple weeks.
Uh huh, yeah, I know what that is.
That is I got other things I don't want to deal with. You got
taxes? Taxes due? What is it? It's almost the end of the fiscal
year. Wait, it's not the fiscal year though, is it? It's just
the regular year. That's I I know what that is, okay? You want
to stream a lot? I There's other stuff I don't want to deal with.
GG. Yeah, he has been and he like he wasn't even streaming consistently
before that. What do you mean? Like if you look at if you go
to like his bods or whatever like he was for a minute there I
swear he was really only doing like live and learn or whatever.
He like dropped off the face of the earth. That's why we could
we stopped Just Us Players or like we put it on hiatus because
he was like I'm too overwhelmed with IRL stuff. Damn. I wonder
if he's still doing that. >> a [__] podcast
going on with Connor so it's like okay, I see you Pisco.
Yeah. Man, I hope Connor comes in and tries to argue some of
that. That'd be very funny. I yeah, that would just be very funny.
I hope Connor comes in and tries to argue some of the H3 stuff.
I think that would go very well. I hope you go to sleep soon.
You genuinely
because you like you've seen those studies that show that it's
actually more hazardous for people to drive when they're sleepy
than it is for when they're drunk or it's like basically equivalent,
right? I think right now we're in the territory of like
if you may as well be drunk at this point on stream.
Well, that's like most streams anyway, so what's the problem?
I guess you're
Now, I I am going to end it. Thanks for being here everybody,
okay? Thanks for being here tonight. W e stream. Be back tomorrow.
More content. I think I'll actually do this debate tomorrow probably,
okay?
He hasn't started the black saint yet so he's okay. Just so true.
So so so true.
Let me tell you folks that there are I I'm just going to do the
JF Gar Gary quote and I don't want to do it. Idiots. I can't
I don't know what the JF Gar Gary quote is. He basically says
that I'm going to say something crazy.
I'm going to say something crazy like
oh, I can't even remember. All right. I'll be back tomorrow guys.
Have a good night everybody. Bye.